hello everyone we'll be starting in more
five minutes thank you for joining uh
please take this time to introduce
yourself in the chat box and let us know
about your educational background and
research and trust thank you
a very warm good morning good afternoon
or good evening in whichever part of the
world you are after an incredible and
insightful day one i would like to
welcome you all to day two of comics
research symposia
on day one we heard from speakers on the
academic front we heard and discussed
about vast range of topics from
relevance and integration of comics into
different types of studies including
program genotype phenotype correlations
machine learning to precision medicine
cancer systems biology and different
areas of analysis on t violin pro
platform which included bulk and single
cell transcriptomics and metagenomic
data analysis
today is yet another exciting day as we
will hear from researchers and
professors from different industries and
institutions today we hear about the
application of omics research and
relevance of the field of bioinformatics
from clinical informatics to the future
of geronimics not only this but we also
hear from industry researchers about the
skill sets required for standing out in
the industry and finally we'll hear from
professors and principal investigators
from national association of idea
principal investigators and louisiana
state university about their research
and how students can leverage the
opportunities
now without further ado i would like to
pass on the stage to dr mohit mazumba
director business development i find
biotech to review the topics discussed
on day one and introduce us all to the
topics of day two over to your doctor
moment
hello everyone thank you sunalika
and uh also if you can request
the
listeners to maybe share about
themselves so that
we can also get to know them and uh
get to
maybe work together someday
all right
uh so thank you sunalika again um and uh
hello everyone a wall uh warm welcome to
all of you joining the second day of the
omics research symposium
to though to those who are joining for
the first time
my name is mohit mazumdar and i have a
phd in computational biology and along
with a great team
i'm heading the global business
development and omics logic in asia
in this introductory session we will
start with the recap of day one and it
will it will be also a great opportunity
for those who could not join the
sessions yesterday our team is already
working on the session recordings and
they will be soon available and will be
posted on our social media and youtube
channel so stay tuned and also subscribe
on the youtube channel to get
notification about the videos
so as the nalika already described what
we did and i think we did a lot as i'm
as i was saying that there was so much
to learn yesterday from the experts from
academia and research institutes about
bioinformatics and and its data-driven
uh science and machine learning why
machine learning is hyped and
and we talked about and saw the
application so we learned about
applications we learned from case
studies and discussions on how to be
trained uh how to be trained uh get
trained and
what is the future of this field
so uh
in today's session as i said that we
will start with a recap to so to start
with that uh uh yesterday we had uh mr
malika like always started with the
omics logic global portal and describing
how we see bioinformatics
describing how what are the different
bioinformatics training challenges that
are related to this tremendous growth in
this field enormous computational power
requirements lack of coding knowledge
faculties lacking the
required facilities and uh the structure
so uh sonalika explained how
logic addresses these by standardization
organization and systematization
applying bloom's taxonomy levels seeing
biology as data science and employing
the hybrid learning approach
so followed by which uh the session by
surah alika was followed by the
introduction of hci initiative which i
did and the team responsible for daily
interaction and development of resources
and collaborations across asia pacific
and uh then we discussed about that with
the help of our international
collaborators partners benefiting from
this community and we announced the
partnership program partnership
university program yesterday the
partnership university university
program is designed for the university
partner to benefit from the
collaborative association with pine
biotech and their partners so this
special program is designed by utilizing
the best of resources which are hosted
at learnomexlogic.com
includes the coursework project-based
training for beginners intermediate and
advanced users helping them achieve the
objectives of bioinformatics or omix
logic data science and bioinformatics
research training
the omixlogic partnership program which
we described in much more detail
we described that it follows a unique
curriculum designed for personalized
training and research experience that
enables the participants to develop
critical scientific thinking utilizing
modern bioinformatics and data science
practices on industry relevant problems
so the omixlogic program for university
also follows the in-depth structure
which we went through by looking at one
of the case studies
where we described the different stages
and resources the stages include basic
training example projects and coding
preparing preparing to work on a project
by practicing on various data sets and
algorithms and finally to be able to
work on on your own research project or
a faculty driven project so we piloted
our pro mix logic training with several
universities and we showcased a recent
program as a case study that clearly
highlights the effectiveness and the
impact of the pro of the program
now this case study that we highlighted
yesterday was about the collaboration
and the partnership hello everyone my
name is
there's a video presentation which got
played but what i was saying that this
collaboration and the partnership
allowed students to work on their topics
and interest and do real research on
noble projects which were curated by
mentors and experts
and also as well as for the su for the
students uh for the students uh to
improve their ranking in college and get
an impressive resume that highlights
their achievement
and for those students
such as your aditya
and who has a researched interest to
work on several projects and to
contribute to the scientific community
and as well as
by working hello by working on pressing
challenges that had made the society
dysfunctional such as scored 19 and had
had a huge impact on uh well-being uh
this was said also by dr vishan gupta
the next keynote speaker
who started describing about the
collaboration with ames new delhi
and his work which explained like how
what is the importance of uh indian
cohorts
while studying the kovic 19 or while
doing the government in research and
then kobe 19 which left so many people
dead had no molecular data especially
from the indian cohorts covet patients
have
it it got concluded to the fact that the
covet patients have lung microbiome
dysbiosis the the lung microbiome
distinguishes between
patient types so that's a way to
distinguish between patient types
leading to the suggestion of you know
patient stratification so it was a very
important topic and research that uh was
highlighted by dr ishan gupta followed
by the dr suchin agar who talked about
various courses which are offered by uh
the university uh dy partly university
and discussed genomics transcriptomics
proteomics metabolomics
what is omics what are the branches of
omics and the process of bioinformatics
analysis so there was a lot of emphasis
on
the workflows which showed the basic
tools also like blast eugene mega uh
then finding out variation then find
what do what are the application in the
uh in of genomics and transcriptomics in
different
fields such as molecular medicine
microbial genomics risk assess
assessments uh micro uh bioarchaeology
anthropology uh human migration so this
huge huge application that we learned
that from dna identification to you know
agriculture to live life live stock
livestock breeding and bioprocesses so i
think the application that we learned
from this talk was really helpful and
also the pathways i mean it's very
useful for the students to know about
this and maybe choose a direction
and that was followed by a great talk
again by dr anju bharathwaj who was
talking about genomics and its
application and the current places and
the shape it is taking so she
highlighted about the human genome
project
the global interest to understand human
genome human diseases and understand the
genomic variations what are the single
and nucleotide polymorphisms whatever
what were the candidates genomic
approaches and genome-wide association
studies and the global afford to catalog
the genomic variation she also shared a
lot of resources which i thought would
be would have been very much helpful and
uh as as i said that these sessions will
also be
will also be posted online
then we had that very interesting uh
educational panel discussion where we
discussed about the new educational
policy in india and their the actual
need for data science education and got
to know about from the experts that uh
how we can have data science education
uh being imparted to students through
basic training and a project-based
learning and then we discussed about the
new education policy and how it
encourages the
hybrid learning and what are the
challenges that the universities faced
while doing the hybrid learning and what
are the what are the main
taking away points positive points and
how that has led to a hybrid setting of
education which is very very um
effective
uh then we discussed about some of the
promising areas where bioinformatics is
needed in asia and
india and also with the respect of
academic like standpoints academic uh
experts so job opportunities in academia
and what are the different ways to do
and go about this uh doing a master's or
phd and all of those questions were
answered and discussed in detail in this
session followed by that we had a very
very
interesting poster presentation
competition that covered uh omics and
bioinformatics artificial intelligence
machine learning astrobiology space omix
computational biology and pharmaceutical
industry so students where uh
we're showcasing their work and that
we're from various
backgrounds and from various research
areas and that kind of concluded the
first part of this uh
day one and then we had different panels
after the asia panel we moved to the
african panel and we learned from the
panel where we learned about the
omics logic african programs
partnerships and outcomes discusses by
ayan faye and eddie conley where we
learned about the bioinformatics tools
and resources that have been provided
the data science for biologist program
and then discussion about the discussion
with the panel about all of these
different topics where
we discussed about scaling
bioinformatics education and training
and what are the future opportunities
and how bioinformation is evolving in
africa considering that it has such a
diversity in its genomic makeup
considering the number of infectious
diseases and also the clinical
clinical information that we get from
africa is much more structured than in
india so this is where some of the
things that were highlighted and then
from the african uh panel we moved to
the us panel where uh mr brodsky uh ceo
uh highlighted that what are the
advances in this in enabling
technologies and then how bioinformatics
and these events such as hackathon and
then the understanding of how
bioinformatics is applied in wellness
and health then how to build a team
build an application publish and share
initiatives he discussed about our
initiatives in the us he discussed about
the virtual programs that we did and
also the research fellowship program and
our participation in tech cup leading to
the semi-finalist position and now we
are moving towards that competition in
the next in this coming month
so that was uh the introduction and
start to the us session and we had
follow-up uh important talks on
scientific topics which i think
interested you uh many of you a lot and
though for those who are joining for the
second day
we have many interesting talks and
industry input coming up and i think it
will be another very interesting and
informative day for those who all are
joining so again thank you all for
joining today's session uh we are going
through a recap of what we did
on day one and uh after the indian panel
and after the african panel and the
introduction to the u.s dr nikolai
started who is a senior bioinformatician
at the department of biology university
sweden um talked about the machine
learning view of multiomics data
integration he was discussing about the
multi-ohmic integration across you know
across several features and several
samples he discussed about the hidden
patterns in individual omics and then he
discussed about the curse of
dimensionality and also gave practical
example from from his lab from his work
and
to get an idea and work
and know what they do
that was followed by another interesting
talk which was focused on uh
bioinformatics application so
uh what uh what we imagine for future uh
is these dashboards and these dashboards
will give momentum and proof to be an
excellent instrument for sharing
biological data sets together with
results that is what uh dr julia pinoff
concluded with but she discussed about
dashboard integration a very important
aspect of cloud computing and doing this
um and developing these dashboards which
are like pipelines which get answers
which give answers to specific
biological problems suggest you
discussed about the easy data
visualization and interaction how it
could be shared allow easy navigation
and analysis of different models
exploring ways to add code for r and
python so these are some of the
important aspects she discussed and i
think it was a great session uh followed
by the session by elisa vetta she is the
research associated associate at the
topper research by from topper
bioinformatics research center and she
discussed about the analysis of meta
genomic data on t bind for platform
where uh she described about the crime
tool that used to anna that uses that we
use to analyze and analyze the
metagenomic data and which is now uh
available on and for platform and gave
an overview of metagenomics how can you
upload files how can you run algorithms
and how can you uh design those
pipelines and out get outputs
and then understand by visualization and
again the incorporation of dashboards so
this was from topper tower group
describing about the advancements that
have come up in the tibia info platform
followed by that
we had uh the session which was about
the forensic sciences like how omics is
now used in forensic sciences so sarah
dr sarah
she worked on interdisciplinary forensic
sciences and integration of omics
technology she told us how the future
research will be able to expand on these
current studies hoping for a lead
leading to a wider implication of
performance technology in forensic
sciences we actually discussed about the
application of genomics transcriptomics
proteomics and metabolomics for
forensics and what is str profiling
which is the short tandem repeat
profiling for identity identification of
victims or perpetrators and then what is
foreign dna
phenotyping and then there were a lot of
keywords which were
which would be really interesting for
those who are interested in forensic
sciences and understanding that from
soil microbiome to all this omics data
how it is helping in investigation of
irony hidden india's crimes and
sometimes uh other uh applications as
well
now uh after this initial discussion and
all of the
all of the
uh keynote speakers uh
um
we had lucas um who was an undergraduate
student of statistics and uh his uh
representative of omixlogic team in
latin america uh talked about his
opening remarks in his opening remarks
talked about bioinformatics education in
brazil and introduced introducing the
bioinformatics
training and how we are working on
different courses which are now
translated in portuguese and will be
available and is available for students
who are
more comfortable in the native language
followed by that uh introduction we had
the speaker
of dr louis sokomoto who is who talked
about the precision medicine in brazil
uh so
uh the reality and the trends and he's a
precision medicine patriot he's a
patriotic oncologist described about the
patriotic cancer and frequency in
frequency in children the survival rate
the importance of childhood cancer for
health system and then what are the
molecular classified what are the ways
to do the molecular classification
what are the actionable targets uh using
evidence-based somatic variation and
also shared clinical cases
then uh we had this session about system
biology as sonalika was saying that we
had so many different sessions from
different uh different research areas uh
where dr kasturi kanan who is an
associate professor at translational
molecular pathology
discussed about bioinformatics and
cancer system biology so system biologic
biology initiatives for brain tumor how
there is a unified goal to create a
computational framework to integrate all
available patient centric brain tumor
recurrence data to generate
to generate these hypothesis which is
more unbiased in nature because of the
entire incorporation of data for
actionable target validation and for
predicting diseases outcome for initial
clinical trials
so
all of this was concluded with this
with this panel discussion uh which kind
of uh summarizes that how to apply these
technologies to solve challenges as we
saw in the case of sarah and then from
nikolai from physics to life sciences
how he got fascinated and
by physicians and clinicians to mind
more knowledge and how dr kasturi talked
about his journey and he got curious and
get
self-taught bioinformatics and
talked about what are the skill sets
that are required by students coding
databases and all of the tools that we
are seeing is something that
elia discussed and this was again one of
the sessions where we concluded all of
this and uh we discussed about uh
how interdisciplinary fields are
integrated with multi-homic strategy to
evolve students in bioinformatics and
data science which is the future of uh
future of uh
future of healthcare and well-being so
from this
this was the recap of day one and i hope
that this recap is helpful for those who
who could not join uh yesterday or who
could not complete all the sessions as
we had nine years or nine hours of
intensive uh talks and sessions for uh
students from our global community
joining from india joining from asia
joining from africa
joining from europe and the us and latin
america
so um i'm really excited that we had
such a wonderful wonderful time
yesterday and uh now really hoping that
after this quick recap uh we are back
with yet another day and today we will
hear uh hear about the prospectives of
different researchers and indian
industry experts from us and india and
africa so today
we we kind of highlighted of some of our
collaborators and
industry collaborators many of them
would be
available today to help the
viewers or the participants to learn
about what is what are the advancements
in the are in the industry
how to how do you get into these
different uh careers and what are the
opportunities
combining what we did with an industry
within academia and now learning from an
industry perspective uh is a great great
way to go about uh the
depth of
where this is heading and to you know be
prepared
so
today uh we will listen to our great
panelists who are industry professionals
from nepea as sonalika has already
described what we are going to do and
and gave an overview so nepea and its
network universities and institutions as
well as industry partners such as faba
and bioinformatics companies such as
illusion data as well as engineers
companies such as primary life sciences
to application driven companies such as
on phenomics and eq mine and maintenance
hype who are helping students transition
to industry will be some of the
some of the
the speakers and keynote uh panelists so
let's quickly take a look at what we are
expecting and what what what kind of
sessions that we will be having so we
will have of our first session in in
very in in few minutes perhaps with uh
with dr g sarkar who is a physician
scientist and would be talking about
clinical informatics and use cases and
challenges we are really looking forward
to the session because you would be able
to understand how clinical informatics
is being applied in industry and what
are the opportunities as well similarly
then we go from there to dr shibi uh
shibu chakrabhattikanan who is an
entrepreneur as well as a scientist
working on so many different cancer
therapies almost the cutting-edge
technologies that are being used
worldwide and uh working from uh from
india and bringing some of these
technologies and research in india so it
will be something that will be a great
session for all of those who are
interested in cancer research
then we have dr nidhi quran
from faba who are who are very close
collaborators in india located in
hyderabad and the network
that faber represents all the
biotechnology industry and academia
where she will be talking about uh the
different opportunities that far back
academy is bringing and how our
collaborative work is also helping a lot
of students and also universities to
develop these programs
where they can
you know in where they can kind of
bridge this missing link link between
academy and industry that would help
actually a lot of students transition
from academia to industry
without the struggles that we usually
see students and uh through our own
experience right now after that we have
again a very interesting industry panel
discussion and that industry panel
discussion will focus on some of these
topics that you can see on the screen
that would tell us about the future of
indian healthcare sector how
bioinformatics in industry is different
from academia like uh the questions that
we you would want to ask is that how to
prepare from a from for it for a job
that you have thought of that you have
dreamt of uh of in a company without the
stated experience what are the key
points that recruiters notice in a cv so
there are a lot of opportunities to
learn from these academic experts and
ask your questions and we will be
looking forward to to answer some of
your questions as well as the questions
that we have prepared for the panel
discussion that will be followed by some
of these important skill sets and we
have been discussing about the
participation of industry and the skill
sets so dr rajdev and ketu will be
talking about that and then we have
session from uh miss padilla africa
talking about the
diplomas and cpgr grant program and then
we have the uh like more of a
specialized sessions which is for a
larger audience who are interested in
protein protein interaction and how
these uh grafted peptides are used as
strategy and then bioinformatics in
beauty industry a very um
inspiring kind of a talk and we are
looking forward to learn actually it's
this new for many of us that how
bioinformatics is used in beauty
industry what are the applications and
then uh
learn from speakers from university of
malta about the life science research in
space
so how life sciences research in space
is uh uh being done through
dr joseph bohr who is an associate
professor and principal investigator and
uh also working on single-cell so then
we have the price distribution ceremony
for that from the students who presented
and submitted their posters and then we
have sessions by the nappy uh nippy
founders and neppy
directors so dr guskas phillips director
of the division of biotechnology and
molecular medicine biomed and a renowned
professor of virology will be talking
about
the nappy idea program and
then we have
ilya brodsky who will be also describing
our efforts with nepi network and how
what are the different expectations and
outcomes that we have seen and then we
have some specialized sessions again
which is to understanding of viruses and
microbio microbes so these are for those
students are for those who are
interested in facial disease research
then we have
machine learning uh where all of this uh
research is being utilized further to
develop models to develop uh models that
could be predictive in nature then we
have uh from bench to a computer where
we are discussing about application in
cancer therapy by doctor immunology uh
from the lsu school of veterinary
medicine and then we have the final
discussion from nepi which will conclude
the day two and uh where we will learn
about the different aspects of how to
improve
uh the training that is across 23 states
and puerto rico so i think we are really
really excited for all of these upcoming
sessions and i hope that all of you who
have joined us today and will be joining
us throughout this event uh we'll be
able to learn and we'll be able to ask
and we'll be able to experience uh the
the discussions and the talks from our
uh from our respected experts and uh
dignitaries
so without uh now uh wasting much of
this by discussing what will happen
let's see what will happen and
with that i will like to invite our
first speaker dr jeet sarkar
who is again
a passionate speak
passionate researcher who is mining and
doing biomedical data analysis for
better clinical outcome and has been
contributing by applying knowledge by
doing translational uh research and
finding solutions and multi-omics
analysis as well as uh learning and
applying it for clinical informatics so
over to you um
dr jeet sukkar
thanks mohit
so am i audible
yes yes
so i'll just share my screen
so is my screen
visible
yes
okay so thanks uh thanks moving for the
opportunity to uh
talk on this topic uh so uh as far as we
all know clinical informatics is still
in a very mature stage and considering
the
deficiency of
proper curated structured clinical data
and considering the
impact of this particular field it's
still in a developing scenario so i will
just cover some of the use cases and
some of the models which
which we we have been developing and
which which i have been developing to
address various clinical problems and i
also brief
in these three particular sections so
first i will talk about the solution
categories so what are the possible
categories in which the clinical use
cases can be bucketed followed by a
solution life cycle because clinical
data is rapidly generated and
so the clinical models need to be
rapidly updated and so on and lastly i
will just give a walkthrough of the use
cases of a few use cases
from clinical informatics
so uh starting with my background so i i
have done my mb base almost 6 years back
so by training i am a clinician followed
by
my
expertise in
data science and
mostly building models for metabolic
diseases so that's how i wanted to
combine these two area to
develop these
so
to summarize we can have
so we we have been working i have been
working on
six different type of solutions
so starting with the
left one
so this is the
broad category of predictive analytics
so this is more of a
supervised modeling where there are use
cases like days to get hospitalized
length of state prediction it's a very
important marker for
for
the hospital performance
chronic disease risk prediction and of
course probability prediction so these
are all predictive models where we have
the data and we can do some predictions
next comes the cluster identification
while you can identify disease subtypes
we can identify sub-specialists so today
things are going to a
sub-specialization model that we go for
uh retina specialist we go for
strabismus specialist so this is this is
the domain of the ophthalmologists so
how we can identify these sub specialist
doctors within our domain of
ophthalmologists these clusters can also
be identified from clinical data
we can also identify disease clusters
whether what are the diseases which
which tend to co-occur in a certain
population group of a population of a
certain age
and we can also identify equation
clusters
next we compute time series analysis now
time sleep is a very important
part
given the advent of these variables and
fitbits so it's massive amount of data
generated each and every second and so
because the vital parameters of
human
of human
body are rapidly fluctuating so we can
predict the
the blood pressure or respiratory date
or
so using some time series models so
from the perspective of
hospitals and
health care providers you can also
predict uh fruitful prediction so
because you know there are certain
diseases which are acute and seasonal so
there is the
there is a trend and seasonal uh
seasonal nature of patient coming to the
opd's and clinics so in order to
properly manage the
uh manage the burden of patients and the
doctors so we can also do footfall
prediction and lastly vitals prediction
in icu which is a major because in the
in the intensive care unit there are
lots of parameters constantly measured
almost every minute or even every hour
so those prediction also comes under the
peripheral cancer analysis
next we come to image analysis so it's
very it's a very much emerging field
with last decade where
x-rays and city science and mris and
even even usg these all things can be
automated to a certain certain extent
also for the pathological images with
the
tissue sections this can also be uh
automated to a certain extent
another important part is the
handwritten text analysis this is very
important for healthcare domain
because healthcare still has massive
amount of data
in uh hard hard copy format so digital
formats you don't always get in
countries like in asian countries and in
multiple countries where there has been
not
the healthcare system hasn't yet been
almost
digitized there are plenty of
handwritten texts and scanned pdfs and
all those things and converting them to
digital data and structuring them
cleaning them
then extracting medical entities to get
insights
this is a very big domain in clinical
informatics
and
anything can be a combination of all
these
all these five categories and it will be
a customized model and that model can
also be developed so so clinical
informatics covers this broad range of
offerings of healthcare solutions
so how does a solution life cycle look
like in clinical information so suppose
i work with clients
where customers can come with some
their data or their requirements so
there will be some introduction uh and
meeting for the use cases
and
followed followed by that there will be
some
identification of possible model
solutions for the use cases
then we'll
come the data
exploratory data analysis which is just
to explore the data how it looks to
provide some
basic data in sites
and then to
propose the models now this portion is
the most vital vital part
from data idiot with the best model uh
proposal and this and here there is a
constant iterative process to
look for more suitable models which can
based on solves the clinical question
and lastly and and perhaps the most
important part is the deployment and
integration of these models to the
clinical workflow because the clinical
workflow is already super burdened uh be
anywhere in the world so integration of
a new technology of a new model to the
existing clinical clinical workflow
assigning nurses or physicians to use
that clinical model for their uh
clinical
predictive purpose or assigning a new
person who will do this job on on
on their part
this is a very uh important part and
that's where it also ensures uh
repeated iterative process
where this usability is again and again
tested unless the uh model is properly
fit within the clinical workflow
so now
the use cases so just overview uh
now i will discuss them today about i
just give some examples of supervised
models unsupervised models
graph network models and some time
series models so we can just
build some business insights we can
optimize the cost of expenses of the
hospital
uh
and evolving concept is value-based care
value-based care care means where
that is
every clinical treatment or a clinical
intervention uh is
can be quantified as something valuable
so
the healthcare system is gradually
shifting towards value-based care the
insurance companies in the us and
other countries they are also focusing
on balanced care so
so models can also be used for risk
stratification and then i identifying
high-risk patients
uh
catering uh to them more frequently uh
so so that the
care is more of value and that serves
the purpose of the insurance companies
also clinical insights data labeling
model model validation risk
stratification so these are some use
cases
now an important part is feature
engineering because in clinical domain
you have lots of features and lots of
different types of features so it's a
very
very
mixed type of data set so engineering
those those features to get
proper features which can be fed to the
model
and which and and which will be having a
high predictive value
uh uh identifying those things and
future engineering is a very important
part of clinical informatics
a model selection translational insights
is very important
and so predictive models clustering
models ocr where we can just
scan and extract handwritten nodes image
analysis
some use cases that are here and then
finally the application development iot
management wearable integration and
remote monitoring these are also some uh
some possible use cases
so now
uh
doing a div time so i will just
walk through the
skeleton of a supervised model workflow
just to give an idea of how
the thing can be designed so on the left
you can see the data sources so we are
having
electronic health records we can have
wireless variables medical devices
clinical notes pharmacy records then
regular surveys lab investigations now
these data types are of various
different structures so we we
first of all you have to structure it
and we have to
make it
machine readable so these all deposited
to the to the database so we you also
have to connect
these all these things via suitable
hardware
so that this data is
is ingested and properly curated
on real-time
then comes the data data preparation and
from there you can get certain variables
you can get social demographic variables
you can get comorbid
conditions lifestyle habits self-taken
service real-time building
fighters now each category will be
having multiple
features and those will be fed to the
training data set will be a validation
to develop the model
and now this model can be used uh to
predict as i already told length of
state prediction chronic disease risk
prediction hospital re-admission
prediction
so predicting post of complications
vital parameter prediction and all those
things and the model can be customized
and updated as
the clinical needs and other things and
we can also do some sort of feature
important scoring where we can identify
that these three features or these four
features are the most important for
predicting length of state so maybe
these three features should be the uh
more frequently
monitored features uh for this
particular set of patients so this sort
of model can help us
help us
predict these sort of clinical outcomes
so
for the unsupervised model workflow i i
just presented one use case
so suppose
we had data of ophthalmologists and they
have been treating particular diseases
now all the diseases have some standard
icd goods so if a
ophthalmologist treats and suppose i see
suppose
a disease code like
6
g138 so
number of cases of g138 he or she has
treated
is in a tabular format
now these and the uh all suppose this
all these ophthalmologists will be
clustered uh in an unsupervised manner
and after clustering when we when we
when we saw the visualization what we
found is so that was certain so this
so that there was a difference in the
clusters suppose this blue dots these
were mainly those ophthalmologists who
were catering ocular muscles and eye
movement reflex refraction diseases
this green cluster were those who are
providing only moldy colloid and retinal
diseases
and we found that these green
green physicians were mainly
regenerative specialists and these blue
ones were mainly pediatric ophthalmology
and stabilism specialist so so you can
already identify these
sub-specialists who are particularly
expert expert in a sub-domain of a
particular
ophthalmological domain
now this can be of multiple help so
maybe uh in this case uh so because if
so all of you i guess understand a pca
so a pcm means these blue and these
red
axis they are more or less at a 90
degree so
blue people
don't contribute to a
green one so that means
specialists are
don't get a service for pediatric
ophthalmology and strabismus and the
also the other way around so if i can
identify a specialist who is having both
these skills then that is a very common
very rare combination and those those
persons
can be a sort of a common door
to these sub specialists so these sorts
of business insights and healthcare
insights can also be uh
extracted from these provides
unsupervised model workflows
so next i was talking about the graph 10
network
models so suppose in a population we
know that
people generally in the geriatric
population they suffer from multiple
diseases so the person has diabetes as
well as high potential as well as
dyslipidemia or hypothyroid and other in
these cases so if we could identify that
at which age group and given a gender
what are the
most common co-occurring diseases for
that particular group
if we could find that then given a new
person comes we can just uh provide a
much more personalized
screening program
that so you fall in the category of 60
and you are a male
so and you are having diabetes so in
that case you may be having hypothyroid
and hypertension and eye disease
so you should be screened for these
three or four diseases
so to achieve this what we did we took
the disease conditions of all patients
and we
so
and we calculate the frequencies so the
nodes are the frequencies and if
the two nodes are connected that means
these two diseases
uh tend to occur more frequently in the
population so suppose one person is
diagnosed with
long-term current use of aspirin in that
case there is a good probability of that
person suffering from hyperlipidemia
suffering from insomnia suffering from
primary osteoarthritis suffering from
vitamin d deficiency so this person
should be screened for this
this surrounding five diseases suppose
another person comes with another
particular disease so for that that the
set of nodes will be different so this
will help us to cater a much more
precise and personalized uh
straining health training workflow from
person to person
so in this case we just ah designed it
so just to showcase this thing so these
six these seven diseases are having are
closed related to the long term
use of aspirin so any person coming with
this diagnosis should also be screened
for other these five conditions so there
are already some training protocols in
place where one person having over 40
should be diagnosed who should be
strained for this condition but this
will make things much more precise and
personalized
lastly the time series model which is uh
perhaps the most important or because
it's a very huge data so here you can
see this respiratory rate of one percent
uh
fluctuating which time so every two
seconds uh the reading has been taken
now you can see in this particular
condition there is a huge uh increase of
the respiratory rate
compared to the other uh findings so
here there must be must have some
abnormality or some
exercise outburst or anything
so if we could predict these
uh this hyper
value
from the preceding values then we could
have prevented or alerted the patient
that you might be having an increased
respiratory rate in the coming uh
two or three minutes so be cautious so
these sorts of things are also uh are
are also right now a bit are also right
now a bit more um
hypothetical and uh these are being
tried by people to model but this is how
the use case looks like so here we can
apply something called change point
algorithm so what it what what it does
is it takes the entire stretch and
breaks the stretch into certain uh
certain slices
and
for this slice the mean standard
deviation is
different from this slice having a
different mean and
mean a standard deviation so we can so
we can identify this abnormal slice
where the mean and sd is
significantly different from the
preceding as well as the succeeding
areas and in this case there's one
problem is data has to be real time uh
synchronized and analyzed so uh that is
a different problem it's more of an
engineering problem and in that case we
can also set parameters and rules that
if the value is over this certain thing
then give a alert and we can also build
data driven insights that if the data
tells that the person is going to have
an increased respiratory rate or
heartbeat then please alert the patient
and the surrounding
physician doctor ambulance and all those
things
so uh just lastly coming to the end of
my talk i will just briefly give
overview of how end-to-end workflow for
chronic disease may look like so we can
just
get the data the data acquisition from
the wearables and medical devices we can
do the data prep feature engineering
model building clinical decision support
which will be validated with the
physicians and lastly we can use that
thing to
produce automated alerts
so as to
help predict abnormal events
help recognize skipped medicine doses so
if somebody is having a abnormally
increasing blood pressure then we should
check that whether the person has
skipped his or his
medicine for the last one week or what
is the compliance and that can also be
put in as an alert to the person and to
the concerned caregiver
for mental health it's a very important
topic coming up and
predicting
suicides predicting depression
attacks and panic attacks
uh manic phase prediction in
bipolar disorder and for this that the
data source is much more
much more comprehensive clinical data
genomic data vocal expression data
because the vocal expression how the
person is talking about the phone that
changes
and the facial expression changes social
media and regular survey all these
things can be structured and
fit into the model and accordingly we
can do prediction it's it's definitely
very
critical
there are certain ethical issues and
lots of legal issues but this is the
this is the one direction in which
mental health is also going to proceed
towards
so i just end my talk here and i'll just
take any questions for the last
five or seven minutes thank you
thank you so much dr jeet for this
wonderful wonderful talk where we
learned about a lot of
application or driven
how can you how the industry is looking
at the problems and
finding solutions for what what the
students have learned i guess is also
the same and i i think that we have some
questions so
are there any questions from this from
the participants
austria
[Music]
i think some personality is uh
putting it in the chat so let me read it
out for you um dr sirkar so uh what are
the possible career options for people
pursuing bioinformatics in
bioinformatics and clinical informatics
okay so
so biometrics mainly consists of uh
till now uh genomics transcriptomics uh
proteomics metabolomics and
maybe metagenomics so uh
a lot of these
these omics approaches and the data
generated from them
uh this is going to be used for coupled
with clinical trial data
and with clinical prediction so the
thing is not
so mature right now because as i told
there is a certain
lack of bridge between healthcare
providers and bioinformatics
but this is whether
so there are companies who are trying to
and trying to integrate omics data with
clinical trial and clinical
clinical
outcome data and those are really big
big short
things which are coming up so if
somebody can have the skill set of
bioinformatics and
is having the um
orientation to apply that in clinical
care and clinical trial data
that would be a great uh great uh career
in the coming days
almost a day or still i i hope
all right and that's that's i think that
is helpful uh
next there is a question by dr chitra
tamal
he's asking that graph theory can
identify the group of closely related
diseases
uh can we predict which will come
earlier
okay so uh so i guess
graph theory uh so in graph networks
there are also temporal graph networks
so
if we can build temporal graph networks
uh
in that case we can't do predict but i
will tell one thing
the major problem is with data so uh
so suppose a person is having four
diseases so hypertension diabetes and
hypothyroid and dyslipidemia so what is
the particular chronology of this
disease is something very tough to and
discipline the person has gone for uh a
clinical visit got tested with diabetes
and then also found that he is suffering
from hypertension but whether
hypertension came before or diabetes
that is a very difficult thing to
comment for a real world patient but
this should be something which should
also be right and given we can have
longitudinal data
from a certain age where disease doesn't
set in and we are having
annual checkups then we can have those
data and temporal graph networks can
really identify this
sequence of
diseases
yes all right
thank you thank you so much for that
answer one last question uh rissy m west
longer she's asking uh thank you doc for
a great presentation uh could you shed
some light on your work with metabolic
disorders
okay so uh my work was mainly on type 2
diabetes so now as you know type 2
diabetes is known to be a obesity driven
disease that people who are obese tend
to have
diabetes more but
as you may know that there is a there
are certain studies coming up which tell
that type diabetes can also occur in
so-called non-obvious persons now
those non-obese persons may have some
increased visceral fat lower muscle mass
that's a different discussion but why
why do these non-obese type 2 persons
also become diabetic because these
persons
they contribute to over 50 percent of
the indian population so in india over
50 percent of
type 2 diabetes patients are having a
low body mass index a body mass index
less than 25
so my study was mainly to explore the
underlying pathophysiology and i covered
that so i studied the uh adipose tissue
of non-obese and obvious diabetic
persons uh
biologically and uh cells using using
cell biology and i studied
terminological datasets and also
clinical records so that there are
multiple uh multiple
levels of the entire thesis and you can
find it on research gate or just by
searching me on google scholar citation
and you can just
have a good uh understanding
all right
okay thank you so much uh dr sarkar for
this wonderful presentation as well as
for answering the questions and as we
are
on a short
short time so we will be able to share
with you some more questions as they
come over over the email and i hope that
you will get the opportunity to respond
to some of those
sure sure thanks thanks thanks
thank you thank you so much again now uh
moving to the next uh session i think we
learned about some of the aspects that
dr sarkar just uh discussed we learned
about finding uh meaning out of
biomedical data and leveraging them for
better clinic better clinical outcomes
uh as you learned about the omics data
you know either genomics transcriptomics
proteomics such data types and how can
they be used for different clinical
outcomes now um i would want to uh go
further with this
and
now we have the next session which
which is uh
which is focused on uh
cancer uh research so we have dr shibi
khannan along with us dr shibi
chakravarti khannan who is the ceo of
oncophenomics
um just a second sorry about the slide
deck
yeah
so uh let me introduce dr khannan first
uh so that i uh so that we can learn
what he's going to talk about so dr khan
is an entrepreneur and a physician and
scientist and now also computational
biologists and we have been fortunate
enough to have several of these
discussions with dr cannon and learned
so much about translational cancer
research and its application in india
and i think it's a great opportunity for
the audience and for everyone who is
here today to learn from his and his
experience where his focus of work was
cancer genomics and
utilizing different sequencing platforms
for immuno oncology for drug discovery
and development that led to uh cancer
immunotherapy and developing those
protocols for cancer immunotherapy and
uh there are so many different keywords
that are associated with what is going
on with the uh with precision oncology
and all of that so
it's it's really we are very excited to
learn by by you dr shivikan chakravarti
and anything anywhere anyone getting
ready for the future of genomics over to
you sir
yeah
thank you
can you guys see my screen
yes yes
okay thanks thanks muhit for the
wonderful introduction so basically
anything anyone anywhere is basically
from nanopur's official website so you
can see here so let me go to the
beginning
i also have a presentation so i wanted
this to be a more interactive session i
don't want to bore the people
you know so if you are an ngs next
generation sequencing whether you are on
the vet lab site or on the
bioinformatics side uh when people say
ngs what do you think about you always
think about illumina
and iron current and other shortly
technologies but the world is changing
the world of genomics is changing
at a very fast pace so we started
adopting nanopore technology around 2017
2018 when the technology was still at a
very early stage and a lot of people
used to say oh nanopore is not good it's
only for research it doesn't have the
accuracy does not meet the level of
accuracy of illumina but that's not true
anymore so it's a fast evolving and fast
developing technology
uh maybe i'll make the screen a little
bit bigger so that you guys can see yeah
so
i want to give some a taste of what's
what's coming in the near future so and
i'm not i'm not alone uh i am part of a
huge community of nanoproducers more
than 30 000 laboratories across the
world have adopted nanopore primarily
for studying microbiome uh bacteria
yeast fungi virus and very recently
during the covet pandemic nanopro came
as a very big
solution uh to for real-time genomic
surveillance of how the virus is
mutating very fast and spreading all
over the
world and all the countries started
using uh so the adoption real adoption
of nanocore technology happened during
the pandemic so that's something
illumina would not have done that
because of it's a it's a capex heavy
equipment you need to invest millions of
dollars to have an ngs facility but
nanopores like they have different small
small instruments for big instruments so
here they show uh let me just scroll a
little bit so here you can see the range
starting from a flonal or smidgeon all
the way to the minions the gridiron and
then we have the prometheon so they have
the complete range and nanopore is one
technology uh you don't you're not tied
to the lab so you can literally take it
in wherever you go so people have done
it or even done sequencing in a space in
a space station and they're done in
remote corners of the world you know so
there's a lot of information available
on the website
so
as a broad spectrum uh what is the main
use of this technology uh just like any
other ngs technology it has a very uh
multiple use cases most common uh how
nanopart became very popular is
metagenomics especially when you have
they have this what's what's in my part
analysis i give you a tube i go to
colors of environmental samples or some
bacterial samples or some i take a
sample from poultry form or i go to
himalayas and take a sample of the water
right so what's in my pot can you tell
me what's inside that uh tube uh that
colorless liquids that's the
metagenomics is the most important and
most popular use case and then of course
there's agri genomics and then because
of the long reads uh you're able to have
n50 the context we have like we are not
limited by the lens whereas an illumina
there's always a size limits like 143 in
our base pest so here there's no limit
so you can have very very long reads we
have seen in our lab minimum of 1.5 kb
to 40 kb fragments with very good
overlaps so it becomes very easy when
you want to uh do adeno sequencing and
align and map the genome
and of course the most common use case
is the studying the bacteria the virus
and now recently a lot of work is being
done on human human genome that's what
we come in so we primarily focus on uh
cancer diagnostics and we do something
called the comprehensive genomic
profiling in our lab so we also look at
the tissue biopsy and we also do the
liquid bypassing so nanopro technology
has been used uh since the beginning in
our lab earlier we used to
do some comparisons with illumina data
and ion torrent data but now the
accuracy has improved a lot so we no
longer do this orthogonal validations we
just go direct with nanophone because we
are confident we are able to find the
mutations very easily
there are several unique advantages with
nanopore of course you can see there are
so many laundry technologies that is
packed by you and so many other guys
like high ic bio nano almost every week
we see a new company pops up right so we
have singular genomics and so many new
companies coming into the space it's
very popular and then we have the mgi
which is a clone of illumina but they do
it in a different way and they do have
some unique advantages it's more
affordable compared to the aluminum uh
but generally entire ngs world separated
into short-range technologies long-range
technologies among the wrong laundry
technologies packed by your nanopore are
the leaders unfortunately pacquiao is
too expensive so the per sample cost is
as is 300
uh sometimes every 100 gb of coverage
it's more than three thousand dollars
for a small library like us on most
developing countries uh this pricing is
not affordable unless you are a
university project you have some grant
money right uh so for clinical use it's
not making sense uh so we have been very
happy with nanakul uh the per gb cost is
as low as 30 30 dollars so it's not
backwards 300 years 32 so it's literally
uh one is to 10 kind of ratio so i don't
think anybody can beat nanopore on the
on the pricing side
the other major important advantage in
nanopore is
it's a real real time sequence so in
illumina it's like a one week long
pipeline both the wet lab and
bioinformatics three days for the
wetland minimum and another two three
days for the bioinformatics so if i get
a sample on a monday i can give a report
on a friday or saturday sometimes you
know some holidays comes or something
happens some delays happen sometimes it
may take longer than a week uh seven to
ten days that's why most ngs
laboratories and genomic service protest
they don't give a turnaround time less
than three weeks they give typically
three to four weeks but in nanopore i
can do it the same day i start from the
morning do the dna isolation do the
library trip in the afternoon by evening
i can load the sample so this is this
picture you can see the the minion
device which is a most affordable device
anybody interested in genomics they can
start buying this the instrument comes
free of cost you're basically paying for
the flows of the reagents uh the startup
cost is only like five thousand dollars
it's very very very very low low economy
uh anybody can start wearing sequences
anything anywhere and anyone you don't
have to be a ngs expert and uh it's kind
of you know the kids comes with
excellent protocols uh both on the web
lab side also on the biometric side they
do provide a software online cloud-based
software for the data analysis
especially if you're doing meta genomics
projects it's one of the easiest to
start start with the rapid barcoding
game and you can start doing
metagenomics in the lab every day it's
very easy to auto so
we have made a mission
uh to help everybody to adopt nanocore
technology of course right so if you are
interested call me i will help you set
up the lab i'll help you with onboarding
you know so we we have a team of people
who can support you so we don't want
anything in return we just we just want
people to start using nanopart
technology target illumina those are the
dinosaurs of the past right let's move
on to the future that's why i said
getting ready for the future of genomics
the way we see it the next 10 years
long-range technologies are here to stay
and more and more competition comes and
the price is going to come down and it
could be as low as nine dollars per gb
uh so in ngs you always go with the per
gb cost right so that's it's making a
lot of economical sense especially for
emerging markets like india africa south
america asia pacific
everywhere you know you can do it and uh
again the time taken is just a 24 hour
to 48 hours uh maximum you can do you
can completely max out the floors within
72 hours but that's a huge advantage
that on real time as soon as the data is
being captured it's up to the server and
you can continuously monitor the data
within six hours for example covered
virus we can do it in within six hours
we can actually tell you what variant
difference they have a very nice
protocol of course you'll have data in
the first 30 minutes itself but we wait
for four to six hours to get some
confidence on the very visited delta
variant or we crown even if it's an
omega not a sub variant so we can do all
that so we have an abl lab we do covet
testing also and we also do that for our
search purposes under icmr guidelines we
also look for variants because we have a
mrna vaccine project
where we use nanopore extensively so
without nanakula i don't know can we
even do this kind of work you know so uh
kind of the time the time turnaround
time or the time it takes to develop the
data
so it's a very simple uh prepare your
samples then sequence and analyze three
step process you know
let me quickly walk you through uh the
three main products so you can see
minion
uh it's starting from thousand dollars
you know so it's a starter packs
actually five thousand dollars when you
add the kids and the agents and you can
see grid ions starting from 50k
and promethean they have two two kind of
offers it's actually a two tk instrument
but you can go for the p2 uh which is
more affordable so if you are a
university lab or a commercial lab and
you want best of both worlds there's a
difference between the mania and flow
cells and the promethean phosphorus so i
would recommend go with the gradient
gradient gives you five fluorescence and
the p2 so you have two prometheans so
you will have the flexibility of using
both menial cells under chromatin
process depending on what type of data
your customer wants right so and here
you can see in the product
specifications what can we do with
nanopro
everything you can do in illumina you
can do with nanopore
it's not like you know only illumina is
good at smps and genotyping we can do
snp deduction dynamo in fact it's a lot
better uh homo polymer detection is also
very high and recently people have done
benchmarking studies they have been
natural publications many publications
illumina vessels nanopore versus back
bio they have done the neck to neck
comparisons with known samples and
nanopore has come out as a clear winner
uh there's a there's a page i'm not open
that uh there's a page that talks about
the accuracy and uh base level accuracy
and also at the genome level and the
chromosome level accuracies and nanopur
always comes at a huge winner and at a
very affordable process like like a
superior technology at a more affordable
cost another big advantage in nanopro is
the methylation so no other technology
gives his advantage of both genetics and
epigenetics on the same run on the same
experiment imagine if i have to do
illumina
ngs i have to for example illuminate a
company called grail they have done
liquid biopsy for multi-cancer early
detection they have to do they have to
split the dna sample into two vials one
wire goes for normal uh variant calling
pipeline dna mutations another while
goes for the epigenetics the bisulfide
sequencing so they have to split it now
what is the ratio the proportions did it
is pretty exactly equally complete of
the event so the sampling bias comes in
the picture but in nanoproduction are
splitted the entire sample run is run
through the same native barcoding
protocol and you get this raw data the
raw data can be analyzed in two
different pipelines so splitting happens
at the bioinformatics level not at the
vet lab level so so there is no sampling
bias the same sample you get base
modification especially the methylation
so that is the
one of the main reasons many people are
now switching over from aluminum from
bisulfate sequencing switching over to
nanopore is because of the methylation
detection another huge advantage
especially for cancer research we not
only look for small mutations we look
for big mutations the anything more than
50 base pair called the structural
variance sv detection and also have to
take facing so this is something not
many people know this
uh people report egfr mutations for
example the cis and trans so depends on
let's say i have two types of mutations
or la-58r sensitivity crossing mutation
or t-summon dm which is a resistance
crossing mutation if these two mutations
come on the same strand of the dna then
the resistance biomarker overtakes the
sensitivity biomarker but if they come
on the opposite strands then the patient
is still sensitive to tk so this has
some direct implications in tyrosine
kinase inhibitors uh so we got the
company diagnostics like drugs like
airload and name j fitness and all these
pkis tyrosine kinase inhibitors which
target the egfr keras or b ref very
important to know the system trans how
can we do that you have to do hypertech
phasing you have to know if my cluster
of mutations are they coming on the same
strand of dna are they coming at the
opposite styles of dna so haplotype
facing is coming up in a big way in
cancer research and another hot area is
the transplantation medicine so where
you have to do xyla typing if you're
going for bone marrow transplantation so
cancer patients leukemia lymphoma so
many patients they go for bmd also
hematopoietic stem cell transplantation
so
typically they go with relatives some
matched donors sometimes today donors
are very difficult to get you don't have
siblings you don't have any family
members to give you bone marrow then you
go for matched unrelated donors nude in
a mud
case which is more common nowadays what
we do is something called haploid
identical that means a hundred percent
is not a match but fifty percent match
but the fifty percent match is on the
same strand of dna so haploid identical
uh so recently there was a natural
publication where they show there are
twenty one double grinders for every
every person walking on this planet
earth 21 people in this planet who are
exactly like you
they also look like you they also have a
similar genome you know the facial
features and everything so it's very
interesting people so
finding an unrelated unmatched donor at
the haploid is becoming more and more
easier nowadays so this is truly
revolutionized uh transplantation
medicine that's where hl typing uh on
entire actually alleles the mhc class
one cluster locally very easy to do on
the nanopart platform and again in agri
genomics and plant genomics wherever
when you're working on new species you
don't have a reference genome and now we
have the pan and human genome pan genome
project and we also have the r.1 and so
many other projects so assembly is dino
assembly right so this is the the key so
highly recommend uh go to the nanopore
website nanoprotect.com
and click on the resource center
on the resources so here you will find
all the latest videos and stuff and let
me quickly walk you through the
community so anybody can have a free
account and here you can see i am logged
in i'm in the dashboard and you can see
there's a huge community active
discussions are going on also you have
all the new releases software downloads
and you can check the protocols you know
it's very easy to getting started with
nanopore now you can you have all the
protocols here and for different
different kids it's very easy uh it's a
lot more simpler than illumina if you're
coming from illumina
it will be a delightful experience uh
working with nanopro and they have
different products for example
extraction protocols are you starting
from dna or starting from rna what is
your material like they make it very
easy you know there's also a protocol
builder which can basically walk you
through the different sample types and
what type of validations you want to do
so you can see tissue cell culture
fluids whole organism agarose blood
environmental ffbe stu you're not limit
there's no limit any sample type and
then depending on the organism so they
have different protocols they want one
for memory and one for plant like that
so pick the protocol that you need and
follow that to the line don't change
anything it is guaranteed to work you
know that much i can i can tell you uh
i'll just quickly show you this video
[Music]
so ah let me go a little bit back so
here so this is the flow cell
okay so
you see this small area here uh this is
where we drop the sample so it's very
simple and we just there's a small we
have to open that spot on that lid and
then put drop drop drop and then it goes
inside so it's basically like
electrolytic chamber so there is an
upper chamber and lower chamber and then
there's a asic chip on which the
nanoprocessor being embedded it's
basically a protein nanopole and once
the dna goes inside it's basically
threaded threading through the nanoproof
so then the a6 are reading the critical
signals which the software will
interpret that's where the base quality
comes so this is the time baseballing
can happen so you can monitor the data
in real time and once you exhaust the
dna in the top you can basically stop it
and this is as part of the library this
is what you're doing so this is your dna
sample and what you're doing is
basically you're attaching this motor
protein on the adapter sequence
and here you can see these are these are
the a6 chambers the surroundings are the
membranes on which the nanopros are
embedded so there's a 2040 membrane
wells each containing at least one
sometimes it may contain more than one
uh but typically now that the
optimization has happened a lot you'll
only find one nanopore per uh sometimes
the nanopore is not fully fully formed
maybe it's broken you do find a few
channels by time you receive a few
channels the protein has denatured or it
has folded it's not working uh but
majority of them 70 80 percent still
work so even though you're guaranteed
2048 force by then you receive it during
the shipping and logistics you may not
get 2048 so they say uh minimum 1500 or
1700 is covered under guarantee if it is
lower than that then they will replace
the leave your brand new flowchart you
know so
uh so nobody gets 100 capacity that's
something that you need to consider you
know
[Music]
okay so this is the important steps you
can see this tether is going to catch
this right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
okay so this is how it works so
basically when the dna is being threaded
there's a disruption in the ionic
current which is detected
earlier i used to think it is threading
one base at a time but that's not
correct it's actually trading four to
five bases at a time and different poles
have different
speed limits and depending on the speed
the faster it goes the lesser the
accuracy the slower it goes the higher
the accuracy so it all depends on you
want a
structural variance a bigger i don't i'm
not caring about snps or single
nucleotides i only look at large things
then you can go faster but if you're
doing varying detection you're looking
at
single nucleotide base level things then
you have to go slower
okay so i think you've got the picture
so let me open
uh
the presentation
uh i'll just quickly show you
so
why we call it as the the future
of genomics right
uh so illumina has been there for a long
time illumina and other guys iron
torrent they haven't done much
innovations
this it's the same technology they had
20 years ago they still keep selling the
same things again and again but nanopro
comes up with a lot of new information
almost every year so they have this huge
conference called london calling every
year so this is these slides are taken
from the
plenary lectures uh from the london
college 2022 i'll just pick some
important slides in that
uh so the first is you know you look you
can look at the evolution of the
technology from 20 2017 2018
so they had the millions the gradients
and then then they launched the flanges
because some people said banana is too
expensive
for a smaller libraries then they came
up with the smaller ones which only has
126 channels the mineon has 512
times four so you have 2048 and the
promethean has 3000. so promethean has a
bigger capacity if you are doing a plant
genomics project lenovo sequencing you
are depending on the size of your uh
samples uh how big the genome is how
much coverage if you want 100 gb to 300
gb kind of coverage then you have to go
with the brokerage
and again the accuracy has improved a
lot since 2017 2018 now in 2022 uh we
are already at a very advanced level
that
the every technology has its own uh you
know product development life cycle and
uh it's already at a very very at one
stage i'm not sure how much more new
things they can introduce they already
introduced so much new things uh this is
at the pinnacle of i know it's uh it's
everything that we have hoped for
and uh earlier it was called r 9.4 now
it's 10.4 the r10 series has clearly
clearly have a huge huge performance
update how because mainly you can see in
this graph so you have this different uh
the basis per second bps uh you know so
used to be 520 then 400 and 216. so the
slower it goes
uh the more accuracy the software is
able to regain my so basically it is
artificial intelligence uh running
behind the scenes so we used to have
algebra at the beginning then we have
guppy so they guppy there are different
versions uh so always use this always
check the version we install the latest
copy when you analyze the data and we
highly recommend the mineon mk1c which
comes with the screen it has an onboard
gpu and one terabyte storage uh the
regular minions they have a temperature
problem if you keep it in a normal room
i had this
problem uh we we have like five six
millions lying around in the lab
so there's too much heat uh creates a
problem especially in india
so i recommend go with the minion mk1c
uh which is a same similar costing no
big difference plus you have the
advantage of a very good thermostat
it controls the temperature very well uh
the minions the standalone minions don't
have that option
then if you want if you have the budget
go for a grid right so that's that's
something
and now the the good news is it's
backwards compatible so if you have the
older online process well accuracy is
not an issue for your data you can still
work with that and they're also forwards
competitive so you can basically use any
kind of floor cells
on the different ways to run on the
prometheans you can run uh single
samples you can run you don't have to if
you have p24 or p48 no need to put all
24 at the same time you can just run two
or three chromosome fluorescents at a
time you have lot of flexibility uh
especially if you're doing human genome
we recommend minimum like two or three
maybe up to five five is a lot uh but
two to three is fine people have done
very promising you know like for here
you can see matt loses you know more
than 170 gb uh as data has been
generated from the new kit 14 uh which
is currently running at 400 bps right so
so the new kit 14 chemistry the kit 12
came then the kit 14 has come
so it's early access so the existing
current users can get access to this
people who are interested in in the
accuracy
and they've done a lot of improvements
on the motor and the motor adapters and
also the chemistry that's what's
happening in the kit 14. so this is
currently now available many have so
initially they launched they'll say it
is early access but after wait for a
couple of months it will be available in
the regular store so i highly recommend
if you're looking for accuracy go for
k40 if you're looking at structural
variants under log large promotional
kind of things or metagenomics but you
don't need to get 14 you can go with the
kid 12 or the older kids also not a
problem
the more interesting part here is uh if
you have the greater iron or permit and
the bigger instruments
now i have a like like a tuning i can i
can increase the speed i can decrease
the speed how fast the dna is being
threaded this is not possible in any
other technology this in in nanopore and
i can literally control uh the accuracy
the synthetic they have shown the data
for simplex agency and the duplex
accuracy so it's a tunable run settings
notice never this is like you know like
like a science fiction like a dream come
true you know
depending on the kind of uh and then
that's i i forgot to keep on slide
there's another another very interesting
feature in nanopore called adaptive
sampling today if you do like illumina
you know you everything is amplitudes
you need to design primers you have to
make the pcr
products you have to amplify certain
regions of the dna right and then you
have to sequence it uh but adaptive
sequencing is like no need for ampling
amplifiers nothing in the software we
program these are the regions let's say
i'm working on chromosome 8. chromosome
8 is my interest i'll give the reference
genome for chromosome 8
as one of the uproar file formats uh so
i'm doing a whole genome project i'm
literally putting an entire whole genome
of the human dna in the sample
but the when dna is being threaded the
software will identify okay this does
not belong to chromosome 8 it will
reject it it will spit it out it's
called you know adaptive sampling and
when the dna the next strand goes inside
it says oh this looks like chromosomal
i'm going to continue sequencing so i
don't need
why do you need applicants
just go with adaptive sampling the only
challenge there is you will not get
hundreds of gbs of data because you are
getting rid of 90 of the unwanted dna
you are focusing on the
highly focused dna but then you are
looking at the dna in the native
conformation with the base modifications
you are not uh changing it same same
with rna another huge plus point in
nanopore is the direct rna sequence so
there's so many features in narrowboard
once you start uh learning about that
they say man why are we still doing
illumina
or any of the shorter technologies
once you go into nanopore world you
never come back
you know so again uh for a long time
nanopart used to be just a single rates
so now they're introducing the duplex
feature the kits are not yet available
it's coming soon
so this is how the duplex lead works
so basically what it does it's it's
stretch one one half of the dna first
but then there's a connector link and
then it goes to the other end same like
how you now works but they have done
some modifications in that to avoid the
ib infringement with the illumina
and now we have this uh three major uh
pose so we have three major flow cells
so we have the r9 series we have the r10
series and then the new new rx series
the r11 12 length and something will
come with that in the new series
currently the r names and rpms are
available 9.4.1 and 10.4.1
we have completely started using 9
series we are now using the 10.4.1
this is giving very good accuracy for us
and we are able to get uh you know like
a complete whole genome coverage uh at a
3x to 30x and adaptive sampling of those
500 genes something like foundation
medicine or cotton health the
comprehensive genomics there are 500
genes which are important in in cancer
so we are doing adaptive sampling for
those 5 agencies focus on people
and this is some some data represented
about homopolymer accuracy it's very
nice
and also you know like at the rarity
that you'll see theoretical maximum
output in 72 hours how much you can
generate you know
and then where are where are we now so
we are now with ramora so ramora is the
latest for the methylation and here are
some some examples you can see the
precision and accuracy uh it's already
it's giving the best bang for your bug
compared to bisulfate sequencing so if
you are into methylation uh nanopore is
the best option for you right now you
know you could do both genomics and
division like something
last line
yes so we'll take questions
thank you dr shebi for this wonderful
uh overview and understanding of the
nano pro technology and uh there is also
there was also a comparison so uh for
for our users and viewers i think uh
many of our users and viewers have been
uh students and faculty and uh for
students i think um
one of the things that have been
a gap or perhaps many of the
biotechnologists and biochemistry
students
would want to know much about how the
data is generated so i'm just
summarizing that this has been really
helpful for those who would want to know
how the data is generated and what is
the industry standards because many
times especially with faculties who are
also working and want to conduct
experiments are kind of outsourcing this
to the industry this sequencing work to
the industry and then they're getting
reports and then they are
learning about uh what is the possible
insights that they can gain from the
data however like having an in-depth
understanding from this session is going
to be very much helpful in designing the
experiments and even like before
designing uh hypothesizing the
experiments so thank you so much dr khan
and for this uh insightful talk and we
started from clinical informatics by dr
jeet sarkar and then we learned about
how the data is being generated and then
uh what we want to uh know also there
are some questions so let me read that
out to you uh so keeping uh so one
question that i'll read now is keeping
some of the limitations of nanopore
technology in mind in your perspective
what are some of the ways the technology
can be further improved in the future so
where do you see that uh the future with
nanopower technology how they can evolve
further from this yes
yes so like i said the base calling
algorithm can keep on improving so one
of the huge advantages in nanopore
uh we have done some some sequencing way
back in 2018 that raw data are still
lying around
every time they release a new version of
guppy on it on the new version of all
the software medical removal on
everything i can go back and re-analyze
the raw data i get i can retrieve more
information so that's the that's the
beauty of nanoproof uh because the base
calling algorithm is improving its runs
on artificial intelligence behind the
scenes the more training dataset you use
to train this algorithm the better it
becomes right it also opens up the
possibility let's say you are working on
a very unique kind of project which
nobody has done everybody is working on
model organisms let's say your organism
let's say you are a diabetes
professional working on gila monster we
don't have a reference you know pervilla
monster or the komodo dragon for example
right but the saliva has the the
diabetes treatment so you're working on
that you don't have a reference you're
completely doing something from out of
the stretch i take monkey box for
example right and nobody has built a
monkey box reference to you and you are
the first guy doing it so then you can
basically train your own uh algorithm so
the software gives you that uh that
ability
uh to train based on your own training
data set you have like a gigabytes of
data lying around in your in your
software database in your hard disk you
can train it and you can customize it
especially on the i highly recommend
there's one talk from one of the
nanocore team members they talk about
how to customize uh albacore or guppy or
remora for your your particular lab
scenario and i also highly recommend ap
to me labs uh this is a tutorial website
so they have plenty of tutorials
and you can see uh they have different
different uh versions also released and
they have a [ __ ]
share this one in the chat so there was
a question
next question was
like a full guide or these tutorials i
think this is the question yeah so all
students go to labs.dp2me dot io and you
have plenty of tutorials you know let me
let me click on one of them
and uh you can see the first start with
the installation right so you need to
install docker to access the server so
you can just install it on your desktop
and then start with the basic stuff like
introduction to fastq the vcf file if
you're interested in variant calling the
bam file phosphate do the basic qc
tutorial start with this and then here
you have uh adaptive sampling and if you
are into plunge in the next do the
assembly highly recommend you do the
metagenomics the epitome sequencing uh
sixteen s analysis
uh also they have other other examples
also for example if you're in covid
biology highly recommend the source coe
do analysis uh so let me just open it
quickly i'll show you
so basically if you're familiar with
jupiter notebooks uh so this is how it
looks so right now it's a static
page but once you connect docker and you
have the b2b labs up and running uh i
can click on any of this code chunks and
hit enter the code will run so now it's
just a static html page so here we'll
have like instructions followed by chunk
of code so it's very easy to follow
these tutorials especially if you're new
to working in a command line uh so
jupyter notebooks if you are if you are
into bioinformatics you need to know
jupyter notebooks
that's something i recommend everybody
get familiar with working with jupiter
thank you thank you so much dr kanan and
i'm just looking at the website i'll
share it with our audience and uh i
think we are out of running out of time
and thank you so much for your
participation in this keynote session
and helping all of the uh listeners with
uh the advancements and
the technology so i we will be able to
share with you some of the questions
that are still there
and now
from as i was saying that from clinical
informatics to understanding about the
data and its application now we have our
next keynote speaker amongst us dr nidhi
and a close colleague and uh i'm a head
for academic coordinator at faba
universe academy so dr kurana is
currently the head for uh academic
coordinator with faba academy which is
aimed at imparting industry relevant
skills to the life science students so
besides being a molecular biologist by
training she is also a life science
mentor and has mentored over 200 more
plus students till now for career
building in the life science sector so
uh
with that i would like to invite dr
karana uh hello nidhi
yes hi hi mobet
uh i'm sure you guys are having a great
day and uh congratulations first of all
for this event
and thank you so much for introducing me
to the audience
um
okay so shall we get started
yes
great um before i get started everybody
um i would love to know my audience so
and i would also appreciate if we can be
as interactive as possible so let me
start by asking all of you your
uh you know the current status uh like
your educational qualification
uh your stream
it would be nice to know your background
like in terms of where you come from as
an um educational qualification you know
your msc phd uh please type in the chat
box i would love to see some answers
because you know my talk is about
um finding that missing link between
academia and industry
people are talking about
uh that the gap in academia industry so
what is that gap
and what should we do as professionals
and as students you know to fill that
gap to make a bright future for
ourselves
so do we have an interactive audience
here my first question
uh let me know phd wow thank you jodi
for answering
i am expecting a few more answers
everybody
are you bse masters okay msc
bioinformatics students bachelor's of
pharmacy
very nice thank you tiffany rupa dipia
great well by technology phd msc biodeg
psc
great phd beginning
uh
glad to know receive msc genomics and
precision medicine
okay
that's an interesting mix of audios that
you have uh you know ranging from
undergraduates still phds
and um
researcher okay so i will now share my
screen and you can keep answering the
chat box
um
let me share
okay
can you all see my screen
give me a thumbs up
great
all right everybody
so
the you know that gap that i talked
about between academia and industry it
is hurting the entire ecosystem the
entire uh ecosystem of life sciences
industry why
because on one end the companies
complain
that you know they cannot hire fresh
graduates or you know inexperienced
people because they do not they're not
adequately skilled
and on the other hand the complaint by
the students from the students is that
you know companies do not hire them and
so there's a misconception around number
of job opportunities
or uh you know the training the number
of
training courses that can enhance their
skills
so there's some kind of a missing uh
link there
so my talk is going to focus on
what are the expectations of the
industry and what is academia based on
my observations what is academia
currently doing okay to help the
students make that transition
but before i delve into all of this
let me start by
uh you know a common expectation
from uh but that we have from ourselves
when we enter into college you know that
first day of college after um after our
school
and
what do you have in mind when you join
your college you know the expected uh
professional part by the students looks
something like this you know you ought
to complete your graduation or post
graduation
uh and then you apply for jobs
uh you are expected you expect yourself
to get a job
and then you perform well you get
promoted and then you know live the life
you desire so tell me at least i had
this uh expect when i joined the college
i would love to know from you after your
bsc msc phd whatever course you're doing
what is your professional expectation
from you does it align with what is what
you're looking at the screen right now
yes or no give me a thumbs up
do you expect to get a job from
whatever you're learning in your
institution
isn't that the sole purpose
to find a career for yourself
yes or no guys
okay
great
so
exactly most of you are saying yes that
is the expectation you know
but
do you think that this expectation is
being fulfilled just
in that manner that you
are thinking about it
so the reality is
the student completes graduation of post
graduation degree program
then they apply for jobs
and then what do you see
you know struggle to get hired
maybe you know most of you may have also
experienced it if you actually
you have tried applying for jobs uh you
do not hear from organizations for
interviews you send out your cvs to
hundreds of jobs but you know you know
uh you do not get back with any reply
you're told that you do not have the
required skill sets to work in the life
sciences industry
and
maybe if you get an interview
you you turn down because again as a
as a fresher you're told that you do not
have relevant experience
you know
who how many of you actually relate to
either of this scenario here
andy here says no jobs even after
masters in life sciences
um
so
you know i i do not want to comment on
that right now because there are jobs
andy i can assure you that but it's just
the approach and because nobody's
preparing us to approach for those jobs
so that is why we are not taking the
right steps at the right time to really
benefit from the opportunity
so here the reality that
you know that i have shown you on the
slide it resonates with most of you
and this is what my observation after
talking to you know 500 plus students in
groups on personal basis
most of you come up with this scenario
so do you see a problem here with our
expectation from academic institutions
and basically the outcome of the entire
scenario
we expect
our institutions our colleges our
universities
to prepare us to build a career in life
sciences
but somewhere something is missing
because after we complete our education
from that college or university we
actually end up
struggling to get a job
right
so
what is that missing link what does the
industry tell most of the time to the
candidates who approach them for a job
that you do not have the adequate skill
sets and i'm sure and after talking to a
lot of students out there life sciences
students our academic institutions do
not even you know uh lay enough emphasis
on the term skill sets you know enough
so most of you or you know if i have an
intelligent audience here good because
most of the students who i have talked
about they are not even aware of the
term skill sets the term skill sets
confuse them so let me just you know
give a brief um insight into what a
skill set is
it is actually the knowledge the ability
or experience needed to perform a job it
could be any job guys it could be r d it
could be management it could be you know
accounting so based on the skill sets
that you have worked on and you know
you're working on to hone them with your
everyday practice or your experience or
your exposure
you develop these skill sets which you
can use for the for your job later in
the future okay
so
in terms of skill sets also people talk
about two kinds of skill sets one is
soft skills it's basically nothing but
your personality on the whole how you
react personally to your surrounding in
various aspects
but this another um so
academic institutions do contribute
towards improving your soft skills uh
but most of the work should be done by
you
when it comes to hard skills
these skills are actually quantifiable
and teachable and they include the
specific technical knowledge and
abilities required for a job
so they are technique oriented
and it is the hard skills that the
academic institutions or we expect uh
the uh the institutions to prepare us
when we you know go for college go for a
course to prepare us in terms of hard
skills so that when we approach for a
job at a company we are not turned down
because of lack of adequate skill set
so here now i would like to point out
various um
you know these are all my observations
and how what is academia focusing on
instead of actually preparing you for a
career in life sciences
so academia
focuses on completing the syllabus and
giving good cgpas to the students let me
know in the chat box if you agree to
these points or not i would love to see
your answers
see we have an educational curriculum to
follow okay and academia restricts
itself to that curriculum
but what do i mean by giving good cgpas
actually most of us come from the
background where you know during our
school times your toppers if you you're
among the top then we really you know um
you know our parents take pride uh in us
and uh we really make everybody proud
our teachers our family and everybody
so we have this mindset that when we
enter college that is the sole
requirement by a candidate to get a good
cgba
most of us think when we entered into
our bachelor's program that having good
cgpa is what is going to get us a very
good job
but how many of you really know the
example of people who are doing great in
their career but did not have the good
cgp back in the day
it's actually not about the cgpa cgpa
absolutely matters because that is where
your basic understanding of the subject
is coming from
however
you need to implement
the techniques the subject knowledge
that you're acquiring
okay and put it in practical aspects so
what matters is exposure
so having cgpa is important but you need
to move beyond cgpa to literally build
on that career for yourself
second point
academia actually teaches about
applications i'm not saying uh in our
colleges we've never
had uh you know we never knew the
applications of any technique that we
were starting but the restriction here
is to teach about applications of a
technique but only theoretically
you know uh for example rdp recombinant
dna technology how many of you answered
the question you know where rdt is used
on a paper
as a part of your answer and listed the
applications on the answer and that's it
you did it to score good marks
how many of you literally
delve into the detail of the application
of rdd in solving real life problems
which companies
you know with solutions are um you know
uh they're favored by rdt
so it's only theoretically that the
focus is uh fixed on
the third aspect is actually all the
basic and advanced knowledge of the
topics are covered but
you know how these are implemented to
find a solution
or create a product is not emphasized
upon
let me know you know you are allowed to
uh give your views here with respect to
the points that i am putting up guys so
when we study about any topic during our
college yes we study about its basics
yes we study about advanced but
what we fail to study is the
implementation of the technology to
really find a solution or how using the
technology a product is created in real
life scenario
right so that is where the gap is in
understanding the entire
um operations behind life sciences
industry
another
academia actually thinks
industrial visits are enough to teach
students about
how the work happens in an industry
so let me know while i was you know uh
putting up this point uh this
i mean i was laughing to myself but
actually that's true in my msc also i
had an industrial visit and i i'm sure
your universities also most of the
places they arrange these industrial
visits to understand you know to give
you a sense of how industry works but is
that what is required
what does it even do
for like a five hours or six hour visit
what does it how does it help a student
but
colleges do it and basically they should
do something more than that to really
help the students understand the entire
scenario of life sciences industry
another point they do not educate the
students about the concepts of skills
that's required in the industry as i've
emphasized upon it earlier that you know
the term skill sets how to build on them
how to really analyze your strengths and
weaknesses to develop those skill sets
for you so that you really enjoy what
you do going forward
is completely lacking
and then
the ironically
very few institutes try to place their
students after their graduation but the
entire process of those placements that
occur for life sciences student is
hollow
it does not have any meaning and does
not help the students much in their
career building guys now that's the
truth you like it or not
most of you how many of you literally
continue with the job that you know that
you're placed after
your college does that even align with
your strengths and weaknesses does that
give you a sense of uh you know whether
you are built for the job or not whether
you're going to enjoy it or not nothing
there's no preparation behind that
uh scenario
so
academia does a lot
there are a lot of points here but i
think the way it executes this thing
needs to have more meaning to it
let me know if you agree to me or not
here give me a thumbs up if we are
aligned on this uh um you know at this
magnitude so give me a yes or no if you
really connect to what i'm talking here
on the other hand guys i need you to
focus on
what the industry wants
okay till now we actually saw what
academia is providing us in terms of
preparing us for career building and
life sciences but what does what is it
that the industry wants
so everything is based on the
applications of the techniques in the
industry
okay we have talked to many people from
far by itself we conduct many panel
discussions we are going to one-on-one
personal meetings with with the industry
leaders to understand the gap you know
so everything in industry is based on
applications of the techniques
industry is actually product or solution
centric
okay
it seeks individuals who understand the
basics and applications of the
techniques used in the company
when they say that you do not have the
adequate skill set what do they imply
so for example they're looking for
somebody who uh they're looking for
somebody who knows about the use of
hpl's okay now if you're someone who's
used hplc before you
fit right into their uh pocket but the
thing is if you are not very well
acquainted with hplc if you do not know
how to handle the equipment if you do
not know
uh you know how to work with it how to
generate data with it how to interpret
its data or troubleshoot the experiments
that are performed with that experiment
then
you know you cannot add value to that
job
and industries look when they go through
your resumings when they go through your
profiles what you're looking at they're
looking at various ways how you can add
value to them how you can help them grow
and that is where this lack of a skill
set is coming in
our educational curriculum is too much
focused on providing us basic and
subjective knowledge when it comes to
practical it's mostly restricted to
whatever we learn in the laboratories
but that does not do justice to what is
required in real time at industry level
okay so industry six individuals who
know how to handle the equipment can
generate and interpret the data and most
importantly is able to troubleshoot
experiments sometimes industry would
employ somebody who would not have a
hands-on experience of hplc so there is
this another factor when you are
interviewing for that position or you
are
you know telling about yourself to that
recruiter potential recruiter
it's more about your attitude your uh
you know if you would not have had the
hands-on experience on hplc but you
should know what hplc is what is its
principle
what is the uh you know uh the insights
behind generating data from it how does
it help uh their projects you know
like why do you use hplc so at least
these are the aspects you need to know
and then as a pressure having hands on
or no having hands on can be tackled at
some level
okay so for that only you know there was
this one um
a statement in the chat box which said
that there are no
not enough job opportunities after
embassies so there are guys okay it's
just that we need to approach them in
the right manner and life sciences
students actually need to put in a
little bit more effort as compared to
the other streams engineering i.t
computer science anything
because they have been established from
a very long time ago in this in this
scenario and for life sciences uh
students mostly the path
uh you know till now has been bsc msc
phd postdoc and then becoming a
professor
right but now you see a lot of companies
you see a lot of uh industry uh you know
organizations that are coming up with
projects with healthcare projects with
life sciences biotech pharma you know
it's always been there and now it's time
to open up our minds also to explore
these opportunities
but life sciences students need an extra
push an extra nudge to really approach
those opportunities in this case
so
now we know what industry wants from us
and how academia is not able to
uh provide us that kind of training
here i have actually put up a snapshot
for you about
the typical academics labels that we
have so this is a general uh some of the
general topics that all of us find in
our syllabus beta mse biotech
microbiobiochemistry
and then below i actually have industry
skill requirements
so you see in our academic syllabus we
have these big terms you know
bioinformatics genomics and proteomics
bioentrepreneurship
nanobiotechnology
bioprocessing engineering and
fermentation technology
these are actually industry relevant
subjects or topics
the problem is how the activia teaches
us about these subjects
for examples genomics and proteomics or
bioinformatics
if you really think academia was doing
enough to really you know impart that
skill to us which was industry relevant
then
an organization like omits logics okay
which is doing great work in this
scenario would have had no meaning
but you know mixed logic you are
attending this webinar you are a part of
their courses you know what they teach
how they teach how nicely project
oriented they are
you know so case studies
are important you need to work on real
life problems to really understand how
bioinformatics or genomics or proteomics
or nano biotechnology is helping you
find a solution
that is what is needed okay
when it comes to industry skill
requirements i want you to see the
difference so industry skill
requirements are advanced technical
concepts in molecular biology in vitro
assays and vivo models
pre-clinical drug discovery and
development
biocitric biopharmaceutical production
and analysis you know facets of industry
r d focusing on product development and
correlation between functions
industry focuses on physiology
pharmacology toxicology and regulatory
studies you tell me which of these
topics are covered in the academic
syllabus in a way that we should be
prepared to get a job right after our
degree
like like legible guys negligible
so
here is the gap when i say that skill
set is the missing link between academia
and industry what i mean is this
okay
going forward
what needs to change to really have a
positive effect on this entire scenario
what academia can do at their level to
really help the students build their
uh career
in life sciences industry
is starting right at the bachelor's
level there should be mandatory
industrial internships and preferably
for three months why do you say this you
know so uh one day um from farmer we
were organizing this workshop on drug
discovery and development and you know
um
basically the our partner from the
he randomly said that you know in our
curriculum uh the the students start
taking internships from the very first
year of their bachelor's so they're you
know in the u.s the bachelor's is like
four years so by the time they complete
four years they have an exposure of
working in four different industries at
four different roles
and so that is why when they graduate
they actually feel ready
to perform in the industry
okay you are no longer lost because
you've had prior four times experience
of reflecting what you like what you
don't like what are these various job
opportunities how i can perform best in
this particular role you know
uh you know having been connected to
people at four different places you have
built a community and network for
yourself so strong that after four years
after those four um internships you are
actually connected to people who can
help you get the job
that's what networking is
and that's what skilling looks like
another thing that the colleges can uh
you know uh
ponder upon is empowering the culture of
working on projects based on real life
problems to add to the students
experience
and foster entrepreneurship
right now you know these colleges have
these plate replacement cells and
entrepreneurship
departments and sell
but the thing is some active a proactive
approach needs to be taken to empower a
culture where the students are uh you
know they are required to team up to
work on real life problems to find a
solution at their level there could be
many solutions to one problem everybody
and so when you do that you actually get
real-time hands-on experience and you
foster that mindset of entrepreneurship
the solution centric mindset
another thing exposure to the pilot
scale manufacturing projects and quality
control studies for students should be
conducted by collaborating with startups
or industries to impart industry
relevant skills
you know college also needs to educate
them about careers outside academia and
the necessary skills that each of those
careers require
because it is also important to
understand that research and development
is not the only option after your
bachelor's master's or phd everybody you
do have different roles where you can
outperform by your skill sets by your uh
you know likings and disliking by
reflecting by building on your strengths
and considering your weaknesses you can
go for other careers other than research
and development it's not mandatory as a
master student to really just go for
research after your
you know after getting the degree
so
college needs to educate them about
various career opportunities and how to
prepare for them by telling them that
this particular job requires these
strengths and if you're a person who has
those strengths go for that job you know
so
the last thing the least that the
college can do is encourage the students
to build their career based on the
strengths and weaknesses rather than
following the hurt just what i just
mentioned
so over here guys let me know in the
chat box that are you with me here or do
you have any contradictory comment or
your point of view or your perspective
about this
so because i think that this is where
the gap lies this is how the academic
institutions need to act upon to really
uh build uh you know that mindset to
really build experience to really give
the confidence to the students for
career building and life sciences
going forward now this is a scenario
that that was a scenario that academic
uh you know institution need to uh do at
their level but
that's i don't know how far that is from
uh practicing so what you can do at your
level guys so considering what the
industry wants from you considering
the limited amount of work that the
academia can put in preparing you for
getting jobs it is your responsibility
to take proactive steps in these areas
that are shown here
so what you can do to make your
transition smoother from academia to
industry go for internships everybody
you know go for internships
at least once a
year while you're doing that internship
reflect on your strengths or build your
experience around it okay you need to
reflect on your strengths if you're
liking it if you're disliking it or if
you know if you need to consider that on
an everyday uh basis would you be
enjoying this role that you are a part
of right now
because having an internship gives you
gives you a lot of exposure
that is required to really build that
fulfilling career going ahead
second is focus focus focus on
networking online and offline i cannot
say it enough and i don't know if you're
following me on linkedin most of my
course they focus on this particular
point networking as life sciences
students nobody uh talks about it nobody
encourages us for it and so whenever we
talk to uh people when whenever we talk
to the students obviously i'm not a
conversationalist you do not need to be
a conversationalist to actually network
network is when you connect with people
when you deliver value when you take you
know help them and take their help and
build a community for yourself
so work on it when i say online and
offline i'm talking about platforms like
linkedin and offline i'm talking about
conferences symposiums your class your
seniors your professors
make full use of conferences and
symposiums
talk to people
you know you should go prepared when you
go for a conference so that you know you
you over the targeted approach
then you build connections reach out to
your alma mater reach out to your
professors
you know the entire strategy can really
help you find that job for yourself it
can easily get you hired if you start
with the strategy at a very at the right
time
it is not late for anybody guys
okay but if you start at
a younger level then you actually have
ample amount of time to build around
this
so the last is increase your visibility
talk to people let them know you exist
until you tell them you exist how are
they going to find out that you know you
are some person who is strong at this
and may be perfect for this job so if
you increase your visibility if you talk
to people around if you network right if
you approach people and build
connections
there is no reason or there is no
scenario that you cannot get hired
so these are some things that you can do
at your level to really bridge the gap
and make your transition smooth from
academia to industry
so guys um i'll just take last two to
three minutes to
tell you how faba academy is helping in
this space
so to educate the students and support
the students as they explore and further
understand themselves in the career
options and to gain valuable experience
power academy was launched in 2020 and
what we do is we conduct webinars which
are career oriented we conduct these
workshops which uh upskill the
participants uh in industry relevant
skill sets uh which gives them better
career growth so just uh giving us just
about who
is faba academy for so it has a lot to
offer to every kind of domain of life
sciences sector graduates and post
graduates ph.d postdocs and industry
professionals faculty everybody
uh so our strengths are we have
upskilled actually 400 plus participants
including early career professionals our
speakers are you know for these
workshops are invited from india and
abroad to give you really
wholesome uh you know exposure about the
advancements that are happening in
technologies the career opportunities
that are coming up in this field
and so these are some of the workshops
that we have conducted like drug
discovery and development basis of
chromatography techniques um hands-on
training on dna fingerprinting biosafety
biosecurity upstream and downstream
technologies of biologics and biosimilar
and we do conduct workshops in
collaboration with omixlogix also
just like this we did last year
biomedical data science and drug
discovery and drug discovery development
this year so um now we're moving on to
doing more hands-on workshop because
until uh you know 2021 it was more like
virtual but when you gain these extra
skill sets which are industrially
relevant you are actually um equipping
yourself with uh those adequate skills
that the industry is looking for
so with this guys though these are some
of the webinars that we have conducted
um you know for example rnai
technologies and career opportunities
this was about next generation
sequencing and this was about science
communication you know rewrite it your
strengths to become a science
communicator we invite the experts from
india and abroad their ceos they are
doing outperforming uh themselves in
their field so they bring their own
wisdom and experience to teach you about
these aspects
um this is about the one of the upcoming
webinars with dr gautham das who is the
co-founder and managing partner of my
biome therapeutics and it is on 8th
september i would love for you to
explore
this opportunity and register for this
webinars our webinars are free of cost
and so
you
be a part of it and gain some value out
of it so guys with this thank you so
much um i would love to answer some
questions if you have and let me know
if there is any way that i can help you
with it thank you very much
thank you so much man that was indeed a
very interesting talk and we have a
bunch of questions to ask but as we are
running out of time i would email you
these questions and i hope it would be
fine if you could answer them and we'll
get back to the participants
thank you thank you so much
thank you so much now once again for the
wonderful talk
and now that we know what is the right
kind of skill set that is required for
industrial research how can someone
acquire these
what kind of internships or job
opportunities should one look for in
such scenarios so now we would be
starting with our academic panel
discussion and i would like to welcome
our academic panelists dr kalyani karla
dr shibi and dr sunari khandra dr
kalyani owns a phd in biology history
and is a mentor adventist high and dr
sonali holds a phd in cancer biology and
she's the ceo of kiki minds
thank you sunalika and uh
hello everyone uh we are now heading
towards the
uh industry panel discussion and uh i
think uh what nidhi
did was like uh to give us this amazing
platform
uh with her energetic talk and nidhi as
you are also a part of this panel and if
you can also join in so
that
that was a great
discussion and we covered like a lot of
points that we were hoping to discuss
and uh actually that makes sense now to
uh go into this next
session which is to discuss some of the
opportunities that are there and also uh
to summarize some of the points that we
have uh that we have put together let me
share my
uh my uh
presentation
so uh we kind of uh we've been
discussing here for since yesterday
about how the academic research is
shaping up in india we have had great uh
experts a great lesson and also
participants from all around the globe
listening from the experts about how
their research has influenced plus what
they see that how like bioinformatics
can be a part and can be integrated into
several ways and the pathways
for students to learn about it and uh to
maybe transition to
the to the industry by having those
understanding of those hard hard skills
that nidhi was talking about but um we
would want to start with this discussion
that uh as an
industry as an entrepreneur as a leader
how do you see this
industry evolving and that brings me to
my like next slide which is like uh
this recent report
about the
healthcare being reinvented in india and
the numbers around it and the different
areas where
the the the survey sees that there is a
huge application and hence the
opportunity so uh again like uh you know
about make in india programs uh from
indian soil that have nurtured much of
these biotech programs but somehow it
remains nascent so what is then the
solution like uh there are tech parks
and i know the one that had opened up
and hyderabad and sonali has been part
of it so like industrial collaborations
silicon valley like ecosystems so uh i
mean with that question and with that
note i would want to maybe go to sunali
first and start a discussion about this
current situation and
where are we and where do you see that
where are the opportunities
for the future of indian healthcare
sector and also for those students who
are now freshers and who are
listening for the first time about
something like this
hi
good evening everyone am i audible
yes yes
okay thank you thanks thanks a lot mohit
for giving this opportunity uh really
i'm so glad uh sharing uh you know my
evening talking
to all the other along with all the
other panelists and it's really a great
platform and the work what you guys are
doing uh educating young uh you know
individuals and and all uh talents uh
and of course you know giving them
a path or the direction moving forward
next what's happening in the industry so
that's that's really commendable because
at least if i remember uh 10 years back
there were no one to show us the path so
so i would say that you know
you guys are really doing good job for
the next uh you know the millennial or
the or the future scientist
so yeah coming back to the investment in
this space and the the the industry
itself how it is going and i think um
you know
i can take my own example and by the the
whole opportunity we have seen and we
have invested in this space and we have
you know uh and that the whole genesis
of ikey minds happen so just for the
people who are not aware uh you know i
come from uh life sciences background
have my phd postdoc in that but of
course always
felt the gap and and always felt that
there was you know the missing uh things
uh which was definitely you know
bringing more technology into it and um
then i worked with a couple of you know
uh
tech uh startups uh some vc firms to
understand you know how the whole space
moving in this like the medic space how
the investments are coming and how the
business model should be built because
when you're a researcher you just focus
on the science you have never been
allowed to even look at the business
part of it right like how to actually
take the whole science to the market i
think that's the most saddest part of it
because you know as a researcher you
don't really look at who's going to use
it who's who's who's my customer
you don't use this word at all who's the
customer who's the user you just do your
research right so so i think
that's the whole change in your mindset
your perspective when you come to you
know the industry and you look at who's
going to use this and when you know that
who's going to use this your entire
perspective towards building it
completely changes because you know
there's a person there's a
there's a patient or there's a user
who's going to directly use my product
or my services so your perspective
change you know this is no more just for
you know
mice or rat or for animals you you're
going to really change people's life
you're going to change you're going to
touch humans right so that's that's a
huge change uh which you see you know
from your academic industry but coming
back to your question yes and then we
started you know bringing more uh
questioning more like how how we can
bridge this gap between you know uh
people who come from life sciences have
no understanding of technology and on
the other hand people who are tech who
are really good you know coding skills
and and techies but they don't
understand the domain so so how do we
bring these two worlds and when i was a
triple i t i was heading the innovation
center we had amazing startups you know
uh but all they were like tech people
they have absolutely no they jump into
startups you know kind of you know
trying to solve what what is required
and what is the admits need in
healthcare but the challenge was because
they don't come from domain it's always
tech first
tech first kind of you know approach but
that's how it it doesn't work that way
because it has to be a problem
first approach like what's the demand
what is the challenge right and then you
try and solve that problem using
technology so so it's always the other
way
but i think the missing thing was you
know having that that interdisciplinary
knowledge and and kind of you know uh
awareness that you you come from the
domain but you also know what kind of
technology can be used to help these
people or or to solve this challenge
so that's the opportunity we saw and of
course uh you know that's whole uh was
the genesis of ikey minds where we you
know it's it's basically a bio id or or
a tech led healthcare company a life
sciences company very very very focused
on you know bringing these two worlds
together and and try and see how we can
you know
basically leverage the the talent and
and
bridge and basically skill them to the
next level of job which is required
which is which is demanding and what
kind of you know uh uh skill sets are
required in the in the industry and
that's that's what we are doing coming
back to the investment uh in this space
it's it's really incredible at this
point of time in fact when i just
started i kind of got a couple of calls
from vcs and messages that you know they
want to they want to invest but that
time we had just the seed fund so i was
like i was so happy to see that yes
invest investors are looking at this
space quite you know
i mean they are seeing the future of
return on investment on this phase which
wasn't the case a decade back life
sciences has been always a very riskier
space to invest in if you look at the
other space like fintech you know
there's a huge investment been pumped up
in last one or two decade but nothing
has been really happened on the health
tech or the life sciences side but now
what i've seen is like there are there
are very focused uh vcs has come in
angels have come in who are you know
advocating who are brand ambassadoring
who are really interested in spending on
this uh space and i think we we all have
seen that you know post code the way
things have changed the adoptions have
come and if you just look at the number
of startups in fact before this
i was just you know trying to figure out
some numbers and i was amazed to see
like there are almost 5 000 plus health
tech startups are born you know in in
india on the on the health care and
health tech side so that itself suggests
that you know how people are trying to
get into the space invest in the space
and and of course you know um for
freshers i would say
please open your ears and eyes and then
you know look at the opportunity and
just just sky is the limit in this space
yeah thanks
[Music]
that makes sense i i think uh with all
of that your experience and uh the
points that you have mentioned which is
like uh i would say
for an entrepreneur or person who is
thinking about to do something with it
like startups and all
um the interdisciplinary nature of
this
field is
kind of
something that requires them to know
about so general awareness i think uh
awareness about investments awareness
about technology awareness about what is
happening in the fields around it and
what are the innovations these are some
of the very important aspects someone
who is diving into this and thinking
about to like you know do this and again
like another point that we discussed
about that having a prior experience or
doing these internships where
where the startups are working uh
actually could help a lot of people a
lot of these students to overcome uh to
understand the challenges for say for
example first-hand challenges so i think
uh great
value there uh to this to to address
this question and if uh
dr khannan can maybe add something to it
like how does he see because uh dr khan
you are working on the frontiers of
oncology research and using these new
technologies so how do you see this
market and how do you see that how what
kind of opportunities because what is
happening also is that like these uh
these specialized skill sets are
something that the post docs are getting
an exposure in the u.s so how do
students in india get exposed to
those cutting-edge technologies that are
that you are working on and there is a
scope of you know capacity and intake of
such
thank you
that's a that's a very good point uh so
if you live in us if you are a student
in a university either a phd or a post
child
you frequently go away almost every
weekend we used to have fridays and
saturdays we used to have like
institution-wide meetings where you
interact with everybody
also we we get to travel we get to so in
oncology we go to three main conferences
uh american society
society for foreign unconscious ascot
and aacr uh so if you're a basic science
guy
or doing some kind of product when you
go to acr if you're a clinician you go
to asco and if you have a hematology
then you go to ash so and then if you
live in europe you go to esmo
so i had the opportunity of attending
all these uh conferences when i was in
u.s 10 years every year we used to go
all the meetings the university used to
sponsor my my pa used to sponsor one
thing i really missed after coming back
to india
that physical presence of attending
these meetings is not happening because
it's too expensive right first you have
to travel then you have to book the
flight tickets you have to get the hotel
and all that stuff and then there's a
conference registration thing but one
good thing happened in the pandemic you
know they say uh every crisis comes with
some lot of bad things but also some
good things the good thing that happened
many of these conferences are now online
and virtual events have become the the
main stage right now we are in a virtual
event
no need to travel no need to spend money
and
you still have to pay certain
conferences they still charge you for
the rich which i don't understand they
still charge your registration fee but
it's a lot more economical than actually
physically traveling so highly encourage
uh the student community here
uh in your area of domain of expertise
follow these institutions these
organizations like we follow acr and uh
follow them on twitter only green so as
soon as the event is announced
immediately register so during this
meeting i just registered for a mit boot
camp that's specifically for healthcare
entrepreneurship
so it just took me five five minutes
when i was listening to sonali i was
just filling up the form on mit bootcamp
website so it doesn't take much time and
what i do is uh whenever i see some
notifications whenever i receive some
good websites i highly recommend every
every organization whether it's a
for-profit or a non-profit uh they
advertise the webinars and cme events
for clinicians uh webinars are very
common nowadays and they also have all
these global events like the 11 calling
event i was talking about i have been
attending london calling virtually since
2019 i i haven't i've been london once
or twice but i didn't get the
opportunity to attend the live
nanocore conference all the nanopore
community meetings london calling
everything i'm attending virtually the
good thing about nanocore they they have
the video section in the resources page
uh where you can watch all the videos uh
so you can also if you register you
attend in live you can also interact
with the audience interact with the
speakers uh also you can interact with
the with that staff members you can ask
all your doubts so like that many
companies do that uh so that's something
an opportunity even if you miss the live
session but i still register even if i
cannot attend all the meetings i will
get a recorded session they email me
they get a recorded session uh you know
you can you can watch it in your free
time so subscribe to newsletters any
zoom link you see any conference any
webinar click the up click the register
button now
right that's the way that's the way to
stay connected because once you leave
academia and come to industry uh
nobody's uh nobody's keeping you up to
date right it's you have to take your
own initiatives uh to learn what's going
on in the rest of the world especially
for
people who are in india and other
emerging economies
who don't have access to travel
something happening in san diego
something happening in chicago obviously
i can't travel now the embassy is closed
uh they're not issuing visas for at
least one more year so it's a huge
backlog so but the same meetings are
available virtually
even if they charge a thousand dollars
or two thousand dollars i would say it's
totally worth it registered for the
meetings because
one thing you get access to all the
abstracts all the all the plenary
symposiums and everything plus you will
also
get the contacts the networking so most
of the time i'm not even listening to
the speakers i'm actually in the chat
box
talking to people you know on networking
so i highly encourage these three
strategies subscription to newsletters
attend as many webinars as possible and
when you attend a real live session uh
try to network with attendees so here we
have like more than 70 people in the
group so try to interact with them uh
direct message there uh don't declutter
the
the common group uh do direct message to
the person you want to talk to so that's
my that's my three main takeaways uh
from this virtual meetings
that's how you stay connected that's how
you you stay up to date with what's
going on around the world so then you
are not left left behind right so you
are you are on par with your colleagues
in the us and europe
yeah i think great great points and
hacks there i mean we do know about it
but we don't know how to utilize them
and where to find these resources so
i think one of the key to finding
information is also
searching properly searching for these
keywords that uh that are necessary for
you to know exactly where these
resources are and most of the things are
available online and as dr khan and
rightly said that how the poet
19
pandemic has changed the entire way of
you know knowledge knowledge transfer
and also gaining access to all those
events and especially on an online
setting the opportunities are a lot
there's a lot of opportunity and many of
these events are also free for students
and users that and also recordings are
available on youtube so there's a huge
resource out there
where you can learn about these new
technologies and
maybe uh connect with people over the
link over linkedin who are working on
these specific technologies because uh i
think that is one great place to find
people who are working on it something
that you can that like motivates you and
then connect and then have a meaningful
discussion
so i mean with that i would go to
uh go to kalyani and uh ask her that uh
how's her experience in mentis hype and
uh and
how do you see galiyani and very good
evening how do you see this uh academia
to industry transition and those points
like when you prepare to be a to be
like maybe get a highlighted by the
industry or get your profile being
highlighted so that the relevant person
can reach out to you or you can reach
out to relevant person as in and get
that impression
thank you so much
can you hear me
yes yes hey good evening everyone and
thank you so much for giving this
opportunity and it's great to be talking
to a lot of upcoming scientists over
here so i was listening to sonali and dr
ishivi and nidi before this
so i think all these things that these
people have told
has a lot of value that they have
brought into this space for the students
who are here
so quickly adding something to talk
about dr chevy was just saying about
conferences so
i think students can relate to this when
we were students we also used to think
of conferences as an outing that when
you're going for a conference you it's
more like okay i'm going to isc for a
conference so
i'm going to go there and have fun and
all but what dr shibi has told just now
is something that you should all note
that conferences are not just for fun
not food and all it's more about
networking over there and uh and one
more point that i would like to add
along with the three points that he has
mentioned is
you can target people over there so
suppose if you want to connect with dr
shibi sometime on a personal level he
just mentioned that he is going for a
boot camp and if you are interested in
something like that that's the place
that you can target that is just an
example that i'm giving you so if you
have been following a professor for your
next post doc or for a
for a job position going forward for
somebody who is into industry
make sure you find out you follow them
on linkedin
keep following up that which events are
they going to attend in future you keep
track of those events attend those
events so that you have a context for a
meaningful conversation with them when
you go there
and even when you want to connect you
can say that okay i heard you in this
particular conference you spoke about
this thing the moment you put this
personalized messages over there that
will bring the life that is what will
bring the limelight to you
so i have been into industry like i have
transitioned i've done my phd my post
talk then i was in a health care startup
that i was working in
for three years i was there then i
completely pivoted now i'm a product
manager in a
uh in a video publishing house from us
so these transitions so you can see i
have been in the trajectory where i have
experienced all these things
and i would strongly recommend that
networking is something that plays a big
role mohamed and i'm sure you also
understand because you're also in
industry now
so that is something that students
should definitely think on
and one point that i want to elaborate a
little bit on what finally would operate
was also indicating about mindset so
this is something where we are all
getting stuck
it is not a very big thing people have
been making a
you know huge human cry around
transitioning from academia to industry
it is not very difficult if you are
taking the right approach if you have
that mindset if you are prepared for it
you know even before your masters when
you join masters what kind of field you
are interested in you know take
internships everybody has been telling
about it so there's nothing new about it
but when you're taking internship
when you're looking at the particular
job that you are doing there also look
at people around you
does anything else apart from your own
job impress you you know you can maybe
look at some product project manager
wins there in your company and you can
look up to them you can see okay this
person is doing this i would like to do
a job like this
set goals like that and then take a you
know top down approach so that you can
make a career path for yourself that's
something that we keep telling our
mentees always that the problem with our
system is we are never taught to
think beyond our next degree you know
the moment you take admission in phd you
are like okay five years i'll just focus
on my phd no that's not the right thing
and that is not something that you
should be doing you should know what is
your next step going to be after that
and you start preparing for it so like
life is like a chess game so when you
have heard that in a chess a you know a
grand master will prepare for a move
seven moves ahead so why can't you do
that in your life i'm sure your life is
more important than a chess game
i think these are couple of things that
people should start focusing on
you know and you know we were talking
about the healthcare segment it is
booming like anything and it is not the
you not the boom that we have seen in it
it is going beyond that because
something that is related to us that all
of us can relate to
and even the investors are seeing this
as dr sonali was also indicating
i actually urge students always that you
go for a startup job first because my
first job was in a startup
you get to learn a lot you know you are
when you're in a big company it is like
you are given a small chunk of work and
you do the same work day in day out
and i'm sure dr sandy would agree with
me on this that if you if you are in a
startup you
get to wear many hats you get so much of
exposure you get to learn so many things
so early in your career if you're
hustling at that level you learn so much
about yourself about your domain about
your industry that going forward becomes
much more easier for you at least that's
what i feel when i have transitioned
from you know academia to industry then
to another category altogether so these
are a couple of things that we should
keep our minds open to keep looking
around people you know who are there
what kind of upskilling they are doing
you know upskilling is a very important
thing that we should always
focus on you know that is where omics
research you know omics logic comes into
picture pan battery comes into picture
you can you should keep up skilling
yourself never get stuck even after your
phd or postdoc or masters i did my
postdoc a three-year postdoc and even
after that i wanted top skill i wanted
to grow beyond that i didn't want to get
stuck after saying that okay postdoc is
the highest degree what more can
somebody do
but i wanted to break that thing because
i wanted to reach out for more
so never think never think that you know
i have done it this and this is enough
it's never enough there's always
something to learn
i think that
answers your question
yes absolutely and uh there is another
important question i'll come to that but
yes absolutely you're right and we got
to know about like i would highlight
networking one of the things that all of
the speakers have i put emphasis on and
the different ways to do this and what
is a meaningful way to do this because
we all try to do different things but
there is a structure to it and that's
what also
uh something that nidhi showed us
in our presentation that there is a
structure to it and you can get trained
so there are few questions i mean which
are quite relevant i think um uh one
question which i could maybe go to
sonali about so uh
uh paraks segal she's asking that
what are the opportunities for women
uh on how one can do research in
bioinformatics or data science while
working in working from home because
it's it's also like an opportunity for
women who are like at the early stages
and may be involved in family and have
those limitations that we are very much
aware in india
yeah so i
mean as a subject it's not really women
or men it's about you know the
bioinformatics so if i if i would just
you know talk about bioinformatics as a
subject it's a very interdisciplinary
area where you need knowledge of biology
where you need knowledge of
computational biology a bit of coding
skills you know depending on
which uh which direction you are
so you can have a combination or or you
know it can skew between from very
domain side to the the coding side or in
between anywhere of this the whole you
know uh scale of the bioinformatics uh
there is definitely you know i mean
since it's a very collaborative uh
space and it's it's a very very uh
scientific area uh there's definitely a
need for you know be there along with
the team working along with the
scientists because you are so
bioinformatics is not the other areas
where you know like the id right like
where you just work on some project
remotely yes that can be done for some
time but there would be some touch
points and also it depends on the how
the projects are designed like some of
the projects which we do basically we
have a project manager who would be
client-facing who would be you know
understanding and that person is
basically who understand the biology and
the life sciences right and they would
relay this to the data scientist guys
and the data scientist guys can sit
anywhere across the country or the globe
and can actually work on the the logics
or the the problem statement which is
defined to them right so so if somebody
is interested work remotely yes there is
absolutely you know a possibility to
work remotely on the bioinformatics area
as well but then again i mean you know
are you just willing to do the coding
part of it or you also want to you know
go a little bit more advanced on the the
science part of it right so so i i think
that's and that's the the beauty of it
right you just don't want to restrict
yourself on on you know knowing the
algorithm or you know building the
algorithm because you're working on a
very interesting data these are not like
you know any other non-biological data
these are not these are very live very
very interactive data and when you work
with data you would want to work
collaboratively you would want to work
with the scientific team who has
actually generated the data i mean let's
say for example of ngs sequencing right
so so you get all all the data coming
out from your illumina or nanopore or
whatever sequencing
machine and then you try and analyze
this data but then you will also have to
understand how the data has been
generated what was the objective of it
what was the outcome we are trying to
achieve so there's basically a lot of
interactions and collaborations happens
among us but having said that there is
definitely a possibility of one team can
sit remotely and can you know work on
the the coding part of it as long as
they they can effectively communicate
with the scientist you know remotely
it's absolutely possible to to deliver
even even the bioinformatics projects as
well
perfect perfect i think that that kind
of answers the question that
wanted to ask because what is happening
is that like we saw that that many
especially in the context of women who
has
maybe
dropped out and have a long gap they are
coming back and saying that
bioinformatics is something that could
be done effectively in a home setting
and maybe in a hybrid setting so make
sense thank you so much tonali for that
uh for that expertise expert advice
now uh a question i mean uh um for dr
khan as he was talking about networking
so there's a question by one of the
student and it makes sense like after
you network with the expert in the field
what tips do you have on sustaining that
professional relationship for a long
time of approach because we do start
with that but how to sustain that like
uh how do you find those you know ways
to make keep it engaging engaged and
give that engagement for a longer time
or longer
timeline
yes that's a very good question so
during the conferences or webinars we
make the initial meeting and greeting
right but how do you continue that
relationship outside the webinar uh so
the best place is linkedin obviously uh
linkedin on twitter so twitter
uh
i was not using i was one of the early
adopters i'm like uh
5000th person who joined linkedin and
500 person who joined twitter so i'm
like always looking for new tech and i'm
one of the early adopters of all these
new technologies in fact i was using
whatsapp before people in india knew
about whatsapp
rights i'm a very very early adopter but
then i stopped using twitter in between
because it was full of chunk
then later on i realized the entire
scientific community is on twitter right
so if you want real-time collaboration
instantaneous response from anybody for
example clive brown cto of nanopore i
simply clicked follow
follow one second the within five
seconds he followed me back i was like
wow the city of nanapur is following me
back you know you and then instantly we
connected and we were talking similarly
you know during kovid uh i was working
on the pancaron virus vaccine
mrna vaccine so with a lot of interest
in mrna vaccine nowadays because of the
success stories of eisen and modern so
that is this dr florian kramer and he
was putting all this and also eric
dobble and all these other guys they're
putting all the latest updates on kobit
research so i kept following them and
when they put something interesting then
i engaged with them right i messaged i
replied to them and they reply back
so that's that's the that's the key
metric so it's not just you putting
bombarding them with messages they have
to reply back whereas if you take people
like elon musk
millions of people follow him he never
replaced anybody he very rarely replies
unless it's some something maybe unique
you know something out of the ordinary
he never replaced anybody that's not an
engagement the engagement is you message
somebody and they reply so there's a
two-and-throw as a conversations are
happening so social media is the best
place to go don't waste your time on
instagram or facebook
focus on these two platforms linkedin on
twitter
linkedin you'll also get the history of
a particular person which university
they went to where are they working
right now right and if they are hiring
so nowadays they have that hiring tag
and similarly employees and students and
postdocs also looking for a job i am
open for opportunities you can put a tag
on a profile picture
that kind of enables specific linkedin
one one big thing which i recommend
everybody is uh follow or connect with
your mentors and peers and ask them to
give recommendations similarly you give
recommendations to them so it's like i
give you a recommendation you give me an
accomplishment it's a it's a social
exchange
and also update your skills make your
profile 100 i've seen many students
sending me cvs and other things uh
because no people are always looking for
jobs
but then you then you open the profile
they don't even put the picture on the
on the
profile right
so that's then suddenly they imagine the
human resource person or somebody who is
interested or let's say you are applying
for a postdoc job with the faculty they
don't even see your face
how do you how do you expect them to
respond to you right so it's all about
the human connection
so keep your profile 100 updated so if
you take any online course you done for
example you got under this event for
example then you can post it in blink
green and you can share the put the
hashtags put the links and everything
automatically you will get that
recognition right it's all about social
proofing recognition you need to be in
control of your own domain and you have
to showcase that you are going that
extra distance you are taking
initiatives uh to learn things and
exchange ideas and connect with your
peers also connect with the faculty so
it's not like suddenly pop out of
nowhere and say hey dr kanan can you
give me a job it doesn't work like that
and even even if you have some openings
you know right there's so many qualified
candidates why should i pick you over 10
other candidates who have gone through
the
selection process
so you have to stand out from the crowd
how do you stand up from the crowd you
have to let your voice be here at the
same time you want to engage with the
audience so we we have a saying in
startups in entrepreneurship your
network equals your net worth right so
build your network and uh these two
platforms are amazing so in twitter what
you do if you see any check mark blue
checkmarks the verified accounts
unfollow everybody unfollow all the
celebrities and follow the guys whenever
they play like i don't follow elon musk
i don't follow jeff bezos i don't follow
bill gates but i follow bill and marina
against foundation because the
foundation will put announcement when is
the next grant coming i need to know the
deadline so that i can apply the program
follow the people you need unfollow
everybody you don't need that's the best
case scenario same with linkedin
don't randomly follow people don't
randomly
spam messages connect with them on on
that particular topic that's being
discussed right so that's there has to
be some relevancy in the context that's
my that's my take on that so linkedin
and twitter two best places to be right
now uh also learning learning
opportunities plenty of learning
opportunities
so many tips and tricks for the
community it has been a great experience
uh dr khannan and kalyani and
uh
thank you
add a couple of actionable tips over
there do we have time for that yes yes
of course i was coming back to you
okay great so uh just adding on to
whatever doctor should be said so for
students that you know when we mentor
them sometimes we tell them these things
they don't know where to start and
linkedin as a profile when you just join
it can become a little overwhelming you
know for anybody who has just joined you
so few actionable tips i would like to
give here if you have a pen and paper
make sure you you know make a note of it
so when you're connecting with somebody
suppose if you are sending me a friend
request or a connection request there
make sure you mention it there you know
hi
this particular home's logic concerns
that i attended oh you know i want to
know more from you i want to learn from
you your profile is inspiring pick up
something from my profile that you can
connect with like okay you worked in
systems biology i'm also currently
working on systems biology try to make a
personal connect over there in some
fashion you know it should have a it
should not be just like you know you
have just clicked on the button then you
have not made an effort until unless you
make an effort from your end how would
the other person realize that you are
sincere in your efforts so that is the
first thing never send a connection
request without a message in it and as
dr shibi was indicating that you cut you
engage with them so how do you engage
with them on a continuous basis you
comment on their post don't just comment
saying that okay this post is inspiring
thanks for sharing put your own thoughts
to it so if you have done that five
times the sixth time the person would
know that okay this person has been
commenting on my post so if it was an
opportunity arises where you have to
reach out to them for a certain you know
job or any favor you can always stay and
that person would recognize you because
oh kalyani i've seen her she keeps
commenting on my post that means she has
some knowledge about the field so these
are the ways that you're establishing
your credibility over there so when you
are on linkedin you have you also have
to post there so if suppose you are
interested in cancer biology and a new
paper has come up in cancer biology why
don't you post it there along with some
thoughts of your own that what does this
research mean what is going to be a
future impact of this research overall
cancer health care so the moment you put
in some meaningful thoughts there that's
when the person realizes that okay this
person is intellectually sound they have
some credibility in the field they
understand the feel and once you keep
making those kind of engagement that's
when your name is visible always you
know you are somewhere in the radar so
even if you are not connected with them
on a day in day out basis at least you
know you are there on their feed every
time they can keep seeing your name
so these are some of the ways that you
can you know highlight your profile you
know kind of create a brand for yourself
when you're on linkedin and similar goes
with their twitter also you have to keep
engaging with their post and of course
meaningful engagement whenever i'm
saying engagement it is meaningful
engagement where you write something
about that they have done or they have
posted and how your comment is adding a
value to it so keep these things in mind
whenever you are going to link them next
time
perfect thank you so much
for all those insights and it has been
an honor to be a part of this
panel and to be a part of with all of
you uh here
uh so i i am really i'm thoughtful and
think that students have been
and also like
the faculty have been able to gain some
of these
points and could maybe transfer this
knowledge further and students can apply
some of these points and
get the outcomes they are looking for or
looking towards because they
i mean there is a there is a sense of
doing things quickly in this new
generation and without putting the
effort which is required in there so uh
they if there is a constant effort you
will get to the results and that's what
experts are saying again thank you so
much to the
panelists for being being a part of this
uh research symposium and dr kanan is
again filling another form so yes thank
you again
for for being here and helping all of us
and we will be able to see you again
very soon and maybe to talk to you on
different opportunities
over to use sonalika now
so let's talk to mohit and thank you so
much all the panelists that was
very interesting to know about your
thoughts uh thank you so much and thanks
thank you once again
and
now i would like to welcome dr raja
wordman so to expand further on the
topics that were discussed by dr nidhi
and the panel discussion
dr raja vadman is the senior
bioinformatics specialist at prima's
life sciences and spends most of his
time analyzing and reporting cancer
genomic data sets from illumina
platforms and hospitals like cochlear
ben and adeya cancer institute who
he has published his cancer studies in
american molecular pathology journals
journal of molecular and genetic
medicine and has trained several
institutes in india
which were involved in major genomic
programs like sarso surveillance he has
also written several articles on diverse
topics focusing on clinical informatics
comprehensive genomic profiling
nutrigenomics and infectious diseases
and different magazines blocks etc he
previously has had exposure to precision
medicine and non-clinical sequencing
data analysis while he was working with
several bioinformatics companies we are
pleased to have you with us mr raja over
to you
thank you so much for
that very detailed introduction and
thank you so much for the given chance
let me share the screen
somehow i feel my topic has been stolen
by the previous uh
panelist
uh
keeping that aside uh i might reiterate
the same thing in a different form
altogether
let's see how much it reaches
without any further due my name is raj
verman kitu i'm working as a
bioinformatics specialist in premars
life sciences today we are going to see
the technical skills as well as the soft
skills which is needed to be in industry
again
it's not specific to informatics i would
probably consider this as a
recommendation for any technical uh
probably the id or
the bioinformatics together right
wherever the data analysis comes in
picture this can be applied
so three things we are going to discuss
first is technical skills and then soft
skills and the mindset pretty much all
these topics are covered by the previous
panelists but
i will be adding little more extra
points here
so speaking about technical skills there
are some unique skills comes with
certain people and as a team we need to
have some specific skills probably i
would say uh people specific skills as
well as the
team management skills right so
currently we are going to see uh first
let's focus on individual skills suppose
the given problem
yes
so say in the informatics generally in
the i.t related companies or the
informatics companies you'll be given a
problem or will be
asking to develop a tool so those kind
of situations first we need to
understand the problem what's basically
what you want to do either we want to do
the analysis for the given data sets or
we want to build some software and then
we'll be going for the plan like say the
architecture
like clear plan on the architecture the
second one is what are the
infrastructure we need then how many man
powers we need how many people and where
are the resources has to be
put on right and the last one is time
frame and then finally we'll be deciding
what are my deliverables and how fast i
can give so this is a basic benchmark or
probably the need
or the workflow which has to be followed
right in both the cases
so be it it's happening on the cloud or
local this is the ultimate goal for any
given cases right
say we are going to develop a product
say be a software product which is being
done in the local or you are developing
a product in the cloud or you are
developing a database altogether right
or there are some cases since currently
people are so much fond of going for
artificial intelligence or machine
learning or probably the svm is one of
the classical machine learning
techniques neural network concept or
deep learning concept
any of those cases apart from even the
data management first of all we need to
understand what is the given problem or
the situation come up with a detailed
plan and we need to know the logic as
well before even starting any given
coding we need to know the logic we need
to convert the whole problem into the
scripting language by the way we need to
be very good at the maths as well as our
logical thinking only then the scripting
can be executed right and finally once
the execution is being done we need to
go for certain validation so again when
i say validation in the beta stage we'll
be doing some validation where the known
data sets will be given and we'll be
checking are we getting the expected
results or not
again uh you might need to fine-tune
different uh parameters or
specifications to reach the expected
value which confirms your product is
good enough
and then the final minimum refinement if
it is needed will be going for this is
specifically for product development as
far as analysis is concerned it's
slightly different we'll be taking a
different data set which has been
already established or had been
published we'll use that same data set
build a pipeline and confirm the results
and then we'll be using the real-time
data set for uh getting more confident
on that right as far as data management
is concerned we need to know the
policies very well first of all like say
you are a kind of a service provider
where you are building a data management
policies or the products we need to know
the requirement better or their policies
and then we'll be building the tools
again they are also pretty much the same
concept you need to apply the logic you
need to execute it and you need to
validate it and then you'll be giving
the deliverables right it's pretty much
a basic uh benchmark or probably the
bottom scenario which has to be followed
so the key point here first we need to
be understanding is
probably the scope of this particular
given problem and what is the highlight
like what do they want to achieve out of
this whole problem or the product and
the last one is limitation what you can
give or what you can get out of the
products and what are things we can't do
it so
the more we know the better we'll be
coming up with the better solutions
that's what the ultimate uh the probing
is one of the important key this cannot
be done in the middle of the process or
the last
minute rather the more we understand
from the client end or probably it may
be a data or it might be a product the
more we communicate and get the details
from the uh given clients the better
products we can achieve
right so this kind of one of the busy
slide with the scary key points to keep
it very simple uh again
this slide is specifically for
informatics i would say
if you are a information be it your
analyst or your development site you are
in the basic thing which you need to be
knowing for sure is perl and python of
course there are many cloud computing
services there are gui based web browser
there are multiple options are there but
to do a minimum file manipulation even
if you want to do accounting it's not
good to do using a simple excel so in
that case the basic level of scripting
is always recommended if you are in
informatics field again very basic
knowledge for perl and python at least
right
and then before even jumping into the
scripting we need to know the schemes
better like say what is a given problem
which are all how do what are all the
concepts i can apply on the given data
sets and then the systems in this given
configuration or given setup will be
able to execute or not so we need to
know the computation also better with
respect to the scope right so pearl
python is kind of i would say
if you are in informatics field then it
is compulsory and then there are next
level of products where people are
nowadays not even nowadays i would say
down the line uh 10 15 years before also
people are more fond of coding in the
cloud right so where hadoop scala is
kind of widely used if you get a time
and if you are a tech savvy so in that
case you are very much fond of
learning the technical skills try to
understand how cloud computing has been
executed where hadoop ecosystem which
covers almost the data management
product development as well as the uh
full-fledged product development can be
learned in that particular platform
which you can try it out again it's very
very advanced level not for everybody
people who are fond of
tech they can
get into this and the last one which i'm
saying is basically next flow why it is
kind it's kind of trendy and it's not
something very new it came from java and
then groovy it's a like third level of
java i would say at this point but why
it is important currently most of the
cloud solutions is getting developed
using this particular scripting
so if you get a chance again if you are
very much fond of tech learning then
this is a thing which you can try it out
as it is trending right
so uh these are all not again compulsory
if you have your own as i told there are
web browsers are there there are windows
based softwares are there there are free
open source tools are there there are
cloud computing services
those things can be explored this is for
people who fond of learning new skills
developing new skills as you have seen
the previous uh
the whole panel was speaking about
developing the skills so if that is a
concept
technical skills if you want to develop
being a core developer then these are
all things has to be there as an analyst
if you know bare minimum with the ball
python it's good enough but if you want
to develop something it's better to have
all these things in place
at this given point again down the line
uh in two years this may even get
outdated because the new things that the
way i t
skill requirement is getting uh
probably uh moving is so faster right so
in this case today this is kind of
useful you need to catch up with your
skills always that's what i'm trying to
say from this slide right
so uh switching the gear here
uh soft skills as far as soft is
concerned almost people have told this i
am just reiterating the same thing a
different way
at certain acting you need to be having
a technical skill for sure but if you
want to survive in the industry the
people skill is more important yes you
know very well but if you don't know how
to communicate better plus you are not
talking with anybody you are always
working on your own pc it doesn't help
so in that case people skills are very
much important how do you develop you
need to do enough of networking which
has been told before also and you need
to have good contacts again don't run
behind contacts at least if it is
reaching you don't give up like say
someone is coming and talking try to
develop a relation with relations as a
friendly relation with them right and
the team script team split what does
that mean if any given role is any given
task uh for a team try to distribute
instantly uh
rather than owning the like
taking the full ownership
try to distribute it so that everyone
get a chance to utilize their skills
right plus you will be also in if you
are working as a team obviously down the
line you will come to know what are the
individual skills as well so that it's
easy to distribute
their their own favorite skill sets so
that's that kind of one kind of thing
which will be understanding in the down
the line right so team split is one of
the important thing which gives chance
for the individual growth as well as
well as the team growth as well so
that's one of the important thing which
everyone should be understanding right
and self-discipline which of course
people skill basically if you are very
extrovert
you don't want to work on this first
point because you will be having this
inbuilt right there's no doubt on this
but when it comes intraverse is kind of
different we need to be picking up so
otherwise it's very difficult to survive
right and the second one which is self
discipline why we are speaking about
self discipline uh the whole uh say you
are working in office where all eight
hours you're going to communicate or
even if the client comes in with the
requirement you're going to communicate
them the communication is the key again
with respect to what are the words you
use what are the body languages you use
so you are almost communicating or
conveying the message even without
speaking that's what the second point is
which is body language
be it you are giving a talk or you're
sending a mail or you're in the call
like say you are having even one-to-one
conversation everywhere
try to be with the full self-discipline
when i say self-discipline you need to
follow
basic rules which is basically i would
say ground rules which is these things
try to be a lesson
try to have a pleasant conversation as
much as possible and try to spread the
positivity as much as possible and
whenever you speak make sure it's it's
basically your delivery you're
delivering the statement with full
confidence and the way you are
delivering people should get rest on you
so that's the ultimate purpose of
communication all over be it
professional or non-professional this
should be the way right
and if i want to put it in very simple
term
uh try to
write very clear even simple
context so you don't want to be so much
of using a jargons like say very
technical terms even if the simple term
would do to convey the message so try to
keep it very simple second is when we
are in call even though you may you the
the tone is very important the pitch is
very important why people don't see our
face so in that case we need to be very
careful with what we communicate so the
pitch as well as the tone is very very
important in the calls specifically
right
and the last one is body language
this is mostly for uh if you're working
on your own space there's no issues but
when you are really working as a group
or as a team or even if you are in a
meeting it's very important to maintain
a body language suppose
people can easily figure out who is
basically basically focusing and who is
interested and not interested right so
in that case body language is one of the
important factor in fact even if if you
are speaking and if your message is
conveyed and it may even reach in the
right tube but body language if it is
wrong people uh get it very totally
different from altogether so in that
case these are all the key points which
has to be followed these are all the
basic i would say basic recommendations
right
so i think um
this has been told before right i'm just
putting in a different
context in the
communication as well so we need to know
when i say
scope
highlight and
limitations basically
given communication say there is a
communication which happens we need to
grasp the concept quickly so suppose if
someone comes and reaches you for some
topic
try to get the uh like say crisp or
probably the purpose behind this quickly
and highlight only the advantages plus
try to know the limitation this i told
for the technical as well this is
applicable for the simple communication
as well so rather than wasting time on
unrelevant topics or like say unwanted
things rather
understand the concept as much as
possible try to ask as much as question
in the first instance get a clarity what
why this particular conversation is
happening straight away get to the point
right plus you try to know where it is
leading as well as soon as possible so
this is one of the effective way
communication this this is this should
be followed for sure right
as the almost we are in the last part
where the mindset mindset people have
already told also uh since we could able
to see in the panelists there are
different kind of one doctors there was
there was a consultant there was a
doctor there is a ceo plus there are
information so i we could see almost
different background people in one
particular panel which we saw almost
everyone had kind of same
uh mindset here so everyone was saying
try to gasp like say grasp whatever
comes to you don't miss out any meetings
linkedin be active communicate
effectively so almost they told
everything so all
things comes out of one basic thing
which is basically they should have a
very positive mindset plus the eagerness
to learn
with full fash passion right so here i'm
i just brought a little bit of plot
where
try to have experimental mindset
and be ready to take risk again not
extremes at least the basic ones you
should not be giving a second thought
because as a student level it's better
to take a risk at the early stage
because down the line you may not even
getting a chance to take a risk right so
this is a time to take a risk it's
better to take and try to learn things
quickly
again different people have different
learning skill sets probably they may
take a time but as a motto try to have a
motor to learn quickly so because that
is one of the key factor
to improve the skills faster right and
if anything comes new
you can give a thought let get to know
about pro and cons for sure but
adaptation is one of the important key
factors in index industry because every
company is not going to work in a same
way so it's better to
have a
quick adaptation mindset
and then passion driven almost everyone
will be having this if they enjoy the
job which they do in that case it's by
default it comes in if you are not
getting it obviously you need to switch
the job so in that case what i meant if
you enjoy the job you don't want to
struggle more on this so passion driven
should be there if you want to
see a growth in your career and split so
obviously it will be coming in picture
if everything is in place finally the
commitment so if you miss any of these
things in the middle so probably the
commitments should be given to all the
segments which has been shown here
so that's the one which is going to be
driven so it's not like two days you're
doing you are doing something and then
you are living it rather try to have a
long term commitment with whatever has
been mentioned
so uh these are all the
key uh
probably the parameters or the mindset
we should be having it to uh
rather than saying survive to have a
better career in the industry right this
can be applicable for research as well
which overall it can be applicable for
both but
the skill sets which has been mentioned
or the key points which has been
mentioned is very very important
if you want to achieve something in your
career
so uh with that i would like to close
the talk let me see if i have any
questions even though it's very general
topic
all right thank you so much
uh mr raja for such
an insightful talk yes we do have some
questions with us that i would like to
ask
so uh one of our participants is asking
after requiring technical skills such as
pearl or python
i would like to work on a project using
these skills what are some of the ways
that i can showcase my work
so uh
about the projects again we need to know
as i told before we need to know uh what
kind of project it is plus
uh we need so again scripting wise you
can always choose any of the scripting
you have c c plus perl java you have
multiple things we need to understand
what is the problem is less which
particular scripting will be best
suitable for the given uh probability to
solve the
problem or to develop the product in
that case the more understanding we
should be knowing the limitations as
well as the highlight of the individual
scriptings
probably the programmings
i hope that answers your question
and
how do you network with experts in field
who are difficult to communicate with uh
perhaps they're not interested or how do
you convince them
okay so rather than here there is no
convincing rather us she had told very
nicely i think
don't sit even though linkedin uh
request when you say don't just send a
blank message or that blank invitation
you add in your uh key points probably
the catchy phrase when i say catchy
place it's not like like you are putting
a one-liner to impress rather you keep
something give a topic which is common
between both of them so of course it may
take a time uh some people are not open
to start a conversation in the first go
right if you really uh following someone
probably you are uh you are having
passion to follow someone
keep in touch with them it's not like
you need to communicate down the line
anyway you will be meeting them uh if
you are following them seriously
so it's not like you need to force them
to get them in your
radar
so you just follow them and do your work
down the line anyway you'll be reaching
them for sure
i mean be optimistic
yeah that's a nice answer all right and
how do the skills required differ while
working on a project individually as
well as by working in a team
that's a nice question
yes
so first of all uh this is this mostly
uh so let me give a very simple uh
explain like examples first of all when
the project comes in obviously the teams
will be divided individual based on
their skill sets which they have
acquired before even if it if they are
not well trained with the with the skill
sets the team the the individual
division or probably the job
distribution which will be happening
after the project has been settled say
the the business analyst who collects
all the requirement from the clients
then there will be a job distribution
meeting which happens very clearly with
all the team members where based on
their skill sets the the problem will be
different probably the the workload will
be divided so that's one chance where
people even switch or people wants to
learn something new they also get an
opportunity so it's kind of well
organized in the mncs when it comes
small startups as people have already
told you will be wearing multiple hats
you will be responsible for multiple
things so in fact we'll be putting your
hands almost everywhere
right and uh do technology soft skills
set you apart from the crowd
uh
so let me
change the perspective here
the crowd will be anyway uh will be
following the trending part that's not
sure today one script tomorrow one
script it will be always following right
so in your case at this point like today
you decide like today you are you are a
student so today you try to pick one
skills and try to become a master down
the line say at least within three years
right
why i'm saying this because anyway the
trend will be keep on changing if you
know one script today it's very easy to
adapt new one or you can pick up so
whatever you learned in this three years
can be converted to the new things which
is coming so rather than catching up on
something which is which is basically
keep on running focus on something at
this point for some time and then you
switch it will be easy transition
basically
i hope that answers your question
the okay we have a lot of questions
today how can soft skills provide an
edge to a person in the industry and
what could be some of the tips to
improve them yeah we did cover it
but yeah
if you want to add something
no i think it's covered it's fine
yes
okay and as an introvert how can i keep
the conversation going while networking
yes so uh this is this is very very very
difficult
for sure but uh
being introvert is fine still you are in
college and school but when it comes
industry
uh you will be missing out if you are
you can be a introvert there is no doubt
but when it comes something to your
table like if example i'm giving
you going running behind someone and
then saying hi is not needed but at
least if you get a high try to say hello
that's minimum requirement which the
introvert should be doing plus if
someone who is matching your wavelength
technically right
be open to discuss with them uh more so
that's one of the thing which i can
think about at this point introvert is
one of the like characteristics which is
a bond skills but there are certain
topics which you should be able to
discuss with people who have same
interests
yeah that's a nice point
and
amongst technical and soft skills which
is important
which is more important
so uh
at the early stage technical skills are
very very very very important which is
90 10
and down the line when you are well
experienced with the technical the
people skill should be like 70 important
i hope that answers your question and do
you want to uh add something for our
participants towards the end
who are in their graduation and
post-graduation
and are dealing with their busy schedule
of academics but also want to upgrade
their skill sets but don't have the time
or are confused which resources to
follow what to do how do i
actually are confused which specific
skill set to pick they have no idea who
it is how can they
yes
so uh
some skills again speaking about
academic uh there is a really very good
gap or probably the very long gap
from the academic to industry how do you
fill the gap of course the academic
syllabus where you uh cover for like say
the academic syllabus is only for this
course right you may grasp up basics for
sure not everyone is picking the life
skills over there when i say life skills
it means the skills which will be useful
for your career and the life right so in
that case
the bridge these bridges can be closed
by taking extra courses it'd be it might
be either
probably as you can say the mind buttock
is giving multiple courses
where you get to have extra skills which
your own classmate doesn't have simple
example in your classes 60 people are
there not like everyone knows
how to analyze the ngs data example
right so there are 60 different there
are nearly 16 to 20 different pipelines
which has been developed in the cloud
which they uh pinevitec is having where
every individual pipelines has its own
tools and different parameters you can't
pick up everything in your academic
academy can give you only the
introduction to certain areas they can't
go in deep any of those things so if you
want to
develop your skills you need to take
like you need to come out of the
academic syllabus and learn more outside
the
classrooms which is very important
things that's how we'll be differentiate
from others again there is no
limitations here in the learning the
more you learn outside your class is
going to be helpful in your life like
basically
in the career
so in that case
try to do more this has been already
told before also i'm reiterating
conference workshop classes try to
attend more that this improves you
to pick up your skills better
right mr raja
your answers were really helpful and i
thank you once again for being a part of
the symposium and they're delivering
this uh very insight for that helpful
talk
and with this
with this we would now like to proceed
ahead with our next speaker
so far we learned about bioinformatics
research in indian industries now let us
see what is the present status of
bioinformatics in africa in terms of
education internship job opportunities
and research i would like to welcome
miss
patmaio
who works as the bioinformatics team
leader at the center for proteomic and
genomic research and works fifty percent
of a time as the bioinformatics
coordinator at diplomats a cpgr grant
program her main role is in overseeing
efforts to develop different methods to
understand data generated from the
different omics fields the organization
sir she also enjoys learning new
concepts from managing these projects in
these roles she has aided or led in
building successful products and
complete projects
this has
this has refined her marketing project
product and team management skills she
has enjoyed and has found that his
strength is in diligently stitching the
different components needed to deliver
successful services
she is also pursuing her phd program
which looks to explore factors that
contribute to developing competencies in
the evolving biomedical field that
experiences a constant change of scope
in work like at the cpgr
ultimately to improve on products and
outcomes which attracts funding in
business to continue to boost with a
particular focus on work done in africa
that was indeed an introduction though
now i would like to welcome miss
fardmail over to you
thank you very much uh let me just share
my
screen
can you see my presentation
yes we can see us perfect
yeah perfect okay okay so thank you for
that introduction so i'll get right into
it
um i'll start off with the cpgr and i'll
explain how
the two other organizations fit into
this
so here's a summary of
where everything sits so uh the
department of science and innovation in
south africa funds different programs
and one of them is the technology
innovation agency which funds the cpgr
which is my primary employer
and the other two organizations that i'm
going to speak about are diplomix which
is a program so the cpgr hosts that and
the cpgr
also has a subsidiary startup which is
called artist environment
so in these different organizations um
that's where the different sort of
titles come out so in diplomacy i'm a
bioinformatics coordinator at the cpg
i'm the bioinformatics team leader and
at artisan i'm a bioinformatics
consultant
so all of these um
although are connected are quite
independent and have different visions
so it's quite interesting to be in um
either of them then i'll touch a little
bit more about what i do in them i'll
strictly be focusing on the
bioinformatics aspect of of each one of
them but they actually do quite a lot so
if you're interested in learning a
little bit more about when you're
welcome to contact me
so i'll start off with the cpgr
so the cpgr stands for center for
proteomic and genomic research and it is
a non-profit organization that i
mentioned is funded by the department of
science and innovation in south africa
through one of the programs called
tia so that's a technology innovation
agency so we sit in woodstock in cape
town in south africa
it works mainly in the model of a
contract research organization so
focuses on different services and
training
it is omix
focused so omix research and life
science innovation in africa
so the main omics fields that it focuses
on it offers comprehensive services in
genomics proteomics transcriptomics
metabolomics and bioinformatics
so it houses uh quite a lot of
world-class infrastructure so the
organization itself has a wide range of
instruments
so if you'd like to know a lot more
about the different
instruments that are at the cpgr they
have an unpacking the toybox series so
if you go to cpgr's linkedin you'll be
able to follow that series as they
explain each of the machinery that they
have
so the reason why i'm mentioning this
wide variety of capabilities is that
along with that we offer bioinformatics
support so in terms of the work that i
do for the cpgr it's a sort of in-house
support for
all of the wide range of services that
could be offered um
through all of this machinery
okay so cpgr bioinformatics and overview
so
as i as i mentioned the projects that
happen
um in the lab can come through our
bioinformatics so it is an optional
service so if you need bioinformatics
support for any uh web lab services that
you get that's what we're there for
uh so
we have different clients so the
clientele is from industry and academia
but mostly from academia the clients are
researchers are students
consortiums so i gave here an example of
a consortium that we're a part of so
it's a big consortium called madcap so
men of african descent can cancel the
prostate
um and this is a customary that was
created it is a project that is funded
by the nih so that would fall under
consortium and we also have commercial
clients that are either doing research
to better their product or their
offering or they're using our lab to run
some of their services
so in terms of the bioinformatics team
because we have a wide range of projects
that come in we don't although we have
standard pipelines we tailor make
each
product to each client whether they're
from research or um
they're a commercial client we will
tailor make
um the solution that we make for them
the reason why we do this is because one
the clients are different too their
objectives are going to be different so
even if it's an rna-seq project each
client will want something different so
i will explain what i need now
after i explain uh the mic the makeup of
the bioinformatics team so the
bioinformatics team is made up of
biomedic bioinformatic analyst
so the skill set in terms of the people
that we hire is based on the analysis
that we do so it has to when we're
hiring someone it has a focus on
genomics and proteomics
it
the cp job being a cr also a contract
contract research it means that you have
more defined turnaround times because
it's a service that you're offering
someone
unlike in academia where it's a research
project and you have for example a year
to complete your master the the
turnaround time is not as
strict and as defined
so the core skill that we
need for our bioinformation so this will
differ from organization to organization
it will differ from industry to industry
depending on what you're doing so when
i'm talking about core skill set i'm
talking about a core skill set that's
needed for you to be a bioinformatician
at the cpgr so here our core skill set
when we're hiring someone is programming
why because the main skill that's needed
to implement the solutions based on the
different services that we offer in the
lab
our core language we use python
why because it's easy to learn and easy
to use
we try to have a standard language that
everyone uses if you have another
language that you
you prefer or you're you're well versed
in we still welcome you because that may
be useful
um
additional fundamental requirements is
experience in r and bash because we also
do use that and some knowledge of
biology why because
most projects are very holistic you're
not only going to use piping sometimes
you'll need to use bash sometimes you'll
need to use art sometimes what's really
needed for the project is a good
understanding of the biology
so
all of these are important because we
also collaborate with the wet lab so
that's another good thing about the cpgr
is that all of this is housed under one
roof from the wet lab to the analysis so
a client will have
uh from start to finish and you can
actually go to the person in the lab and
they can even tell you that you can say
you know for example uh two i'm seeing
um that the qc is looking a bit fuzzy
and then the person in the lab can tell
you that oh you know what these are the
qc metrics and when i was handling it
they didn't send the aliquot was way
less than the other ones and i was just
trying to make it work so it helps you
understand the better the data a little
bit more so all of these skill sets are
needed uh because um we apply a holistic
approach to solving
problems
and then the bioinformatics platform or
department itself we work
collaboratively internally so as a team
we collaborate together if someone is
experiencing certain issues that's why i
i noted that it's important for us to at
least have common uh programming
languages or skill sets so that
internally we can collaborate and
externally we collaborate quite a lot
with the clients and with the wet lab
we have to make sure that we can
integrate to assist each other
so whatever system is in place it's
important for us to have a common
language as i said so that we can
integrate into the same system one of
the things that our platform or
department has to consider is storage so
we have a lot of clients that come into
the cpgr we store their data we have to
consider how we're managing storage we
have to consider connectivity sometimes
we have cloud solutions or we have to
upload or download databases so
connectivity is a big consideration
we have to consider high performance
computing so
as you all may know that some tools are
really computationally intensive and you
cannot do it on your laptop you would
need a high performance computer
you would also have to consider data
sharing platforms or methods um
because you also want to integrate
externally into a client system because
maybe they receive data in a certain way
so you would have to consider that a
very important one is you have to
consider code hosting platform we use
github so you have to make sure that
it's a very standardized um system at
the cpgr so they are iso accredited
which means there's a standard way that
you do everything it makes
it make sure that you can always
backtrack if you have a problem um that
things are reproducible so one of the to
fulfill one of those requirements is we
put all of our code up on github it
makes sure that um anyone else can come
and replicate it
so yeah
that's an important consideration
you also need to consider tools and
software and related licenses um so
sometimes you only need a license for
one particular client so you have to
think that through to say how will i
complete this project so those are the
main considerations when setting up a
bioinformatics platform
and then bioinformatics is a service
so this is quite different from
academics
we've had bioinformatics analysts who've
joined the team and they've they're
testamented this to say that it's a very
different environment
when you are now offering bioinformatics
as a service it's a bit more refined um
you need to be a bit more sure about
what you're doing because it's helping
inform someone else's project or someone
else's service
um so the next line where i say a
service means an offering that requires
a specific result so when a client comes
in they want something specific at the
end so whatever you're doing you're
trying to get to that point
um in research uh if you sort of reach
certain blocks you can you know take
your time to think another way to do it
or to drop it when you're offering it as
a service the client expects a result at
the end
so you'll find that by informatics as a
service you employ quite a lot of
business principles um
with a high emphasis emphasis on human
capital so
in terms of my team i gear it mainly
towards soft skills you'll find very
quickly when you're offering
bioinformatics as a service that your
soft skills are going to be such a big
component so for example something as
little as communication whether you're
communicating internally as a team or
externally turned to a client you need
to communicate effectively because it
reduces scope creeps so scope creep is
um
the project slowly getting bigger and
bigger because people are slowly adding
requirements so you'll find with with um
clients who are researchers they're
quite excited about their project and
what they'll do is they'll come and say
okay the data do this or can the data do
that or can we do this and can we do
that and that increases the the budget
the turnaround time um and it just
prolongs the project so if you learn how
to communicate effectively then that
sort of reduces scope creep so you'll
find that a lot of soft skills um have
to come in with your with your hard
skills so you have tighter more defined
deadlines so there's a little bit more
pressure in a service environment
so i think this environment works better
for individuals who enjoy
solving like varied problems so if you
enjoy solving some people enjoy looking
at a particular protein for the next 20
years and there's absolutely nothing
wrong with that some people like looking
at proteins today and looking at genes
tomorrow and tomorrow looking at a
specific organism i think this
environment will work well for the
latter someone who likes um looking at
different problems and solving them and
being able to move on
um yeah
okay in terms of
service output
so
it's dependent on the client's
objectives so at the end of the day
uh when we're giving a client a result
if someone comes in usually this is what
we give them either we're giving them
data because they want the analysis done
to a certain point and they're going to
do downstream analysis by themselves so
some people might just say give me my
raw data some people might say qc my
data and then give it to me some people
might say
analyze the data up to a point where i
have your otus and then give it to me or
sometimes we do analysis and they will
interpret the results themselves um
sometimes we'll do analysis and training
because they would like to analyze
future data sets by themselves so
that's also for researchers who would
like who are continuing with their
project they might want you to do it the
first time and where as they get more
data then they might want to do training
so they can do it by themselves training
so you could train someone because they
would like to analyze their own data
sets from scratch um collaborative
which means that they would like the
client would like us to significantly
contribute to their project
so they would like us to analyze and
interpret and actually give results and
then include us in papers and so on
um
[Music]
sometimes it's consulting so they would
like to build it themselves but just
need someone as a sounding board or
someone to check in with so they will
purchase let's say eight hours and then
two hours a week we have a meeting where
they take us through their solution so
here is just an example of um
training so we get a lot of inquiries
about rna-seq and we thought it would be
a good idea to have an educational
webinar we just take people through a
basics of the analysis so that they have
an understanding of it and sometimes
when people understand it better then
they can say oh you know what this will
be too much for me and i'd rather you do
the analysis they can make an informed
decision about how you want them to help
you so from this educational webinar
some people will come up and say
actually this is too much and i'd just
like you to do the analysis or some
people would say oh this looks
manageable and i'd like to take a stab
at it so i would like to take this
consulting hour approach where i go and
i do it and then we meet every week if
i'm experiencing problems
um so those are the basic service
outputs at the cpgr
so now i'm going to move to diplomix
where i am a bioinformatics coordinator
so
diplomix as i mentioned let me just go
back to it it is hosted by the cpgr and
it's an infrastructure program
so the approach involves mainly
collaboration capacity development and
optimization and this requires amongst a
lot of things but partners experts and
cooperation from from my um point of
view and this is just a summary of what
diplomatics does so our aim is to build
world-class in omics infrastructure and
how do we do that it's either we're
placing instruments um and this is the
impact that it has and these are the
impacts that they're going to be direct
induced and directed simulative and over
time you can sort of tell like an
indirect um
an indirect impact and and sorry i've
got a chat
an indirect um
impact
and then um enables access to students
and researchers and that's done in
various ways um so in terms of training
in terms of height visibility high
impact projects um and then the
different impacts are you know you get
class reputational gain when you do high
impact high visibility projects um
so
it speaks to our capability to to to do
things so if i link it back to what i'm
currently doing um for my phd now all of
these as i said are
although they're connected they have
different focuses so maybe just to speak
about high visibility high impact
project for my phd where i speak about
um
once we have a good reputation of doing
reproducible and good um
[Music]
doing research that has good outcomes
then we can have that reputational game
and gain and over time that will attract
funding or that will attract business so
that's like a cumulative or a long-term
impact but um as time goes on you'll see
the impact of it later so i'm going to
speak
uh about deeponics again mainly um with
respect to bioinformatics but if you
guys have any questions that relates to
anything else you can get in touch with
me after
so diplomatics there are three omics
fields that it branches into so genomics
proteomics and metabolomics and
bioinformatics it is informed by a
working group of
experts
and each has an overarching domain
expert who is the coordinator so for
example i am the bioinformatics
coordinator and there is a
bioinformatics working group that has a
bioinformatics chair
and these different branches so genomics
proteomics and metabolomics and
bioinformatics who've had many
successful initiatives
so these initiatives range from either
training instrument placement and or
support for high impact initiatives so
you'll find here that for example
genomics would have a training outreach
or bioinformatics would have a training
outreach and then you develop skills or
you increase awareness of a particular
um
uh field or a particular technology and
then they're
different types of impacts that happen
over time
and then i'm going to talk about
bioinformatics
so information gathering is key to all
of our successful initiatives so before
we make a decision you sort of research
and say maybe this is the need or this
is the current situation and then you
sort of now research a little bit more
to be what is the best way to resolve it
so we would use this working group that
has all of these experts either as a
source or as a sound board or as a
source of initiatives themselves so of
the current needs with respect to
bioinformatics we have four main areas
of interest um so establishing
bioinformatics as a service improving
bioinformatics and project design
enabling or improving bioinformatics
training and inspiring the next
generation
so all of the above help improve
directly or indirectly overall outcomes
so of the list that i've said here i'm
just going to expand a little bit more
about it so bioinformatics is service so
we launched clarity which is a
bioinformatics marketplace
um
it hosts expert bioinformatics
consultants who are managed by an
experienced concierge
it is virtual therefore it's accessible
across across the globe
um currently it subsidized to do
researchers to help establish it as the
service and its work as a service so it
goes back to what we're talking about
building a reputation so that it either
attracts funding or attracts business um
so that's one of the main reasons why
it's subsidized to researchers
we have a strong emphasis on good
project
because
design
have found in terms of
when we
are doing information gathering and
we're really talking about what are the
struggles people are having with
bioinformatics is that when they're not
doing the analysis they feel that the
bioinformatics is
failing them it's not necessarily that
the bioinformatics is failing is that if
you put a good data in then you'll get
good data out so if your data is not
it's not that the data is necessarily
bad but it's not the right data to
answer your research question so for
example your data may have passed in the
lab and the qc is good but if you're
trying to do whole exome sequencing or
you're trying to look for a variant and
you have rna-seq data it won't answer
your question so it's the same way if
you haven't designed your project to get
the data that will help you answer the
question then you're always going to
find problems so that's why we have a
strong emphasis on good project design
so currently of the projects that have
come through our marketplace these are
mostly projects after data has been
produced which means that we would have
already passed the stage of project
design so we found that
clients may have
tried to take a stab at analyzing their
data and have found difficulties and
then now they'll go and find a service
provider and in that
um
other than just analyzing we're really
trying to roll back and get the best
that we can out of the project so again
this is also um
evidence supporting our initial uh
finding that project design is a really
important part of this um considering
bioinformatics that project design is
very important so uh bioinformatics as a
service we also get involved in high
impact projects so the nanopore projects
that we currently have now uh we have
bioinformaticians from our marketplace
working with uh the different partners
in the by the diplomax network so that's
how
diplomix handles bioinformatics as a
service
so speaking a little bit more about
bioinformatics and project design so 46
of projects fail because of poor project
design
why they did not properly consider the
needs for data analysis so if you want
to look at i'm just going to use an
analogy if you want to count how many
apples they are
that means that when you go to the
market you must get apples so that you
can count apples so some times when
you're designing a project what you need
is um replicates in order for you to
have confidence in your data and if you
don't put in
replicates at the beginning then you
will not have confidence in your data at
the end
it sounds like a very simple thing but
um
it's it's a it's a small gap between
like molecular biologists and
bioinformatics bioinformaticians so we
we strongly encourage that
bioinformaticians are involved at the
beginning of the project so some of the
efforts by diplomatics have been mainly
in awareness because when we do speak to
researchers or students
uh lightbulb sort of goes off where we
talk about you know project design um
so just spreading awareness that it is
important too or they they don't know
that you know it's something that they
should do to improve a bind repetition
at the beginning when they're planning
out their project so awareness so last
year
or not this year we had a little
campaign where we released
some lighter advents just to say you
know patrick shows do it right the first
time so
um as i was explaining some of the
projects that we've had that after the
data was already they were trying to do
patchwork where we're trying to roll
back and trying to get the best that we
can out of the
out of the data
and then uh another one is a project
without bioinformatics it's like a car
without wheels it's not going anywhere
so if your car does not have wheels it's
not going anywhere you can create your
project you can run the samples but
again if you don't if you want to count
apples you have to go and buy apples at
the market
um so this is also just an explanation
of how our marketplace works from our
brochure um
we sort of welcome you to it uh give you
why it's important explain our process
and then tell you what bioinformatics is
and then just say let's work together
okay and then bioinformatics training we
do this mainly through partners uh we
found that collaboration works well if
we don't have to reinvent the wheel we
won't they're already partners that are
doing it quite well um
and the aim really is to enable through
facilitating there are two main groups
that we are currently focusing on so
it's the bioinformaticians themselves
because maybe they may need to upskill
or get a new skill and the wetland
scientists um so
it's actually important for my molecular
biologists for example uh
to have an understanding of
bioinformatics so
we it might be good and well for us to
say they should include it at project
design but if they're also not aware of
you know downstream what needs to be in
place or how things work
then although they know it's important
they don't know how to consider it so
it's also important to train even if
it's going to be a basic training of
bioinformatics even if they're not going
to do their bioinformatics by themselves
it's important for them to at least have
an idea of how everything works that way
then they can um
best engage a bioinformatician to get
the best out of them
they will for example already know that
when i meet my implementation these are
the things that we need to cover or this
is the critical information that i need
to give them so here's just two examples
of training um through our partner at
thermo fisher and training through
partnering with
icgb
okay and then we're going to talk about
few future bioinformaticians
i'm just checking my time i'm out of
time but i'm i'm going to be done soon
so future bioinformaticians so these are
high school outreaches so human capacity
development so we focus a lot on low
resource schools um just to stimulate
interest in science and negate quite a
lot of misconceptions they have about
science and also to give them exposure
to this so they might not even know
certain things are aware so we take them
through very highly for um scientific
concepts and we end for example in them
doing like a mock chord and then i tell
them a little bit more about
bioinformatics and tell them all of the
other different science fields that are
involved from example from start
of strawberry dna extraction to the end
all right and then we're going to go
into the last one which is artisan
biomed
this is mainly focused on precision
medicine um
so
one one way to think about is that all
of the research that is being done is in
order to inform solutions so artisan
sort of takes it from the step where
they're now
utilizing these solutions but they have
a focus on precision medicine and they
also have a focus on people of african
descent because as we know from research
african populations or genomes are
underrepresented in research so that's
why the focus is there and it also
better serves their population group in
south africa
um
so precision medicine gives better
insights to disease and that's another
reason um
why why artisans sort of focus into this
better insights into disease in
particular for people of african descent
because if
the research on people of african
descent is underrepresented it means
that the solutions that come out do not
best um serve them
so they also have a training on to them
as well where they want to empower
clinicians and medical experts and
different stakeholders in precision
medicine
so here they're creating consume they're
creating sorry products for consumers
and clinicians
um
and it's usually a commercial product
so
i'm just going to go into a little bit
more about the bioinformatics with
respect to artisan so it is going to be
the same skill set that we use for the
cpgr but you have to refine it to make a
commercial project so initially you're
you're making um you're using it for
researchers so usually like a plot is
the product that you're giving them or
data or a bar graph but with
artisan because it is a product that's
going to a client it means that if it's
going to be a report it's going to be a
more refined and commercial report so in
addition to the programming skills you
have to have additional skills that help
you make it a product so for example
additional skills can be outsourced and
easily integrated it could be a
user user experience experience
engineer who comes in
and
the additional skills as well are not
mostly non-computational so sometimes
you just need a clinical geneticist
who's going to come in better inform
your product
so the initially as i said the initial
considerations are similar to the cpgr
um the pipelines everything that you're
doing is centered towards a product
right so you have to make it easy to use
it has to be well documented it has to
be easy to update the speed and the
storage and the quality are critical so
it's very different from academic
research where for example if you're if
you have a variant cola you can use an
open source variant color that's going
to take two days to run because two days
in um
two year masters is not a significant
amount of time but if you have a client
using an open source two days is like
already too much someone is waiting for
their result so speed storage and
quality are critical
so
there's a wide range of products and
services
it's simple as a co-fit test and
although the testing may be simple
providing it as a service is what's
complex so i'm just going to give a
quick example of one of their products
which is be happy to be you it's the
most comprehensive ancestry test in
africa with an international client base
so it's forward thinking it's a
forward-thinking effort because they
would like to use the rich informative
data to give further insights to people
so i'm just going to go through that so
this is actually an extract from my
report which shows um
my ancestry so here the bioinformatics
considerations as i've mentioned before
are going to be you have to test it's
going to be a complex pipeline you have
to test it you have to manage quite a
lot of things computing power analysis
and all of those things
and then um
for the last slide you're going to try
to extract as much reusable information
as you can so eg with this
ancestry report because you're using the
gsn it has a lot of informative markers
you can use some of the pharmacogenomic
markers to then give insights on
drug usage that's related to for example
in this one covet
yeah so although it's um
the data that comes is
rich and informative and it's complex to
interpret and report artisan has done
has had such a great start by taking
time to understand all of these
complexities
all right thank you
good morning
we are unfortunately out of time for
questions and we need to move to our
next speaker but thank you yet again for
being here this morning bye-bye thanks
well good morning and thanks to the
global community again for getting us
rolling for the day and we're now going
to roll into our americas session
leading to another amazing slate of
speakers
yesterday we really enjoyed several
surveys and uh maybe get to that yet
again today i want to welcome everyone
to the omics research americas session
and this is a time when we come to
discuss the advances in biomedical
research
and all the education hearing from
experts that represent our community in
the us we've been actively building out
a network of experts that can help lead
the way for young researchers and
students
to utilize omics technologies and the
data science in biomedical research and
our first speaker comes from a
background in pharmacy and will be
speaking about drug design and the
importance of omics technologies in this
type of transaction translational
research
he's a professor of medicinal chemistry
in the school of basic pharmaceutical
and toxological sciences college of
pharmacy at the university of louisiana
c the rama has obtained his phd in 1994
in molecular biophysics so that is an
amazing accomplishment his research
interests is in the area of peptide
motor i think i'm going to mess this up
peptidomotic based drug design as a
promising approach for developing
therapeutic agents for autoimmune
diseases inflammatory diseases and
cancer dr joyce i'm really excited to
hear your presentation and correct all
my bad pronunciations the floor is yours
sir
thank you can you all hear me
a little bit more volume would be great
how about it now
yeah a little closer like that would be
wonderful that'll get us going i will
try to come closer
um i'll share my slide can you see this
now
yes and you want you'll want it to go to
uh slideshow mode
yeah i went
your slideshow menu there you go
is it visible now
yes there you go perfect
yeah thank you so much uh i'd like to
thank the organizers and introducing me
and giving me an opportunity to speak
here
what i'm going to talk about is a kind
of a rational drug design
i'm not going to talk much of the
bioinformatics here uh you will see the
end product here
some of the information was obtained
from bioinformatics so my research
interest is has already introduced
grafted peptides for inhibition of
protein protein interaction
so i work on
designing some of the molecules to
target protein protein interaction here
at the school of pharmacy university of
louisiana monroe
so just a disclosure some of the
molecules are developed are applied for
a patent one application is already
approved
just to give a brief review of drug
discovery
we start with the medicinal chemistry it
could be from natural product or
rational drug design
and we go to test them in the test tubes
and then in small animals
if we get positive results we go through
the toxicology
formulation and then apply for new i
know investigational new drug
application
and then the drug goes through the
clinical trial if it passes approved by
the fda
so you can see that
the drug is here i am somewhere here so
i'm at the basic part
let's look at the protein protein
interaction
so proteins you know that the end
product of the information pathway so
you do the bioinformatics and
we work on the proteins
uh it is known that
you know 50 000 different proteins work
in each cell in human body
and you can imagine it's 50 000 proteins
if they interact with one another there
are nearly 600 000 protein protein
interaction that carry out
any cellular process that is happening
right now in your body so that is an
estimate
so if you look at the you know protein
protein interaction
kind of map this is just one map you can
see there are a lot of interaction
between these proteins
so what we are going to look at is
when this protein protein interaction is
deregulated it results in the disease
state so we modulate the protein protein
interaction by inhibiting them
i am going to talk about the abdominal
growth factor separate protein protein
interaction here
uh the human apparent growth factor
there are four epidermal growth factor
receptors known egfr are r1 r2 r3 and
her4
so these are kind of a membrane tyrosine
kinase receptors
upon binding of the ligand the underbody
conformation change when the undergo
conformation change the dimerize that's
where the protein protein interaction
takes place upon dimerization they
undergo phosphorylation
and send the signal for cell growth
differentiation and so on so that is a
normal process
but when this normal process is
deregulated due to mutation our over
expression of these receptors
more protein protein interaction takes
place
and then that leads to uncontrolled
growth of cell which is cancer
so egfr's are important in cancer
among these
her one to her four
her two doesn't have any known ligand
so since we are talking about cancer i
just want to show the statistics
basically you can see on the left side
the highest number is breast cancer
followed by prostate and lung and
colorectal
but if you look at the estimated death
lung cancer is the highest followed by
colorectal pancreatic cancer and breast
so since the number of deaths is high
we need to find new ways of developing
drugs for cancer because current
therapies ultimately within two to five
years develop resistance and some
patients don't have much time
so if you look at the information here
this information came from
bioinformatics as i said i'm the end
user
so they studied a lot of
information in patients about different
types of lung cancer among them 85
percent in non-small cell lung cancer
among the lung cancer and then they look
at the genetic mutation and the genetic
drivers
that actually drive this cancer
large part is still unknown in non-small
cell lung cancer
but the remaining part keras
and then egfr
these are well known
there will be over expression of these
receptor or mutation in these receptor
or deregulation
and then we have her2 erv2braf and so on
so what i'm going to look at is egfr and
her2 today it's one of the major drivers
of this cancer
so if you look at the structure
these are the extracellular domain here
transmembrane domain and the kinase
domain
the four receptors are shown if you look
at her1 her3 and her4 they have ligand
binding site whereas her2 doesn't have
any known ligand and the ligand binding
site is not that open
so in another case also
her one
and
her two her four are kinase active but
her three doesn't have much kinase
activity
so that indicates that one doesn't bind
to lag and other doesn't have much
venous activity that means these
receptors have to work together in an
orchestrated process that's what you
call protein protein interaction
and these receptors the extracellular
domain exists in closed conformation or
open conformation you can see the closed
conformation here i just give the
example here how the domain 4 and domain
2 interact with one another
blocking the dimerization arm we call
this demeritation or socialization arm
once the ligand binds here it opens up
you can see that the dimerization arm is
open now the two proteins interact with
one another giving the signal so that's
what you call protein protein
interaction
so now what is the clinical importance
of this
these dimers and protein protein
interaction her2 her3 demeritation is
important in 30 percent of breast cancer
and egfr her2 are also over expressed in
30 of non-smalls or lung cancer
if both the dimers are present
then you can see that the survival rate
is very poor in non-small cell lung
cancer in some cases i short of nine
months if both are expressive so
remember that egf for her to hurt to her
three protein protein interaction is
very very important
how do they measure the status of this
of course the method is over expression
of proteins are over expression of genes
so that's where the bioinformatics come
into major play and they classify them
three plus two plus and one plus
depending on positive or negative
now
what is the clinical importance of this
protein protein interaction we wanted to
check the dgf for her to hurt her three
as well as egfr
we took the tissue sample from
the
cancer center here in stupor
and then did something called proximity
ligation assay in the search say if the
two proteins are close together
very near to one another and they are
interacting we can direct primary
secondary antibodies to them and the
secondary antibodies are actually
targeted dna fragments which can
complement to one another and then they
can do rolling circle amplification so
basically and then detect using the
probe dna probe in this case it's a red
dot
so basically if the two proteins are
close to one another interacting you can
detect them using this assay
and here has shown egfr egf or her2 her2
protein protein interaction you can see
from the probe the number of red dots in
easier for her to her23 more compared to
egf or homodimer so heterodimers are
very important in non-sponsor lung
cancer
that is the clinical significance
so we use some cell lines which are
derived from human
you can see skbr3 breast cancer cell
line
and mcf7 breast cancer cell line but
these two are different hearth to
positive or too negative
and bt474 breast cancer is a line and
lung cancer cell line which show three
plus that means are two positive so
these are some controls we use for
non-her2 cell line
so now
in egfr related
or her2-related non-sponsor lung cancer
there are three mechanisms
r2 protein expression or to gene
amplification how to gene mutation
apart from that
mutation can happen in egfr and double
mutation can happen around met
amplification so all this information
came from bioinformatics data from human
patient samples so we use this data to
design the drugs
so now what is the current targeted
therapy for non-small cell lung cancer
and different types of cancer targeting
egf around her2
we have antibodies targeting
extracellular domain
and kinase domain lot of
small molecules but remember these
kinase they are not specific for
particular kinase even though they are
somewhat ex to some extent specific but
they develop resistance because kinase
is an enzyme it changes the active site
so within two years all these develop
resistance hence there is a need to find
better ways to treat the non-small cell
lung cancer
so our idea is to inhibit the protein
protein interaction so we have egfr her2
her23 her to her poor dimers if you look
here on the left side her2 interacts
with any of the other egfr partners
so we call it it readily dances with any
of these molecules it is always an open
conformation
so it forms actually protein protein
interaction sending the signal for cell
growth suppose in the case of cancer we
target this protein protein interaction
site which is domain 4 here
using a compound here
we inhibit the protein protein
interaction there is no signal for cell
growth and hence
therapeutic effect for cancer that is
the idea so how do we design
i'm a medicinal chemist we look at the
protein protein interaction and look at
the structure of the protein so here is
the structure of herb2 domain four
and it interacts with herceptin was the
antibody we took that crystal structure
you can see arginine a positive charge
residue interacting with the negative
charge additive here
central part a hydrophobic interaction
and hydrogen bonding we kind of measured
this and formed a template here arginine
spacer hydrophobic group coh so based on
that we designed a compound with a
rational drug design arginine ah
naphthalene group with a no
peptidomimetic and then phenylalanine
here we tested them in cell line which
over express r2 which does not over
express r2 so there is around 800
nanomolar and in non her2 positive cells
16 nanomolar so there is a selectivity
here so with that lead compound we also
look at the protein protein interaction
of egf for homodimer egfr
her2heterodiamond
you can see here
the protein protein interaction site is
dominated by leucine tryptophan
phenylalanine and thionine so these are
hydrophobic amino acid then we look at
the literature
literature they have found that they
have studied several thousand proteins
and look at the protein protein
interaction site
these are called hot spot residues
you can see the tryptophan arginine
tyrosine phenylalanine isolation leucine
if you look at our compound arginine and
tryptophan analog phenylalanine so
hotspot residues are there we believe
that because our compound has hot spot
residues it interacts and inhibits the
protein protein interaction
so this is a small peptidomimetic if you
put this in the o it is going to be
digested by the enzymes so we modify
them so we can modify them with
different functional groups d amino acid
substitution or cyclization or end
capping
so i'm not going to talk details about
that how we do that here are different
ways i did in-terms modification
c-terminal modification
other peptidomic modifications
cyclization
so we did all that studied several
compounds when you want to cyclize we
can't just cyclize a you know protein
chain a small peptide
it'll flip or snap off
so then what we have to do is just like
a plumber we use particular amino acid
at a particular site like a t joint or a
l joint here
so in this case designed based on the
previous compound you can see arginine
naphthal group phenylalanine aspartic
acid we use this we repeated this
sequence and then cyclize one side the
other side just like a plumber uses lrt
shape connection is proline proline
protein proline is known to induce what
they call beta sheet in peptides and
proteins so why did i repeat this
i repeated this because there is a good
chance of binding if both sides have the
same amino acid residues
and peptidomic residues
so we did that hoping to get better
binding
we tested them on how to positive or to
negative cell line you can see that in
lung cancer cell line
the activity of ic50 is 18 nanomolar
if you take the herb to negative it is
50 and 40 micro molar so there is a huge
difference so our compound is cyclic now
it work
now
our idea is binding to her2 protein
domain four how do we check that with
the surface plasmon resonance here we
have a chip dextron chip on which we can
immobilize the protein
so on the immobilizer protein we pass
our compound 18
if they bind they give the signal using
refractive index here you can see that
there is a incremental index as we
increase as we increase the
concentration of the peptide
and then we wanted to see whether it
binds to domain four we took this domain
four in particular and titrated our
compound you can see that it binds
and then we use the control
peptidometric it doesn't bind so this
clearly says that our compound in fact
binds to domain four and probably
inhibits the protein protein interaction
but how do we know protein protein
interaction is inhibited
once again we did the proximity ligation
assay
egfr har2 and her2h3 both the dimers you
can see the positive control there are a
lot of dimers here there each red dot
corresponding to a r2 ej for dimer this
is the negative control one of the
antibody was not added and then when we
add our compound in different amounts
you can see number of red dots compared
to the control decreased so we can see
that there is a decrease in the number
of red dots indicating protein protein
interaction is inhibited not only her to
egfr or to her three you can see that it
inhibits both egfr2 her23 interaction so
it's a dual inhibitor if you remember my
slide in the beginning in lung cancer
and breast cancer both are important
so we are inhibiting the both
so now that is a peptidometric or a
peptide most of the peptide have a
limitation they have to be administered
via iv
so how do you make orally available
peptide drugs that is my question
so for that i want to go to a story here
so this happened long time ago till
1960s a red cross doctor went to congo
and he saw that some of the women were
drinking a tea from a weed
to increase the childbirth
he studied that what is that ingredient
he found that it's a collateral b1 a
uteroactive peptide then he wondered how
a peptide can be stable by boiling and
drinking via oral road was stable
but he could not solve it
until 1995 david craig university of
queensland australia saw the structure
of that he said it is an unusual
structure a cyclic structure with
multiple disulfide bond and 3d structure
looks like this so these are very stable
structure you can boil them you can put
in acid you can put them in trypsin they
don't digest very easily
so those can be used as a template for
design of drugs to make stable so in
this particular case my compound is here
i did not go for cyclotide i went for
another peptide which is stable which is
from sunflower trypsin inhibitor from
another you know plant sunflower seeds
so you can see the sunflower trypsin
inhibitor structure here a cyclic
structure with a disulfide bond and
looks like a beta sheet structure here
so those are comparable so what we did
was we should not disturb the disulfide
bond here that is very very important
so remaining part we replaced with some
of the amino acids and peptidomatix here
that's why i call it grafting because i
took some amino acid here and grafted
onto stable peptide so now we have a
active compound we have a stable
compound so the resulting will be active
stable compound
so
i just want to go through the design the
design cannot be done very easily we
have to go through structural biology
and protein structure and compare 3d
structure
just to show you a sample this is sfda
peptide this is compound 18. the
grafting is shown in yellow here we
tried different possibilities here
and then when we tested them in cells
how two positive cells you can see the
one of the compound sfta g5
280 nanomolar it works and it tested
them calorie cell line which is
non-small cell lung cancer
73 nanomolar in mcf7 which is her to
negative which is actually 25 micro
molar we have also a control compound
which doesn't work
so a compound which is grafted works
once again i come back here and show
that it binds to
r2 protein and her2 domain 4. we did the
surface plasmon resonance you can see
here concentration dependent increase
and how to domain for it specifically
binds here and control peptidomic
doesn't bind so once again you look at
the protein protein interaction between
herbivory egf for her2 you can see the
control lot of red fluorescence and you
added the compound thread fluorescence
is decreased based on the concentration
similarly here how to egfr so our
compound binds to grafted peptide binds
to actually how to dominant four inhibit
both protein protein interaction of egfr
her2 r2 r3
so now so so far i talked about the 2d
cell culture what is the 3d cell culture
effect
remember that most of the cancer drugs
fail because of the 2d cell culture
2d cell culture doesn't have a matrix it
is just they expose it too much the
media as well as the compound so
compound can kill very easily but actual
tumors are different so we wanted to see
in 3d spheroid model we grew mcf7 bt474
a549 calcial three you can see these
three form very good spheroids but
calorie form loosely forms periods we
went ahead and treated them you can see
sfda g5 compared to the lapatinib and
the doxorobisin and the control
you can see here sfda g5 is here
reducing the tumor growth in 3d model
similarly in calorie cell lines which
loosely forms ferrite we can see
compared to the control or compound in a
concentration dependent manner inhibits
the growth of 3ds period
so we also did the pl assay nobody has
reported this before you can see number
of red dots here adding the compound the
number of red dot decreased here under
control here
so now with the cellular work we went
ahead with the xenograph model of lung
cancer
and here is the calorie cells injected
into new mice
10 to 15 days third order of cancer
and then we treat them via iv three
times a week and we use participants of
our antibodies as control
and here you can see the graph tumor
volume versus the base of treatment this
is the control which is shown in green
and then sfta g5 and pertussism often
the move as well as partisan of
antibodies which work for her2 positive
cancer
so you can clearly see that there is a
decrease in the tumor volume by treating
our compound we did the proximity
ligation essay again to look at the
protein protein interaction in tissue
sample of the tumor
you can see that the number of red dots
more in control and red dot decrease in
our compound and phosphorylation here
decrease the phosphorylation of p her2
in a concentration dependent manner
so now our ultimate question is is the
grafted peptide orally available
so we use in vivo model here with the
calorie cells
and via oral gowage we administer 50 and
30 mg two doses
twice a week for four weeks we have a
control and a positive control part of
the montrose's map
and you can see here the change in the
tumor volume this is the control and 30
mg per kg we did not shows much of the
significance but 50 mg per kg showed
significant compared to the control
overly available so we believe that the
peptides can be made orally available by
grafting technology
and overall
a lot of antibodies
as well as tyrosine kinase are targeted
for non-small cell lung cancer as well
as breast cancer egf for positive ones
and most of these tyrosine kinase
develop resistance
most of these antibodies have problem
so what i have done here i have targeted
a unique site domain 4 of her2
and eg acquire her23 which inhibits the
protein protein interaction not only
that it inhibits both dimers it's a dual
inhibitor
so with that
i would like to acknowledge the
following people graduate students who
graduated and some of the postdocs and
graduate students in my lab
and the core facilities purchased the
mob transfers my option from general
tech and dr sita with us at lsu helped
me to carry out some immunology
immunoassays i didn't show that here
and here is my team for this project and
funding from r01 grant from nci
and thank you if you have any questions
i left some time thank you very much
thank you dr joyce yeah we we happen to
have a few questions for you can you
hear me okay sure
all right great so
what is the significance of
peptodiomatic based drug design
um basically we use peptidometric
because as you know that peptides if you
eat a protein is digested in the body
first in the acid in the stomach ph one
to two
and then a lot of proteases near the
breast border membrane as well as in the
lumen before you know it goes to the
intestine before it is absorbed so most
of the peptide protein drugs
basically
cannot be given via oral
even iv most of the drugs can be
digested by enzymes and the
probably 20 30 minutes
so that's why we use something called
peptidometrics
where we introduce organic functional
groups in this particular case i use
naphthalene group
in there
so that is the significance of that
making it stable for iv or oral
administration
which the peptides cannot be done
what are some of the limitations
associated with those type of drug
designs
uh limitation is once again even though
it's a peptide mimetic you can see
particular
enzymes can cut them at a particular
site
even though it is cyclized there is a
possibility
and the disulfide bond can be broken
so those are the limitation other thing
is these peptides can are small enough
they can pass through the kidney
filtration faster
so that's why i use something called
grafted peptide that means these grafted
peptides are quite stable
so hopefully you have seen that i could
give them orally the grafted peptide can
be you know
uh resolve the limitation of these
peptide membranes also
aren't you so for someone who is
interested to start working on the
peptodematic based drug design where do
they start for theory and practice
uh there are several books
so one can study rational drug design
what i do here is a rational drug design
so there are two ways the natural
compounds like golden days you can
extract the compound from different
sources
check them and then filter them and
purify them but this is you go through
the bioinformatics
structural biology
and then design so for this kind of work
to be done
10 years of bioinformatics
molecular biology structural biology
work has to be done but now that is
short on you can see that bioinformatics
can be done with next generation
sequencing very fast
molecular biology is done
so basically i would suggest that you
learn some structural biology with the
basic bioinformatics data
and then see how much data is there
about the structure of any of this
then
start designing that means you have to
spend a lot of time with molecular
modeling you need to know how to
visualize the protein structure
the cavity
and then basically learn from there
fortunately i am actually the american
association of pharmaceutical scientists
had asked me to write a book on
peptide-based drug design
me myself with the collaboration with
others so we have written a book it is
going to come out in couple of months
i can give that information i have
explained in detail step by step how to
design this
but still you need bioinformatics
biochemistry structural biology
understanding
look at the protein structure that is
where you start
hope that would be wonderful to have i'm
sure if it's submitted we can figure out
the right people to get it and get it
published
thank you dr joyce for your remarkable
work in immunology cancer and the heart
disease work it was fascinating to see
all of that stuff on the screen i'm not
sure i understood it all but it's
wonderful thank you so much and we
really appreciate you being on today
thank you so much before we move thank
you before we move on to our next
speaker let me remind you that we made
an announcement yesterday about our
upcoming hackathon and that we will
focus on this type of metagenomic data
in the health and wellness domain now
that site is still being finalized but
later today we'll be sharing more
details about that event in november
as well as providing updates over the
next few weeks so make sure you stay
around and uh we'll we'll get you that
information next let's meet dr ray kanan
she's going to be speaking on
bioinformatics in the beauty industry
dr karen kanan has an phd in
computational biology from the wiseman
institute of science in israel she was
the royal society dorothy hodgins fellow
at cambridge university with over 20
years of experience in computational
cancer genomics
now inspired by the paradigm shift in
the one size fits all to precision
medicine
rhea envisions
similar changes in wellness and beauty
so she co-founded life gnome an
award-winning company that leverages
biological physiological and behavioral
data to personalize wellness
interventions in the prevention in the
preventive health nutrition and personal
care beauty industries
ray is both a researcher
academician as well as entrepreneur rhea
we can't wait to hear how this type of
data the technologies and all that are
being used to bring about new treatments
but we also hope to hear in other
domains as well as beauty welcome
thank you very much do you hear me okay
perfect yes we can hear you fine and
your presentation can be seen well thank
you perfect
um so many thanks for the introduction
and thanks to the organizers for
inviting me
so this is going to be a very subjective
overview
on the increasingly important role
that bioinformatics plays in the beauty
industry
my name is raya hanin and i'm a
scientific co-founder of life
genomics ai wellness company
so some of you may be asking
what bioinformatics has to do with
beauty
actually a lot
so when i started preparing for this
talk i quickly realized that
applications of bioinformatics in the
beauty industry have grown tremendously
in the last couple of years
so i will highlight the most
prominent trends
and that have been driven by
bioinformatics i will give some examples
of big companies
and startups in this area
and also we'll talk a little bit about
the challenges that
bioinformatics faces in the beauty
industry
uh so to put things into perspective
the beauty industry is actually huge
it is strong it's
getting only stronger
and it's predicted to exceed
780 billion dollars in about five years
so what is beauty industry
it actually covers a wide variety of
personal care products skin care hair
care cosmetics fragrances beauty tech
services various related functions so
these figures do not include dermatology
but our conversation is relevant to
dermatology as well
okay
so let's talk about skin
as a computational biologist
i view skin our largest organ as a
complex system of interacting biological
components and the exposure
so the exposure is everything our skin
interacts with that's water environment
temperature pollutants toxins and also
all the products that we put on our skin
from basic soap to very sophisticated
skincare
and obviously skin is a reflection of
all the physiological processes
that are going on inside our bodies so
skin is also our
immune organ as well
so uh out of 20 000 proteins human
proteins
70
are actually expressed in skin
and about 500 proteins have elevated
expression and skin compared to other
tissues
and these proteins are regulatory and
signaling their receptors and enzymes so
understanding their roles in skin
homeostasis and skin aging is extremely
important
furthermore there are various non-coding
rnas from small
rnas like micrornas to long non-coding
rnas that contribute to skin aging and
skin disorders and actually we still
don't know much about their functions
then of course there is our second
scheme
then of course i don't know there is
message to me or to general
okay
um
so then of course there is our second
scheme the microbiome so these are all
the millions of microbes that live on
our skin
and they too change with aging with
environments and various phenotypes for
example dry skin as i will show a couple
of examples
acne and so on
so for a while studies on the skin
microbiome have lagged behind research
on gut microbiome but actually the
beauty industry and the whole research
on skin is quickly catching up
so obviously um
you know all these considerations are as
important
for hair
as they are for skin
and
as you can imagine lots of research is
going into understanding hair health and
hair brain
and hair boldness
so what if we could predict and reverse
for example hair loss
but i will mainly talk about skin
here
um okay so
in other words there is a complex
interplay between
human
proteins human rnas and microbiomes
and also um different fungi and viruses
that live on our skin at the same time
microbiomes produce and release
different metabolites and peptides
and all this complex network of
interactions protect the skin from the
environment and interacts with the
extrasome and
skin care ingredient
uh i call it systems biology of beauty
so you see here
the uh
unilever logo
and this figure was actually taken from
a special skin microbiome issue from
nature
journal sponsored by unilever
in fact all major personal care
companies from unilever procter gamble
l'oreal heavily invest in
bioinformatics and genomics sciences
they all actively work uh on generating
proprietary genomics data sets
sophisticated data analysis methods and
they develop computational models
and pipelines
but this has not always been the case
a few years back that's another
article from the
from nature journal called molecular
beauty
they cite
a prominent dermatologist from a leading
hospital in boston who says that until
actually a couple of decades ago
the beauty industry was almost allergic
to science
the common perception was that consumers
were scared off and uninterested in
science so companies didn't want
this word to be associated with their
products but that aversion started to
melt
with the advent of genomics which not
only transformed research but also
captured the public imagination
and
in this
paper they cite a scientist from the
brand olay at consumer goods company
proctem gamble
who says that
over the years we've converged on an
understanding that we should be doing
really deep biology on the skin aging
process and on products that can be used
to improve skin health it's just like
any other biological endpoint
that a pharmaceutical company would go
after
so just like pharma just like in pharma
bioinformatics and machine learning i
expected to make the search for new
ingredients new formulas quicker cheaper
and more effective
so perhaps initially the beauty industry
was nearly following what pharma was
doing
but just because of the nature of its
business
and willingness of consumers to actually
contribute their data
uh so-called citizen science the beauty
industry with the help of bioinformatics
and machine learning can actually move
faster make more discoveries in
particular in
anti-aging and longevity science i will
give an example of such a company
in a few
minutes so i will now
highlight a couple of major trends in
the beauty industry
that have been
driven by bioinformatics
so firstly
an unstoppable trend is
synthetic beauty sustainability and
ingredient transparency
so biotechnologies are increasingly
impacting their production of beauty
ingredients from algae
to
marine based components
companies produce some ingredients in
the lab and these ingredients
can be some commonly used
collagen quality and palm oil
to some rare ingredients such as for
example
unique scents of roses without actually
relying on expensive rose petals that's
ginkgo kobayan
perhaps the most fascinating example of
a new generation of beauty company
is archaea
uh which recently received funding of 78
million dollars from chanel javadon and
vcs and the goal of the company is to
create sustainable
previously inaccessible ingredients
for beauty industry through what they
call expressive biology
so this is a screenshot from their
website
where they call biology the most
sophisticated technology on the planet
it has unparalleled precision and scale
that modern means have never been able
to replicate
at archaea they combine technology from
the past and present bridging biology
with dna sequencing bioinformatics
fermentation
and storytelling to create new products
experiences
for beauty
another huge trend
is beauty further integrating with the
whole wellness economy
uh pandemic obviously accelerated this
trend the whole trend of self-care
focusing on one's health wellness with
an added spotlight on immunity
and there is an overlap here with
nutrigenomics personalized nutrition
and also special emphasis on sleep and
mental health
there is increasing interest and
research on longevity
so people are planning to live longer
and they want to look
younger
and in this respect
skin aging is obviously the most
recognizable and often the most kind of
psychologically difficult aspect of
energy
at the same time skin aging is
potentially also one of the most
amenable for
intervention
prevention and rejuvenation
so skin actually can be regarded as an
ideal model for studying tissue aging
and i'm going to talk about a specific
example here a company called one skin
um
which i find absolutely fascinating so
what they did initially
they um analyzed publicly available data
actually that's methylation data and
here's all the data sets that they've
analyzed
and they developed
a
highly accurate skin specific
skin specific methylone
a biological clock for skin
so
they showed uh you know they validated
it they showed
uh on an independent cohort its accuracy
what they did next
was
they used this
method as a screening platform for
different compounds
they screened hundreds of peptides and
they found one they call it peptide 14
that effectively decreased chronological
aging
uvb
radiation by modulating longevity and
senescence pathways
so basically they showed that this
specific peptide promoted skin health
reduced senescent cell markers as well
as the biological age of samples
they showed next that this specific
peptide actually outperformed the
current golden standard in the
anti-aging skin care the retinal
treatment
so and then this scientist four female
phds from brazil originally
they
raised funds and they started
a company called one scheme and you can
actually now buy
uh their products
uh
which they call skimped supplements
the product is unisex and it's for skin
and body and uh i highly recommend it
it's very good
um
okay so the next trend um in beauty is
end in medicine as well is
personalization obviously it's not a new
concept
but it's getting more sophisticated
it started with quizzes
it's moved to
selfies
various skin and hair scanning devices
and
now it is
powered by biology so biology is the
ultimate frontier of personalization
and genetics and microbiome are driving
this trend
so here i would like to highlight two
studies
the first one is relatively old um
2009
and
it's looked at
many hundreds of
tweens
and
identified that about 60 of skin age is
actually determined by our genetics
while 40
is determined by the environment
another study
uh followed
thousand people for over 10 years
and found that actually some people age
much faster than the others and this is
visible in their physical
characteristics as well as in their skin
features so the authors of this study
built an ai predictor using genetics and
i have other biomarkers
and they quantified aging in younger
people thus allowing for intervention
and prevention
so
there are
numerous genome-wide association studies
on genetics of skin
skin health skin aging
there are snips
identified to be connected to different
skin features such as early wrinkles or
photo aging
so this information can be used to
predict
not immediately observable skin age
and several companies
including lifenom the company that i
co-founded offer beauty-focused dna
testing kits informing consumers on
their genomic skin traits
curate ingredients and products and
develop personalized
products and services
so dna tests are becoming a commodity
right i'm talking about genotyping tests
and
in the us you can buy them in your local
cvs store
probably over 30 million people have
taken um at home ancestry tests and as
you all know the
if sheep contains about 600 000 snips
with imputation that's a few million so
it's a lot of information that can be
used
by beauty companies to look into skin
health and skin
aging so lots of
very interesting discoveries can be made
here
so it's life known
we are developing a
beauty personalized platform
that uses genomics ai
um
well we use machine learning you
probably heard the joke that if it's
written in python it's probably machine
learning if it's written in powerpoint
it's ai
so actually when you work with beauty
companies everything is ai
um so jokes aside we built a huge um
knowledge base
that integrates data from thousands of
studies including uh gene expression
studies
and what our platform does it utilizes
consumer dna with the survey
and
informs consumers about their potential
risks and offers uh ingredient
recommendation product recommendation we
also collect feedback and obviously
build new insights we identify
new genetic based
features for example sensitivities to
specific ingredients such as retinol
i will now switch gears
and talk about
microbiome
so this is probably the biggest trend in
beauty
uh the hottest trend so cosmetic
formulators are developing their own
microbiome franchises they design
uh health enhancing skin care products
that contain bacteria
bacteria extracts or ingredients that
are meant to enhance skin microbe
activity
and then instagram and beauty magazines
are educating their readers what are
prebiotics postbiotics and probiotics
and as i mentioned before all major
personal care companies
have been working in this area and also
a number of very innovative startups
and indie brands have launched
products that use microbiome
so
this is from a company from a dutch
company dsm
and they developed an ingredient that
they called epibatium beauty
uh this specific ingredient uh relieving
skin dryness
and they showcase a clinical study
uh where
participants use this ingredient and
kind of the
the bad bacteria
was decreasing with using usage of this
ingredient while the good bacteria was
increasing
interestingly
uh tech companies are also partnering
with beauty companies and attempting to
solve
similar problems this is an example of
ibm partnering with unilever
and again an article from nature journal
and they also study a similar problem
they study
an issue of skin hydration here they use
explainable ai
and they identify a signature of
microbes
that
that is associated with skin trainers
so that's i think is very interesting uh
partnerships between tech companies and
views
uh and as i mentioned there was a number
of very innovative startups um in this
field
uh s biomedic symbiom dermala each of
these companies claims to harness the
power of microbiome and address
skin conditions like acne rosacea
and different features related to skin
aging
other companies like skin trust
sequential skin dr elsa jungman of a
skin microbiome test
it's a big business
and
at the same time it's data collection
it's citizen science and it enables
future discoveries so needless to say
that behind all this brand messaging and
marketing all this work is enabled by
bioinformatics and in fact some of these
companies have
bioinformaticians among their founders
so that's another example of a company
jivo don
and in addition to doing taxonomic
analysis
excuse me
they actually uh explore which jobs the
microbiota can do so they do functional
microbiome analysis
um
okay so bioinformatics powers microbiome
trends in beauty
so all these companies
require
development improvements and maintenance
of robust bioinformatics pipelines for
efficient and fast processing of
large-scale metagenomics data
so they needed to detect known species
identifying new species and so on and
bioinformaticians would appreciate that
it requires infrastructure for storage
for the usage and so on
so and all the tools that bioinformatics
has developed are also required here
from machine learning supervised
unsupervised analysis pathways analysis
and so on
and for those interested in challenges
there are plenty
discovering functions of species new
microbial pathways metabolites and so on
so i see that
the notion here that my time is
almost coming up so i'll skip couple of
things here
and kind of
say that there are lots of pros working
um as bioinformatician in the beauty
industry it's easy to collect data it's
past turnaround
it's still a new area of application
there are many challenging problems to
be solved
and lots of opportunities at the same
time
uh there are many proprietary data sets
lots of secrecy
fast turnaround you can see your
failures fast too and even if you have
great science you also need to learn
some storytelling branding and marketing
so you need to learn some beauty like
and i'll skip here and
happy to answer your questions and
please connect with me
discuss with me if you have any interest
in bioinformatics in beauty many thanks
for your attention
thank you we that was really interesting
um the personalization it's going to be
interesting to see where that goes in
the next couple years if you want to
pull your powerpoint down i do have a
couple questions for you
um why do you think metagenomics
specifically is so important for the
beauty and wellness research and then
how can it be integrated with other
types of omics data
uh why is it important oh sorry yes stop
share yeah
um
i mean it's um there are several i mean
in terms of beauty it's easy to measure
somehow um
people are not people actually willing
to share their skin microbiome they're
not as willing to share their dna but
they are really interested to learn what
microbes live on their skin
um
in terms of challenges i think the
challenges are the same as
yesterday somebody from sweden was
talking about integrating different
layers of multi-omics data challenges
are the same
as in any other area but i kind of
predict that integration in the beauty
industry will happen a bit faster again
because people are willing to learn
more
uh about their skin they want to look
healthy they want to look young so there
is this younger younger i'll take
younger
me too yes
um
so that's kind of
what i think okay
what's the integration look like
what's the integration looks like the
integration like for other type of omics
some maybe some fields or whatever
uh it can be um
something that you know it's not just
easy to detect using one type of data
uh like for example microbiome genetics
or metabolomics and transcriptomics
but by combining two types of data you
can actually identify the sort of the
compound bio compound score if you like
so if you take biomarkers from different
types of mixed data
i have a question from the audience i'm
sorry a question from the audience are
you using ancestry data in the research
for instance from the gsa
um ancestry as in you mean in terms of
ethnic differences in aging yes
okay
yeah
yeah
okay
um
there are other fields in the beauty
industry where bioinformatics research
is actively conducted do you have any
examples
other areas other than those that are
mentioned
i mean all the skin disorders uh skin
conditions acne rosacea
sensitivity these are all huge um areas
where you know lots of research is going
on yes
okay
have environmental issues such as global
warming pollution contributed to the
growth of the beauty industry and then
if so how does bioinformatics help in
the process
excellent question yes um
so i mentioned i think in the first
trend was the
sustainability concern and this is why
uh bioinformatics and synthetic biology
they're working on developing new
sustainable ingredients
obviously
and this is going to grow this is i
think we're just at the kind of
beginning of this development
and in terms of pollution and global
warming obviously it does affect
our skin
uh that's for sure and
again i just today saw an article how
the anti-pollution skincare is going to
grow in the next couple of years
yeah definitely a huge huge uh area
where do you think the uh
this will be the last question the
future of personalized skin care
solutions where do you think that's
headed
i think it's actually heading where you
know you'll have your little station
kind of at home
and
you know your microbiome and
meta metabolomics of your skin will be
measured at certain regular intervals
will be sent to some center
and then you will receive uh you know
your personalized products for your skin
depending on seasonality depending where
you are in a big city in the countryside
etc so definitely we're heading that
direction so it will be a few more years
before that but
the vector is there yes
well very good well thank you again dr
kanan for your incredible work in this
field
congratulations on the success of your
award-winning company thank you much for
being here today thank you thank you
you're welcome i want to remind everyone
i want to remind our audience about
signing up for our e-learning portal
if you've
not yet signed up if you've not yet
registered i've just posted the link in
the chat box
for your free learning account if you've
not yet registered i encourage you to do
so again it is free and sets you on a
path to learning about this fascinating
body of research and discovery
sign up now at the link and then click
the register for free or the sign up
button uh the accurate one on the page
thank you so much for that short
commercial
so it's been called the final frontier
space that is and we're hoping that dr
joseph borg takes us where no speaker
has gone before in this case
space omics joseph is an academic
molecular geneticist and the principal
investigator at the university of malta
primary interest is the understanding of
developmental globin gene switching
regulation and control of uracil
properties i'm not even going to try to
do that one again i'll let you correct
me on that and the next generation
sequencing tools to uncover locked
secrets of life he recently led malta's
first space program for life science in
space
through the multitest program and he
also actively participates
in the analysis working group at the
nasa gene lab for multiomics and on the
topical team for european space agency
space omix
joseph my apologies for the star trek
introduction i'm sure i'm the first
person that's ever connected your name
with that right
yeah indeed indeed uh do you hear me
correctly i hope you do i can hear you
just fine and if you want to go ahead
and go to slideshow mode i'm going to
get out of your way it's all yours so
thanks so much uh to the organizers for
for the invitation which i gladly
accepted and i feel really hard to say
honored to be part uh of this of this
omics research symposium because indeed
omics is one aspect of my research work
that i really enjoy doing
so yes so so so background aside
and focusing on blood research and blood
omix today i'm talking to you about
mallet program which is a life science
research program
in space
and this is centered around
diabetes type 2 with special interest on
human skin microbiomes skin microbiomes
that are found on diabetic food ulcers
and i will explain
why we study these in the context of
space
on earth and how we compare the two
with each other so as a brief uh intro
let me just minimize the views here yes
so so all of this
the research program the mallet program
started at the end of 2020 so during the
pandemic years here in malta i had an
idea
to sort of conduct or take my next level
of comic science in the context of space
it all came about serendipitously over
the internet over linkedin
having the idea and then meeting meeting
a group of people that can actually
bring the idea to fruition and at that
time i had i had
taken the idea to our ministry of
foreign and international affairs the
idea being that that sending an
experiment to space could not be more
foreign or more international than this
the idea was
well received
and from there basically we we continued
forward with our program so a very quick
quick rough shot about the program so we
did a number of pilot studies in our
labs
on earth in malta to ensure that the
human skin tissue samples the way they
are preserved the way they are prepared
in buffer that the bacteria the whole
microbiome is maintained for a number of
weeks or months and they do not lose
their viability and that we are able to
both culture them back on agar plates
and also we are able to extract dna and
tested by by ngs mostly 16s typing to
determine the classification and the
taxonomy of the bacteria
this project ties in very strongly with
an ongoing phd program of my student who
is testing roughly 150 or 200 diabetic
patients from malta so we only had a
selective number
of patients that we also progressed to
to the space study
uh this work was done in malta and also
in belgium where we assemble our
so-called biocube i will show this later
on
basically the cube itself
is shipped from europe to the states
from cape canaveral there it is
assembled on a spacex rocket spacex as
some of you or most of you know
travels to to outer space and in this
case
docks with the space station
once it is present or docked with the
space station the astronauts get to work
they take out the cube they assemble it
to a particular place where the cube is
powered up and from here from malta from
our control room or center we are able
to connect to the cube and follow the
experiment so to say
broadly speaking the experiment per se
is not too exciting to monitor because i
mean the bacteria and the skin tissue
don't really change microscopically or
visually except that you see everything
uh floating around but the real work is
done when the cube is returned back that
is what we did for mallet one and for
malet 2 which is a follow-up and a
replica because as as all of you know in
science you cannot really depend on one
experiment and biological replicates but
you also need to validate your findings
and that is mallet too and mala 2 is
right now on its way from orlando to
europe and on its way back to malta this
very week or the end of this week so
it's an exciting time as well
okay yeah so so so of course all of this
all of this
precisely fits in the context of spots
of science
i form part of nasa gene lab as one of
the working groups also essa european
space agency also has its own space omix
team and basically in a nutshell what
what these groups are
is the experiments that we send to space
and back whether they are animal models
whether they are bacteria whether they
are plant or humans astronauts
the the biochemical and genetic data
that we get back are deposited in these
databases especially the nasa gene lab
gene lab repository and there the data
is part forms part of open science and
we call this open science for life in
space
we published a white paper a while ago
where it sort of
drives the message home about how we can
take space biology to the next era by
ensuring standardization applicability
and also a number of important tissue
analysis and fixation protocols we did
already have a number
of scientific publications on this topic
not necessarily on mallet but it also
feeds indirectly and these fall fall
under the the cell press
umbrella
so it is an area it is a topic where it
is very well sought also for publication
purposes
so this is milet one this is the first
cube of last year it is a 3d printed
cube using special special plastic those
are the logos and what is okay what is
male at one basically so mad at one as i
said it centers around
diabetes diabetes as you know is a major
public health concern worldwide and
malta the country that i live in
is one of the highest prevalent in
europe actually about 12 percent of the
population is affected
a large number of diabetic patients are
at risk of developing food ulcers which
is a major cause of concern for
hospitalization
are different types of science symptoms
generally the people okay
a major problem is that they do not
speak up and therefore the infection and
the wound ulcers tend to become more
serious by time
the infections are polymicrobial so you
cannot pin down one particular
microorganism
and a large number okay almost half or
more of these infections result in
osteomyelitis and also amputation
in the malta alone in the malta in one
year there are 400 cases of minor two
major amputations so more than one
person per year per day
which is a very very significant number
so so this this was the idea behind a
phd
study which is ongoing and also the idea
to marry this together with a space
science research
this is a very conservative diabetic
food ulcer generally they are much worse
much bigger
and yes here i would like to mention
my phd student christine gutt was a
biomedical scientist she works in a
laboratory at our hospital and she's
conducting her phd work at the
university and she's studying the
genetics of bacteria that infect wound
ulcers like christine i have a team of
at least
three other students who are one is also
doing a phd focusing on ophthalmic
disorders and two masters projects which
are focusing on global engine switching
and development and control of
hemoglobin so so so the way that we work
as a team together even though the
students are not all on the same topic
we share the experience we discuss with
each other even in terms of journal
clubs and generally this this this
yields a rewarding and a rich experience
so this is a typical look inside the
biocube you can see half of the cube on
the right hand side
is focused with with a raspberry pi and
computer essentials or accessories and
on the left hand side is the unit where
there are cuvettes ready to be assembled
with this with the skin tissue sample
itself
something small aside i am a strong
believer of training and inspiring the
young generation and so since
in the biocube we had space okay space
space and space we had an sd card that
can be
utilized to embed
uh messages or
artwork from school children we did this
we invited school children from malta to
have or to draw something that has to do
with climate change global warming or
send a message to the world and we
embedded all of these files inside the
cube in such a way that we can open them
when they are in space and stream them
or show them on social media back on
earth and this was a this was a a nice
exercise and we could see that the young
children were really enticed
so this is just just just two two quick
pictures about the sample preparation
and on the right hand side you can see
the samples being integrated and this is
a more closer look
at the human skin tissue samples
and how they are placed in each cuvette
okay of course the biocube is one part
of the experiment on the other side of
the story that is
on earth and in malta we also require a
laptop or a mission control room where
we can plug in
our system and we are able to
communicate or contact directly the
biocube itself
for many reasons
some of which are for aesthetic or fun
uh the use of camera to see the samples
to ensure that there were no major
breakages or problems
there are also a number of sensors to
detect the temperature humidity and one
can adjust those store sensors and there
is also led lighting and that you can
change different colors according to the
moods that one is feeling
uh but but basically basically having a
mission control center back on earth uh
ensures peace of mind that the
experiment is going well
this is the cube itself positioned on a
module which is an exact replica that is
found on board the columbus module on
the space station okay ice cube stands
for international commercial experiment
and you will see one of these also
on board the space station later on this
is the cube in its final steps with all
the samples integrated packaged in a
special box and shipped to the states
and from the states as i said the
astronaut handled the cube and you can
see here
complete
and i'll look forward
we are very much grateful for your
support today we also took note of your
japan skills so thanks for the
entertainment and then the crook these
epic conferences ready on space to
ground for
so there's just some talk between the
astronauts and mission control
those new
players in space
and others so my congratulations to them
and moving upon it that's what they
mentioned malta for the first time
and there there you can see our cube
alongside others
placed on board the ice cubes facility
which is located on board the space
station once plugged that is powered up
and we have access to it from earth
once once
roughly between 30 35 days elapse
the same
spacecraft that took the experiment to
the space station
is undocked it deorbits around earth and
falls or splashes down in the atlantic
ocean
there a boat will go out it will
retrieve the spacecraft the spacecraft
is taken back to the kennedy space
center and from there all the
experiments that were
sent from the space station back to
earth are sorted it's just like a post
in service and we received the the cube
back to malta and there were the real
work starts where we open up the cube we
we take out the samples and there is a
battery of tests that we do on all these
skin tissue samples which includes
aerobic
and anaerobic bacteria the use of
cultural media as broth and also
cultural media as agars and various
forms of course christine god being the
microbiologist is much more well-versed
in all the different tests that we do
an interesting observation or a
photograph that we had to do
was when we identified that bacteria
sent to space and back were actually
cultivated on agar plates so this showed
us for the first time for us in malta
that we are we were able to send an
experiment the bacteria and the skin
microbiome survived and came back to
earth to sort of tell tell detail
yes so
there is there is a large number of
genetics and omic tools that we are
doing
the first of which which is concluded is
a first wave analysis which we call a
16s typing and 16s typing serves as a
taxonomy
classification of all the bacteria that
are present in in the samples in the
mallet one we had six different samples
so
six different patients that came to our
hospital and each patient a human skin
tissue sample was obtained
the human skin tissue sample as part of
the surgery process was split in three
okay
one was immediately processed and frozen
so we obtained the human skin microbiome
profile on day one
and the other two
pieces
one was left in our lab on earth
and one was sent to space and back
and therefore for each single patient
which we have six okay we have three
different
data points as you like okay so we have
the omics or the 16s typing for each
of the three
timelines and we can compare the
differences between those three
and we can also compare the differences
between the six samples with each other
okay and there where we obtain a
comparative a comparative genomics
approach
this this figure shows you a spread and
and the largest number of bacteria found
together with the lowest number of
bacteria found in the skin sample itself
of course this was replicated for all
samples
yeah so so so our aim was to obtain a
signature that is correlated with the
tissue type itself we had many other
tissue types as well i mean we had a
simple skin swab from healthy controls
to act as a control we had the foot
ulcers themselves those which were sent
to space station and those which sent
which were uh left or on earth we also
had biofilms from certain wound ulcers
and we also had negative uninoculated
controls
there is extensive informatics that was
done i did not do this myself but a team
of bioinformaticians also with the help
at nasa gene lab which exclusively work
on these type of analyses
um and interestingly from these analyses
uh before going into metagenomic
sequencing which is being conducted as
we speak so to say which we are waiting
for for the mallet two samples as well
but from just the 16s typing we could
see or we could observe that a small
select number of bacterial species
in space
appear to thrive or flourish more
than the ones than the same tissue type
that was left on earth so there are
these
subtle differences but meaningful
between
one tissue type of one patient
left on earth sent to space and the
differences between the two and we have
a select number of bacteria that exhibit
these differences
we can mention that
later on one of which one key bacteria
is more cannella
morganae
yes also so the immediate next steps is
that we are comparing the 16s data
between these three data points over the
six biological replicates
something which we haven't done yet but
we want to explore is that the patients
themselves who came to hospital
we would also be
sequencing the full genome
of each of each patient
and this we believe will give added data
added information that we can sort of uh
interplay or overlay so to say the
genomic data of the patient together
with the microbiome data obtained from
the human skin
metagenomic sequencing is a no-brainer
so that is being done on the isolated
microbiome together with colleagues
in the states
and of course there are a number of key
people that sort of
what i have shown or presented in these
few slides have made this possible so
primarily there's the ministry for
foreign european affairs and for miles 2
there is also the ministry now for
research and innovation
a number of key people that are in the
states and these are chris mason he's a
very renowned scientist who in the past
has worked on
nasa
twin astronauts maybe some of you know
mark and scott kelly who are one of them
is a senator
uh they are twins they are identical
twins they are both astronauts and there
was a huge study where one of the twins
was on earth the other twin was a year
in space and therefore there are many
blood samples being taken urine samples
and other measurements and one can can
conduct all the genomics and the
multi-omics that one can think of and
compare between the two and it's amazing
the results that one gets back brayden
brayden tierney is the one who conducted
the informatics for the mallet program
afghan was the original point of contact
at nasa who introduced me to the world
of space bioscience i am indebted to him
kevin kasarin team he is a vascular
surgeon at our hospital and he's the one
who physically operates and takes the
skin tissue i mean we depend on these
medical professionals
arkham fort and evolve are private tech
companies it's impressive
the the the the interest that we see in
such
experiments or programs by the private
sector who want to be part
of this mission
also an interesting and interesting
bartering idea if you like is that the
biotech companies that agree to sponsor
our work or sponsor our mission they get
to emblazon their logo on the cube
itself so that is that is
uh
exposure that is out of this world in
the literal sense of the world
and of course christine got this she's
the phd she's the phd candidate who's
doing all of the groundwork in the lab
physically working
yeah so this slide is we're almost at
the end here the slide is sort of a
collection of mallet one which is the
top left cube
and the mallet two which is the bottom
left cube
you can see a color change
uh milot 2 is an improvement on the cube
design it is made up of a machined
aluminum so this is like the same as a
macbook laptop or these new fancy
laptops that are made of aluminium and
basically you have a block of aluminium
and they are machined from the inside to
outside
and there was also an upgrade of the
raspberry pi computer itself and there
on the bottom on the center bottom you
can see a usb dongle a key that is used
to connect directly with the iss
an interesting idea or notion is that
once you plug in this dongle okay
automatically the mission control room
or the laptop that you're using
disconnects with the internet and you
only connect with the iss this is part
of the encryption and security security
policy and on the far right far right
there you can see
the spacex rocket that departed earth
to arrive to the iss
this is a list of all
sponsors and logos to date
and three pictures that shows you a
close image of malice to cube
yes miles two i didn't speak too much
about this
we had five samples and not six
microbiomes and we had one sample
reserved for dried yeast saccharomyces
cerevisiae we have some ideas that we
wish to to implement uh when the
experiment gets back
and that's the cube itself on board
the platform itself
and i believe that was the last slide
and if you have any questions or ideas
or maybe you have an idea to send to
space
feel free to reach out to me on joseph
spaceomics.com
and watch out for for some emerging
publications
on the mallet so with that
i thank you all for being patient to
listen to me
i think i cannot hear grunts i cannot
hear you
good old microphone
does gravity play a role this is from
the audience does gravity play a role on
aging process and the rate of cell
division i'm assuming he means in space
so in gravity so does gravity play a
role
so so there are some conflicting of
course this is this is a little bit
different from the mileage program that
we do right however in the context of
aging
we have been
told
that that in space we age faster
however recent recent evidence and is
also published
there seems to be
observation that telomeres
at the end of the chromosomes instead of
shortening
actually
in longer duration they elongate and
that means that the cells might actually
become more
younger
so maybe we'll be having trips to space
to become younger as opposed to aging
well that'd be interesting a little
expensive but interesting nonetheless
right
so
how is the malice program used to
understand living in space
yeah so so mallet program okay so so
it's ambitious it's a very first program
for malta and the the idea or the
overall objective
besides the core is a life science
experiment on diabetes type two we also
know that
astronauts in space generally are very
healthy and and and athletic okay
however astronauts in space also
have difficulties with with with
vascularization and the bloodstream
itself they undo space anemia
so understanding uh wound ulcers food
ulcers and the complications that arise
on earth
can feed indirectly with complications
that we observe in space especially if
space is opened up wider for astronauts
who might not be completely athletic or
fit
like some of the people that can just
pay to get there right
so do you think there are specific
measures that astronauts take before or
after going into space maybe talk about
one or two of them
this is this is a very very good
question i think to date it is still not
completely set in stone but there are
definite measurements i mean any
measurements that are done
at the brain eeg and cardiac cardiac
function i mean these these are these
are these are
logical logical tests that need to be
done to assert that the individual the
astronaut is fit
especially to survive a three-month
six-month mission
an interesting thing is the introduction
of omics testing genomics dna rna
expression profiling this is a very very
very recent entry and as we progress
we're going to see more and more or mix
testing on astronauts
fascinating
well thank you yet again this has been
wonderful i apologize again on all the
star trek references but that was fun
glad you played along
i'll uh avoid any more cliche space
movie references like your work serves
the needs of the many but now it won't
go there
so thank you again
dr borg for being here and we're going
to move on to our poster presentation
prize distribution
and we're excited to announce the prizes
from our poster competition so i'd like
to invite celica ray from pine biotex
malika
thank you so much grant
all right so we are glad to announce the
results of the poster presentation
competition now this year we got an
overwhelming response from students and
researchers from different backgrounds
from different parts of the world the
abstract committee identified 16 posters
from a pool of 25 posters for poster
presentation competition the posters
were
evaluated by judges on criteria which
which were scored on the title of the
poster the relevance to the theme of the
conference center logic results
legibility reference and outlook of the
poster that included color spacing and
balancing so here we have the results
now the first award for
uh the category best technical and
research project on a competitive topic
goes to uh dr uma yada who holds a phd
in life sciences and her topic was on
machine learning approach for drug
response prediction in diffuse large b
cell lymphoma patients i would like to
congratulate her uh um are you here with
us can you please um
announce yourself and also turn on your
camera
yes uh
yeah so uh can you hear me
yes i can help
congratulations so
yes thank you i would like to take this
opportunity to thank our mixed logic
fine bio for this platform this has been
a great platform and is a great platform
not only for graduate students but also
for continued learning and upgrading
your skills and knowledge which is the
need of time
i'm grateful to my mentor dr agbandran
for his guidance i thank sunalika for
immense support throughout the project
thank you all at omex logic sparsh
i thank all the judges and i also
congratulate all the participants for
their work thank you all
so much uma
and the award the second award that was
for the category
if i could ask
i'm sorry if i could ask um if i could
ask uma one question while she's still
on what do you plan to do next what's
the next big thing for you
uh regarding uh the continuing on this
topic of project sure your career
however you wish to answer it
uh sorry i couldn't get your question if
you could repeat
what are you planning to do next either
with your research topic or your career
so uh regarding the research topic is
that if this uh particular for this uh
work what we have done we have
considered just the gene expression data
now we want to uh
like try to integrate it with us copy
number variation and mutation data one
number two regarding career i'm looking
for postdoc opportunities
wherein i would like to explore in the
field of data science and machine
learning and applying in field of life
sciences and precision health precision
medicine oncology precision oncology
that is what i'm looking for
okay fascinating thank you so much just
like to hear where this is going and
it's uh again congratulations son ali
could go ahead i'm sorry i interrupt
thank you
perfectly fine thanks so much and the
second part for the category of uh
promising research direction for future
potential goes to
miss ayushi notre she has completed her
master's in bioinformatics honors and
her topic was identification of critical
genes associated with intra-hepatic
collegial carcinoma weight gene for
expression network analysis
hi
she are i
around can you please turn on your
camera and also your mind come on
yes hello
um
i would like to take this opportunity to
thank pine biotech and omix logic for
giving me this opportunity to present my
research work and get it reviewed by
judges from
from all around the globe and i will i
would also like to thank the judges for
selecting my project as the most
promising research direction for future
potential
in this project i tried to correlate the
genes associated with this cancer with
the tumor micro environment and as we
know that the tumor microenvironment
plays a very critical role in the cancer
progression development in metastasis so
it was a great area to work on thank you
and thank you and uh congratulations
that's a wonderful award so
where will you go next what is what are
your plans
next well i'm pretty much very
interested in studying how a particular
disease occurs in the body at the
transcriptomics level
so i would want to carry on my research
further by on
this particular topic only where i study
diseases and how that particular disease
is caused and the underlying genes
responsible for the
disease occurrence in the body
do you have a recommendation to others
for trying to work on their own projects
or trying to win
yes i would like to recommend everybody
that do a lot of like literature review
because that enables you to
have a particular research interest um
ignited inside of you so a literature
review is passed and so that you can you
know find your particular interest in a
particular research domain because there
are n number of things that you can do
using bioinformatics so do um the
literature review and find your
particular interest and then work on it
fascinating thank you so much and again
congratulations
thank you
thank you
thank you grant
and the third prize that was for the
category
of
most innovative approach in an
established domain goes to mr or jason
dutta and mr shubham kumar masters in
bioinformatics and
their project topic was in silico
reverse mutation of spike protein rbd
from different stars both to career post
so uh we just see instrument uh do we
have you both here with us
yes
so
thank you for giving me the opportunity
for participating in the research
symposium post presentation competition
and it is good to get evaluate your
research work
at this platform and i would also like
to thank my colleagues for kelty and my
pi mr sandeep senior for their constant
support so we worked on the structure
analysis part of saskatchewan
rbd protein like spy protein and we try
to do the reverse mutation in our
project and we try to find them
like how can the
mortality rate can be like
get down and what are the next uh
competition like uh what are the next
techniques which can be used for further
making the medicines in the future like
uh to get these sars corporate down uh
as a pandemic
congratulations to you both
how was this experience developing your
own project meaningfully both
so
we worked like we used multiple tools
for our project we used seven tools for
mutation analysis and then we used
different docking tools to get our
results for the protein protein
interactions and the structural analysis
was done in this whole project and it
was good to like
complete whole project in terms of
structural analysis but in
bioinformatics
uh in addition to that we have also um
we have also analyzed the phylogenetic
analysis of this our scope variants with
humans
fascinating stuff guys what are you
planning to do next
next um we will generally try to pursue
png in structural biology like drug
discovery
medicine
precision medicine topics
or
main topic would be a raster biology
so in these three phases we will try to
perceive energy
well thank you very much and again
congratulations most innovative approach
is a really great award thank you
gentlemen thank you
congratulations once again to all the
winners and now the stage is all yours
friend
to proceed ahead with the trunks over to
you
very good thank you so much
well we're very excited on our next
guest who is coming up the professor of
virology and biotechnology
and uh the department of pathology
looks like i'm getting a note here i
want to make sure i'm on on the page
here am i going forward too fast
gentlemen
all right we have with us
um dr julia banner she was uh one of the
judges and uh she has a few comments for
the
winners so hi julia how are you yeah
hello everybody and thank you again for
inviting me and uh congratulations to
all the winners to dr uma ayusha
uh owasvi and chopin uh congratulations
i really enjoyed
uh looking at all the posters it was
very exciting to actually see that
how you use uh the tools and how you
use the data that is available and i
think it's a very
um
great opportunity to see what uh you
know
what our investments also
not our in particular but also from the
whole field putting the data out there
for everyone
to see and to use is a very big endeavor
and a lot of people put a lot of effort
into it and of course also
the tools that are available many tools
are today available
uh freely uh so it's really exciting to
see how others use them and how
you make up your own
great
research projects and come up with great
ways to use different tools so
congratulations and
thank you for the opportunity to be here
with you today
and also
if i have these a couple of minutes uh i
wanted also to thank the organizers uh
for this event i know that enormous
organizational effort has been put into
this to to bring the whole community
together to organize
uh the talks to find the speakers
so again uh
thank you very much for organizing such
a great event uh and thank you for
inviting us to be part of it
julia what was the hardest part in the
judging sequence
uh
yeah the judging sequence um
[Music]
well most of the posters were uh very
nicely organized so it was very easy to
understand the flow how the person got
the idea and from the introduction the
methodology
how uh people have used the tools and
what conclusions they came up with
uh so that wasn't a very big challenge
in most of the uh
of the
[Music]
posters that i have been looking through
uh sometimes uh
it was a challenging to actually um
uh
follow uh follow this logic uh but
then it was uh you know obvious uh how
to judge
um but of course some uh posters are
very good and uh you know it's always
hard to put a number
the final number so
i think it's a problem for all the
judges all the time
right how many judges were on the team
i think sonaminka can answer that one
better
so we had both judges from different
institutions and uh last year
very good
so julia since you're on the spot here
is the only judge on the screen
what could others do that are watching
this right now on the next competition
to be uh move higher in in their work
what what did you notice anything that
was lacking or some way to for to help
them
uh i think the uh
really um
well from what i uh seen from the uh
posters there were uh some posters that
i was uh really
uh sad to see that just because of
technical issues i couldn't even read
the text some of the texts were put as
uh
pictures
uh instead of the actual text so instead
of judging the actual work that the
person uh put into this project you know
and the thoughts that were going on i
had to rely on
very
partial information just because i
couldn't see the text so if you are
preparing a poster just you know make
sure that
we can read it and then it will really
improve
uh
your input and we can really judge your
work and not just you know how
the picture appears so that was uh
something that is very technical and i
think easy to uh
to correct
um
another thing that i would uh also
mention when you're uh preparing posters
and this is of course you know
with the posters that uh
were
talk posters this is not at all a
problem you could see the flow of the
events the introduction was really
closely related to the
methodology we could understand what the
question of the research was and how
that question was supposed to be
answered and then in the methodology we
could see how the person answered these
questions which tools were used which
data were used it was all very very
clear so when this
link is missing
then it's uh you know it's unfortunate
we cannot
read or we cannot understand what
actually was done and then uh
and then it's just uh the project is not
clear um
why is the person actually doing this
project
so so you know just keep the flow
the regular flow of the project
you have the introduction where you have
a hypothesis you are
checking
and then methodology how your support
how you decided to check which data
which tools you used and results and of
course conclusions
uh
so so you know the
the regular themes
i i almost hear you saying it might be
worth it for those that are doing this
next year to maybe ask a mentor to
review for them or someone maybe is in
the competition before maybe review
their work to make sure that's all clear
that you know that is always the best uh
thing to do i think
even if it's not a
an official mentor just somebody else
who uh who doesn't know your work who
hasn't been with you in the project just
to read through your
poster to see if there is this logic of
a regular project so anybody a
co-learner a co-student a co-researcher
anybody
i think any poster benefits from that
because when you're in the project it
seems like everything is already clear
right we have been in this
uh work for so many uh days and nights
sometimes
uh that we lose track of what's clear
and what's not clear to them to an
outsider so it's always a great idea to
have somebody else read it and
look through it together
right
sonalika can you speak to how many
entries there were
is that released
i didn't get any 25 all right so there
were
25
posters that
we got but only 16 of them were selected
uh to be put together on the poster
presentation landing page that we
prepared and out of these 16 we have
these three winners
very good well thank you that's it's
even a
no that's a bigger honor but
to be chosen out of 25 the only four
that move forward that is fascinating
what
any one of you that wants to speak to
this what was the biggest challenge in
answering what julia just spoke of the
the flow or what was your biggest
challenge to make sure you even though
you knew it
that someone else could understand it
anyone that wants to unmute and speak to
that please
somebody jump in and help me here
yeah so starting from introduction till
results it is very hard to like relate
all of the steps like hypothesis in the
introduction than in the methodology
like we have used more than 10 tools so
it is very
difficult to like mention all of those
in the methodology part in the poster
then again in the further part resultant
conclusion then we have to showcase all
the results which we have uh got from
the project we have done so it is really
hard to like relate all of those
together but somehow we managed to do
that
okay very good someone else please
this is really great information for
those that would compete again so that
we really appreciate your helping us out
here
go ahead yeah i would also like to have
the same because we have so much of
information when we do a particular
project work that putting it in just
like a piece of paper all together
becomes really really difficult so you
have to choose what you need
to
put
out over there and what you need to
leave um like what is um the thing in
the project which is not of that
importance that if you leave that out it
still makes sense so we need to be very
critical on that and we need to put on
the important things and we need to
likely about one or two minor things
which can be understood if they're not
over there as well
very good
well thank you all again so much i think
we're ready for our next speaker so
we're gonna go ahead and let you guys go
back to all your research projects and
number crunching and and all that stuff
if you plan on entering again next year
best of luck to you
and for those of you that uh would like
to enter next year please watch for
notifications on that on our website and
of course i'm going to put it in the
chat box again if you'd like to register
for your free learning portal so you can
learn more about everything we're doing
at pine biotech and omnics logic
please jump on that and
get involved again thank you all so very
much and we'll go ahead and roll to our
next
speaker
a professor of virology and
biotechnology in the department of
pathological sciences
and a director of the division of
biotechnology and molecular medicine
at louisiana state
the lsu biomed dr colusis has
extensively utilized viral vectors for
vaccine development and cancer treatment
his other research interests lie in the
structure and function of proteins
and glycoprotein and the use of
virus-like particles for drug delivery
bioinformatics and the development of
new drugs to combat infectious diseases
constantine if you are there the stage
is yours
and we may be having a connection issue
so if you would all hang with me for
just a moment
we will make sure that we get him on
screen
dr casulis if you are out there and on
we would appreciate you connecting
uh grant you have to make him a co-host
for him to be able to speak and share
his video
i cannot do that we'll have to have
somebody else on the team pull that off
elio
again our apologies for the technical
issues here we'll be fixing this right
away
uh sonalika i guess you are the one that
can do it
well this is always the fun part of zoom
and webinars across the world
we thank you for your patience uh if
anyone wants to ask let's do a quick
little poll we we forgot to ask this on
the way in today now we see we have
about 65 people participating on chat
who where are you in the world and what
is your name we'd love to see where
you're at and maybe
drop in your uh focus of omics as you're
moving forward let's have a little poll
see who we can get going here
irina thank you for the opportunity
you're very very welcome we're glad
you're here today
there's dr kuslos good morning sir how
are you
very good
finally we got through sorry about all
the mix up there we uh we had you all
introduced and then we didn't have you
on stage so thank you for your patience
with us
okay we're ready for you to go ahead
absolutely um i do have some uh
slides i would like to show so uh
hopefully i can share
um you should have screen sharing
capabilities and just go into slideshow
mode okay
let's see here
okay can you see my slides
not yet okay how about now
we're getting there i see your desktop
but no slides
okay must be the wrong one then hold a
second
beautiful island however yeah
let's see
what's going on here
okay
there we go and go ahead and go to your
slideshow menu and get in slideshow mode
and you should be
okay you see the slides right
can you hear me yes we do go right ahead
thank you
yeah so um i guess good afternoon
everybody uh you know my name is uh gus
kusudas i'm a professor of virology and
biotechnology uh at louisiana state
university and head of the department of
pathobiological sciences
i also have the honor of being the
president of the national association of
idea principal investigators uh neppy
nippy is a
not-for-profit organization
that represents 23 states and puerto
rico and all the nih funding that goes
into
the special program from the national
institutes of general medical sciences
which is called idea which is really
funding
biomedical
research at multiple levels
including
primarily at the graduate institutions
flagship institutions
clinical translational research centers
as well as a number of other
co-funding opportunities through nsgms
and i will tell you a little bit about
nebby first and everything else that we
do here but
i'm delighted to participate in this
bioinformatics
conference
we have a long-standing relationship
with
bow tech
and we have embraced the platform and a
lot of the training as well as the
software
and a number of other things that we do
and pinebartec is instrumental in
helping our programs here at lsu as well
as through neby providing
content and
research opportunities as well as
training modules throughout the 23
states and puerto rico
so nepi uh aims to protect and promote
the idea programs
as you'll see later it's approximately
450 million dollars per year allocated
to approximately 200 research centers
throughout the uh the 23 states of
puerto rico it fosters interactions
promotes research sharing enhances the
visibility of all these programs that
just mentioned
and develops consensus on priorities
identifies and disseminates best
practices and also identifies
opportunities and developing strategies
one of the main
concept is that by promoting biomedical
research within these 23 states and
puerto rico that traditionally do not
receive
a high level of nih funding
that we be able to develop manpower and
lift those states to be able to compete
for traditional nih funding through all
the categorical nih institutes
um
this is the uh leadership team
um with that uh currently uh you could
see of the nebby website and
all the programs
fund the organization through a setup
fee and nappy does a number of different
activities
that i will mention to you
as we move forward
so the mission again is nappies to
provide leadership to communication
and to improve the biomedical research
throughout the 23 states in puerto rico
we want to foster interactions among the
idea programs and all these 23 states of
puerto rico
to promote uh sharing among uh resources
among these different programs and
importantly enough that all the inbrees
as well as the cooperage ctrs especially
the inbree programs have a special
emphasis and mandatory emphasis on data
science and bioinformatics so one of the
major aspects of the inbree programs
the
is actually the promoting data science
and bioinformatics i am currently the
principal investigator of the louisiana
biomedical research network
which is one of the emperor programs
there is only one ebrip per state so
there are 24 of those programs
approximately 20 million over five years
and it's devoted to really support
primarily undergraduate institutions
creating a pipeline with a mandatory
activity to be a promoting data science
and bioinformatics
so
again with developing priorities and
consensus
in fact the all the imbis are meeting
october 18 in new orleans
to arrive at the consensus on priorities
and new directions and we want to
identify disseminate best practices and
to develop strategies to achieve the
common goals of the entire idea program
which is really a pipeline coming from
the undergraduate to the graduate
program to the postdoc level to the
faculty level and beyond
so
history of the idea it started in 1993
with approximately 50 million over the
years has really become much bigger
approaching one percent of the nih
funding totally and of course the
program is very unique because it serves
unique populations such as rural and
medically underserved communities in
these states so health disparity is one
of the big thing
topic that's actually addressed to those
states
that predominantly have a majority of
these health disparity issues
um
this is the up to 21 the funding right
now it sits at 2022 at 430 million
hopefully in uh next fiscal budget it
will go approaching the 500 million uh
which is will be approximately one
percent of the nih budget and of course
a sizable part of
every state's funding is actually uh
this idea program as you see in
louisiana here in mississippi uh you can
see
21 million of the 176 million 2021 was
actually idea funding
the different programs that i mentioned
include the centers for biomedical
recess excellence the kobe's and those
are for uh mentored by senior
investigators and their goal is to take
young faculty typically tenure track
assistant professors to become
independently funded with an r1
mechanism and the program can transit to
a phase two and phase three based on how
successful it is in graduating
independently funded investigators the
idea network like the louisiana
biomedical research network has a
different goal of promoting biomedical
research in primarily undergraduate
institutions typically they go for r15
type of grant applications or by even
beyond that and to create a pipeline of
undergraduate and graduate students that
ultimately feed into coverage and other
programs
we also have the clinical translation
research centers that are sort of small
clinical translational centers the
bigger ones are in massachusetts
elsewhere and those approximately funded
about 20 to 25 million and have a
different scope of really translational
medicine and translational research the
pennington biomedical research center is
now the headquarters of the
louisiana-based
clinical translation center it's called
the la cats
the idea program also provides
co-funding it's very important because
if you are submitting r1 or 15 and
you're not within the pay lines you
could actually get
funding by uh having co-funding provided
by the national institute of general
medical sciences and there are also
technology transfer actuator hubs that
were funded previously and they may
continue in the future creating an
entrepreneurship activity to promote
also economic development within these
23 states in puerto rico
so um the uh
nigms promotes the additional programs
over the years we had collaborations
with other non-idea
nih programs including the maternal and
infant mortality research
the copy 19 patient registry cloud
computing
and affiliation with the united strides
program google and amazon in fact they
really discount prices for idea
participants to participate in uh
this particular programs in
including google and amazon related
products
they're also continuing
new activities in collaboration between
hdms and other ones
and i urge you to look at nhgms websites
to actually see these new initiatives
that are of course supported by the idea
program and categorical nih institutes
these are the idea states
in green here
that you can see
and uh the programs include again the
call brisbane cprs co-funding and the
entrepreneurship hubs
uh the nappy in itself um
has a number of activities and i urge
you to look at the neppy.org website it
funds idea undergraduate travel funds to
washington dc to visit congress it
awards
undergraduate graduate students in
assistant professors best presentations
we have four regional idea meetings in
four of those uh regions so that uh
nigms has um you know uh be able to uh
enlist us
and uh we also have a national meeting
the national
idea symposium by medical access
excellence on nisbri that
was held every other year in washington
dc
in person
those were basically postponed because
of coffee 19
the next virtual conference would be
held december 12-14
uh it would be from noon to 6 p.m
to accommodate the different time zones
and we hope to make these announcements
and uh start accepting abstracts and all
presentations uh uh very soon
uh we also uh uh will be through the
nappy you'll be able to access idea-wide
databases and research expertise and
network with other investigators and we
have offered
discounts to virtual courses in data
science and biomedics in a collaboration
with
the pine biotech that you see on the
nepe
website
a number of activities included nappy
sponsored symposium this was a 2021
symposium
other symposia have also been promoted
to the navy including i think this one
here this conference i hope it's also on
the nepi website
and the last thing i wanted to talk to
you about is the louisiana biomedical
research network
this is the website
for the
network itself
and
you can see through that and level of
information about
louisiana-specific activities
we do
we have a summer program that is also
funded by the louisiana border regions
we had over 50 to 70 people
participating in
a different projects of the summer
relating to bioinformatics and
computational biology
that we execute every summer and of
course
the lbrn has
two major cores
one is the bioinformatics and by
computation core which is headed by dr
chris taylor who's a professor at the
lsu health science center in new orleans
and a protein production purification
proteomics lipidomic score that's uh
headed by dr jahan lee who is a
professor here at the lsu campus
in the department of biological sciences
the lbrn has an annual meeting that's
scheduled for uh most likely the second
week of january um and we do uh invite
uh people from all over louisiana to
participate especially people that are
funded or participate in active drm
programs but others can actually visit
we also sponsor a bioinformatics
regional conference
and that will be planned uh hopefully in
audience at the university of new
orleans campus
sometime next april through our lbra
website you'll be able to see recorded
lectures or previous bi-informatics
conferences
we had one last year which was virtual
they had 10 uh fantastic speakers from
all over the country
included michael snyder the chairman of
the department of genetics at stanford
promoting this composite of
transcriptomics proteomics metabolomics
to ultimately arrive at a digital twin
that would enable to predict diseases
and follow patterns uh changes in the
body uh
in addition to a complete scan
you know head to toe
that
provides new information
of
how basically everything works and
integrating this data
into a digital twin it was i think a
fantastic presentation and that's where
basically
ultimately
the science of data science and
mathematics will go especially for
health you know where you'll be able
to combine
huge data sets
whether it would be
genomics transcriptomics proteomics
metabolomics
health related
factors and clinical readings
to be able to combine all those to
create a digital twin
that ultimately would predict or
basically um
detect
any potential perturbations in the body
system to
allow for prophylactic or therapeutic
approaches to disease that may occur
months later in life
so
this is what
i wanted to sort of
formally
discuss with you
and
i'll be happy in the remainder time
to
answer any questions
that
you may have uh with regard to nih the
idea program
nappy
lbrn
uh or any other topic in bioinformatics
i had the pleasure working with
pinebartec to offer an advanced course
in transcriptomics a few years ago
we are now promoting
the creation
of a bioinformatics data science
bioinformatics course
in every
primarily graduate institution
uh in louisiana those are eight
institutions in
our primary institutions
however there are 27 that participate
throughout the state louisiana so we
hope to start with lsu uh sphere report
to create uh with dr esquezvec a
bioinformatics course at the 4000 level
for undergraduates and graduates and
that will be using content
from pinepot tech as well as faculty
members from the network and we hope to
repeat that and create a data science by
informatics course
in every of the eight uh principal
primarily undergraduate institutions and
this is really the purpose of lbrn and
the idea program to provide
opportunities
and training uh for biomedical research
with a special emphasis in data science
and bioinformatics
so um i'll stop sharing and
i'll be happy to answer any questions
thank you uh wonderful
all this all this help we just went
through the poster presentations and the
awards and to have this much help out
there is wonderful so
how is neppy working with the idea
community to promote biomedical research
training and advance the importance of
all the nepe programs
so um nappy
is
the
principal
or co-principal organizer of the
national nisbri meeting and also
participates in all the regional
meetings
all
the registrations and some of the
expenses already picked up by nepi
uh however lsu
has a um u13 grant to support the
conference so it's actually an nih lsu
nappy collaboration to run those major
conferences
and we provide stipends on our area for
bioinformatics speakers and we organize
symposia within those conferences for
biomedics the other important thing that
we already have started is to provide
subsidized or discounted courses
trainings we started with buying biotech
to throughout the network
uh also we have asked
uh content
that is being created by any of these
these programs uh 200 programs uh
whether that would be
special projects or exercises or even
you know a recorded
training
that can be uploaded on an epic website
and shared among all these individuals
would like to also to ultimately create
a forum for
job seekers and placement of graduate
students um especially in the data
science bioinformatics sector and you
know we're moving towards this goal as
we try to populate the website uh more
than we have at this point
i i don't think i can hear you for some
reason you got muted
ah yes i wonder who clicked my mic
button that's probably me um this is
from the chat
this is specific to african students but
you may want to answer more generally
are there internships or workshops that
are fully funded
for students regarding bioinformatics
gwas and transcriptonics data analysis
possibly specifically any any of that
so obviously
you know
through these programs all the inbre
programs have fellowships and support
students but really you know they're
limited
to those state um
participants
so for instance the puerto rico in brie
would support puerto rico louisiana
would support louisiana through the brn
and so on um
at this point we don't have
fellowships for international
uh students to participate um
in particular programs unless they're
incoming students to any of the
participating institutions here in the
us
however it is possible through
philanthropic donations to
uh nappy and we've had some fun before
that that
that could be something that we could
work in the long run
very good and in relation um
the the backside team helped me out with
a career opportunities link on the nippy
website so that was posted to chat for
those of you that are interested in so
we've got that link up there also so
make sure you check out the chat box
so how can all these programs from the
whole program work together more
efficiently is there a way to do that
well this is why uh the inbree uh
programs um which are really um
for uh uh
all of them including the principal
investigators and the coordinators are
meeting in new orleans october 18
in a whole day meeting
to actually find ways that we could
communicate better together there's
already
[Music]
annual meetings where the principal
investigators are meeting to discuss
potential collaborations we do
participate in regional meetings because
again
five or six states have their own
original meeting so we all get together
and discuss different things
there haven't been formal ways to
actually get programs to work together
part of the difficulties because the
funding is limited to
individual states so
we cannot use louisiana funding to send
our students easily to another state and
the vice versa so it has to be some kind
of an exchange where you know
somehow we'll be able to do this some of
that has been occurring
already
so we can send students for instance to
the mississippi proteomic training
courses but if you look at the navy
website and you look at all these
programs it's pretty amazing the amount
of resources
for biomedical research that they have
and
nih is really promoting this synergy and
collaboration
um i think we started doing this but
obviously we could do much better
so we've we've posted two links now one
at the uh on omixlogic website in
nepe so what are opportunities for
students pursuing
data science or other omics studies at
nepe and are there formal certificate
courses that can be obtained do they
have to go for
please talk into that please
yeah one of the discussions uh has been
uh whether uh individual programs
whether it would be lbr and for
louisiana creates a certificate program
the difficulty there is that we have
multiple institutions
in order to actually get students
enrolled and receive credit a particular
program has to be accepted by all
campuses so the alternative to this is
to actually help throughout brn and
maybe nepi to have
courses in individual campuses that are
supported through nepi oral brn
i do a division though the possibility
of having an epi-specific certificate
or a
state specific certificate
however that certificate would be a
nappy certificate not necessarily a full
credit certificate that the typical
higher education institution will give
and
the enrollment for this would be
hopefully partially supported by
philanthropic donations as well as
registration
that would be paid individually
hopefully at the minimal cost to have
as wide participation as possible
do the universities recognize the nepi
certificates as access to other programs
or like almost like gained hours that
they don't have to get later
they do not right now because you know
most institutions keep very
close control of their credit hours
however
obviously these certificates do count
for the job market
as well
as potentially for incoming graduate
students or preparation advanced
preparations so they could actually meet
expectations when they get into a
regular credit oriented curriculum
i i
know little about these certificate
courses and i'm sure they may vary but
is there a is there a time can person
get a certificate in eight weeks is it
eight months can you speak to that
well we are really at the planning stage
right now and
the anticipation is that there will be a
very specific program where you'll be
getting
different levels of certification
by providing a variety of different um
modules that would start from very basic
going to very advanced
and
the certificate could be awarded at the
different levels level one level two
level three um you know whether you
don't be the expert certificate that
type of thing um so uh that's something
that we have been you know
discussing and we hope to launch um
maybe at the beginning of next year
after we get
you know everything that we need to do
uh
established already so we can actually
pilot it
first and then move it to having a
bonafide program
so what i hear you saying is someone
might be able to go a short shorter
period of time and get a lower level
certificate but then build on that build
on that and build on that possibly so
yeah exactly and i think you know
pinebot tech has a lot of content right
now we work navy works very closely with
buying biotech
like i said we hope to get some
philanthropy donations to be able to
allow people to
register at a lower cost through dampi
and then use the nappy credentials to
validate you know those certificates at
that level because don't forget they're
really
practically
100
institutions of higher
learning
in 24 states that are basically support
nappy at this point
fascinating so we already talked about
internships and job opportunities
but what can a student do after they
complete a training or get a certificate
where can they find research or
or things to bite into in the other way
it depends on the level of the student
um obviously if you're undergraduate and
you are seeking to go to graduate school
that becomes very important because uh
you hit the ground running and you know
a lot of different things and depending
if you go in engineering or in
bioinformatics or data science you'll be
able to really just uh go through that
curriculum very easily
obviously uh
in the uh in industry right now anybody
that
is uh has credentials in data science
specifically but bioinformatics in
general uh sort out and
and that creates a lot of job
opportunities in the clinical
uh setting as well as on the research
enterprises uh will be biotech startups
and so on so it depends um you know the
ultimately this is a data science
intensive environment i think anybody
that works in data science and
bioinformatics
depending on the field itself
could secure probably a very bright
future
uh either in the higher education
academic setting or in industry
fascinating well thank you yet again
we're going to go ahead and release you
to the rest of your day and we thank you
for being here we appreciate all the
input on nepi and all that you're
involved in
and uh again just thank you so much and
uh we will hopefully see you again thank
you sir okay thanks uh grant and then uh
anybody that may have some questions
please uh you know contact other nepe uh
directly through the contact information
or it'll be rn um the louisiana
biomedical research network okay have a
great day bye now thank you
well yesterday i introduced him as one
of the tech masterminds behind the
symposium well he still is elia brodsky
is one of the co-founders of pine
biotech and serves as ceo
his background is in applied mathematics
and data science and currently
completing a degree in business and
management from tulane but you haven't
been working on that this week but
before i pass the mic to him i want to
remind you one more time to make sure
you register at
omnicslogic.com for your free learning
portal and as soon as elia comes on the
screen i'll post that link one more time
just in case and again that's a free
sign up so go at it so back to the
matter at hand mr broski oversees the
strategic development of research
projects and manages the team
responsible for bioma informatics
analysis training collaborations for
biotech and a big part of the symposium
so ladies and gentlemen let's kick off
with elia it's all yours
thank you grant and thank you to all the
speakers before me
i'm also going to share my screen
and
i will speak
a little bit uh on
why we are here today
you know what is the goal of actually
uh bringing together the whole community
and i hope to
kind of connect the different parts of
this symposium and in general this
symposium really represents what we do
throughout the whole year even though
the symposium only happens twice a year
so first of all
let me tell you a little bit more about
what we do and how what we do
fits in with what we see
as a community consensus about
bioinformatics training and kind of the
current challenges and gaps and what
currently exists
so uh one of the challenges i i think we
just heard from dr casulis mentioned how
different universities different
networks different branches of the same
network can have very different opinions
about what bioinformatics training and
needs are and i think that there are
ways to
work more efficiently and faster
outside of that framework of academic
institutions to really address these
challenges at scale right because that's
one of the
problems here is that bioinformatics
degrees data science degrees they tend
to be really narrowly focused on this
unique combination of engineering and
biological skills or biomedical skills
and therefore exclude the majority of
the students that are just not exposed
to the domain and are not able to
appreciate the way that this skill set
fits into their future research
so
another component here is that
bioinformatics training is really not a
single track not only is it a very
dynamic kind of a field where all the
time you have new methods new skills new
types of data it is also something that
varies across many different domains so
for example if you're learning oncology
as opposed to applying bioinformatics
and infectious diseases maybe the types
of skills that you're expected to have
very
as as you advance in those fields right
in the beginning they might look very
similar but as you advance
those types of databases
methods maybe specific types of
questions that you need to be able to
answer they start to be very very
different
and
that's why
we kind of arrived at the set of
fundamental principles that guide our
armix logic program and that includes
being able to combine several of these
essential elements into a training
experience and those are the courseworks
uh practical activities and case studies
and projects
which really i i hope that you were able
to um experience in these couple of
sessions that we had over the past two
days
uh course work of course relates to um
just traditional elements modules if you
will that kind of take a particular
topic data type or a question and break
down how that topic could be um
understood mastered or even just kind of
applied in a specific way
practical activities you know a lot of
moocs online training
coursework exist out there you know
you can watch lectures you can learn
about fascinating topics but really you
get to experience the component of
problem solving and challenge uh kind of
addressing different challenges that
arise from data when you start working
on things with your own data sets and in
your own kind of a project so
practical activities that we have
include uh building pipelines and
understanding the logic of
bioinformatics pipelines but also a lot
of coding in both python and r to really
understand how to clean data wrangle
data prepared for analysis visualize
your data and also apply different
statistical and machine learning
techniques either specific to the domain
of bioinformatics or really in a more
generic way
and finally this component of case
studies i think is very important
because as i mentioned these domains
vary as you get more and more deep into
the project and so we've
been working to
source high quality curated data sets
from publications that have an impact in
a particular field their domain and
prepare them as case studies that are
open-ended so you get started as a
tutorial and at the end you can kind of
use that data set in many different ways
so it introduces you to the topic gets
you into the topic deep enough for you
to understand the context but still the
ending is open and another i think uh
challenge
is to really have clear objectives and
outcomes that are measurable and so the
way that uh we do it is we
try to address this question of
what do students need to know for them
to get started right and i think that's
a different question
from what do they need to know to master
a particular topic
because
the majority of the students
are not going to pursue a full degree in
bioinformatics
and they're not going to specialize with
those bioinformatics skills to address a
specific topic i think what's more
reasonable to expect is for them to be
familiar
with the way bioinformatics is used in
various domains and then to determine
whether they will participate as a user
as an algorithm developer as a
technician
or potentially a person who is involved
in the conversation right and so because
of this uh dynamic technology and
software and tools that are being
developed
this is an important aspect to just
introduce them to this field i think
early on
now another topic that we already heard
throughout this whole symposium as well
is that you know bottom line you have to
be allowed to not only play with kind of
small demo data sets but actually
work with larger data sets and that
requires uh processing power for large
data sets
and effectiveness of how your code is
organized and maybe help from a
technical
team that can prepare your pipeline for
those larger data sets so
that's why we are kind of focused on
collaboration with academic and industry
partners to make sure that those tools
are available as well
and i think finally another challenge is
with faculty right because
uh you know when we speak about
introducing bioinformatics at an earlier
stage that means that the faculty have
to be comfortable introducing those
topics at an earlier stage to answer
questions to maybe uh you know guide and
monitor progress of students evaluate
them and i think that's another set of
challenges that really we would like to
you know find a solution for because
it is extremely difficult i think in
some areas to attract
faculty who are trained and well versed
in the domain of data science and
bioinformatics and you know ultimately
having to deal with a variety of topics
you know that they might not be prepared
to do
so this is kind of like our operational
uh motto which is
sos standardization organization is
systematization right so how can we take
uh fragmented curricula about
bioinformatics applications in many
different domains
find a way to agree on what all of them
need to
cover
and organize them in such a way that
they could be systematized and
implemented in basically any place from
top universities to universities that
maybe are liberal arts and not exposed
too much to the area of data science and
biomedical research in general
and another aspect of that is really
bringing it earlier on in this journey
of a student so that they can master and
embrace the
terminology and the kind of thinking
behind data obviously mastering skills
as they go along
and as they choose the specific
direction and focus
of their own journey and path
i think what's helpful in the context of
organizing and kind of structuring these
things is bloom's taxonomy of learning
where we kind of see from
basic to more advanced how the learning
actually happens and then start to
introduce that
into
what we call training in bioinformatics
and that means
from kind of knowing terminology knowing
uh specific details and elements of what
bioinformatics is like genomics you know
how do you know what genes and mutations
are
to eventually kind of growing in your
ability to
analyze uh you know use tools and
algorithms and techniques and eventually
becoming creative and and and that's why
we kind of organized our resources in
such a way that anyone for free can
register on our portal and start the
learning process and then develop uh
skills that they would need and a logic
behind the analysis that they really
need
to potentially become
experts or just become
you know aware of these topics and and
being able to try them at least before
they commit to a long-term and demanding
path to mastering bioinformatics and
data science skills in full
now with the help of organizations like
national association of idea principal
investigators as well as many other
collaborators that we work with be it
academic or industry experts we have
developed this core
set of topics that we cover in our
training and that includes an
introduction a very high level
introduction to bioinformatics and
different omix data types
deeper into different specific
types of data that are commonly used
like genomics transcriptomics
metagenomics epigenomics and then more
technically into the area of coding and
specific statistical and machine
learning algorithms that we kind of put
under the umbrella of data science
beyond that we also have divided the
areas of our training into the domains
of our oncology infectious diseases
neuroscience and agriculture now i
realized that that might not cover every
possible application of omics as we
heard even today in beauty wellness in
space uh in other domains but
nevertheless it's a framework for us to
kind of start expanding from the basic
set of skills into more specialized and
as we're able to
build relationships and kind of find
areas of mutual interest we hope to
further expand the number of
specialization tracks and expand the
number of project examples and experts
that can lead those specialization
tracks across the board
excuse me
so
one of the
i think important parts
of working with complex data
is being able to
utilize complex algorithms
without knowing how to overcome
technical challenges with coding and so
we offer both
coding and no coding paths to mastering
bioinformatics and i think that is a
prerequisite really for biologists to be
able to get started we have quite a
number of good examples of
individuals that came from a life
sciences and clinical background that
are able to leverage such tools to get
started and eventually that builds
enough momentum for them to take on a
more technical skill that they see as a
as a necessary requirement for what they
want to do
and doesn't kind of introduce this
feeling of oh i have to do a full degree
in engineering now that i have already
maybe multiple degrees in life sciences
to just even get started right i think
it kind of helps push them over the
board over the that first threshold and
gives them momentum to keep going
um i think that you know
again this is more about uh kind of
making sure that you're addressing a set
of outcomes as you are planning these
kinds of degrees but i think this is
very important for uh you know planning
and and
developing a strategy for effective
implementation right when we come to
outcomes and measuring those outcomes we
have to have a very good sense of what
that is in the short term as well as in
the long term
and i think that what we have discovered
for our participants is that
you know this is a very long-term
process
someone might get introduced to a
specific project in the summer and then
have the time and availability to take a
full course in the winter or maybe
complete it the next summer and so
that's why we have focused on kind of a
profile that you build over time and
building that profile includes a
technical measurement like gaining
points for completing coursework or
practice exercises
as well as more of an open-ended
portfolio that you can start building
from you know connecting your portfolio
on linkedin let's say connecting your
publications on
work id
developing independent research projects
and being highlighted for those projects
winning prizes or presenting them at
different conferences so really that's
where we hope that students that
participate in such training can build
out their personal profile having that
as a place that they can also share and
apply for opportunities in research as
well as industry positions and so
we we kind of have these tools for
tracking progress with points as i
mentioned research assessments where we
bring mentors to evaluate um the uh
efforts and the projects that students
prepare and then bringing together life
and data sciences what we mean by that
is really trying to expand beyond a
narrow focus of bioinformatics skill
sets to be able to talk about actual uh
biological questions or biomedical
questions that are being answered in the
context of mentorship and projects
and i think today was an excellent way
to kind of
see that in practice right all of the
different projects that we saw that got
the prizes but also we have a full page
um on learn omixlogic.com where students
have um already submitted tens of
projects that they have completed either
individually or in teams
from around the world uh from places
like louisiana state university
georgetown university amity university
in india
and universities in ghana so we really
have this international representation
of different teams and projects that
have been completed by
students working through these
this kind of training
now as grant already mentioned several
times
this is free to get started
and really affordable i hope
across the world
to get into we offer very low fees for a
basic subscription and i think very
affordable fees for specialized training
but you can start for free so i do
encourage all of you to if you don't
have an account yet go to learn
omixlogic.com
forward slash sign up and now there you
can sign up and create a profile now
another resource is our group on
linkedin
where we post regularly job
opportunities and opportunities to learn
from experts in this field so you can
join there and also learn about those uh
build your connection and make sure that
you know people know about you as well
now briefly let's talk about this
symposium and what we have done
over the past couple of days
we still have a few speakers that are
going to present today but yesterday we
heard about this need for bioinformatics
training and research in india and in
africa had an excellent discussion about
i think what we really see is that
local efforts are almost as equally as
important as international uh right and
so
instead of trying to say that you know
this is one center that will do
everything for everyone really what it
is is there's a community that needs to
share and exchange opinions and kind of
best practices to be able to build
natural locations where this kind of
training can happen
and also we heard about the need to
actually go and translate
those early efforts and training into
translational research where data from
data scientists or maybe students or
citizen scientists can be analyzed
locally so
indian
challenges are maybe different from
african challenges different from
challenges in the us right and so
building out that community and pool of
talent locally is critical um for those
communities and so we heard quite a few
successful programs that are being
developed in those regions
and we hope that our regional teams in
africa and in india and south america
could be
part of that effort as well
now we also
heard about the india partnership
program quite a number of universities
that have signed up to that which means
that they will contribute their content
and benefit from the
type of resources that we make available
and that includes some of these great
universities like amit university and
others
there
we also heard today
uh and yesterday from great speakers
from both louisiana state university or
louisiana biomedical research network
from international locations
like dr joseph borg
interesting applications of
new technologies like single cell
from sweden
and we heard about the t-biometric
platform from the tauber bioinformatics
research center so it really was
exciting to see how these different
locations are offering interesting
insights into different applications of
bioinformatics
and we heard today um and we saw just
kind of give evaluation to student
projects which are starting to follow
the lead of these experts right so we
saw projects in space in oncology
different applications to different
kinds of biomedical areas of biomedical
and basic research and i think that was
really exciting to see that we actually
see this translation of ideas from you
know such presentation as this
where an expert speaks about what
they're doing and then students being
able to pick up on that fine project or
data sets and kind of develop their own
independent projects so i think that is
really a validation and a path forward
for us to move uh further into
kind of building out this international
community so
another component that we announced was
the listing of jobs and opportunities
for internships that you can find
remotely
in your area or
by moving to a new location so we have
this new page that will continue to grow
and expand a job listing on our portal
and we will link it to your profile so
that you can actually showcase your
skills uh your effort and your project
examples that you've completed to be
able to be more successful at applying
to those positions
i think these events
kind of bring together an international
community so it was really exciting to
see uh these projects that got
highlighted as the best ones by
independent judges that didn't even know
about
each other
in some cases but
they have agreed
on the best technical and research
project altogether on a competitive
topic
the most innovative approach in an
established domain
and a promising research direction for
future potential and
knowing these individuals some of them
and interacting with them i've really
seen their growth both in in technical
ways but also in conceptually that they
were able to not only follow somebody's
tutorial and somebody's guidance but
also start bringing new ideas not from
you know just being creative and kind of
thinking about something but from
analyzing data so really data-driven
research projects that came from
students who are you know basically not
very experienced yet but have been able
to uh do this nevertheless so really
exciting to see that
another component that you know we don't
talk too much about but i think industry
participation right so we heard a little
bit about that but we also heard about
um interesting opportunities for
students that master data science and
bioinformatics to um be innovative and
provide practical solutions to real
challenging problems so for example in
our last symposium we heard from
individuals that work in bioinformatics
at the therapeutic companies like cam 4
or companies that are developing
infrastructure for bioinformatics and
for teaching bioinformatics like google
or we
we had uh hosted uh panel discussions
and and experts from the faba academy
that talk about industry perspectives on
bioinformatics and biotechnology in
general so i think that's another very
important component to what we're doing
because ultimately there's not a place
in academia for everyone to succeed in
the long term and i think that knowing
about those opportunities outside and
also for companies to know that talent
is being developed and is growing um
that is also an important agenda for
what we do
and we uh
we will talk a little bit more
in our next slide about the significance
of uh taking
uh bioinformatics uh training
further to address these two important
needs and that is
the diverse types of data that continue
and develop
we heard today about nanopore we heard
yesterday about 10x genomics
probably recently most of us have been
paying attention to ultima genomics and
the price of sequencing going
dramatically down
that
leads into the need for i think a
broader
framework for analysis integration
modeling and visualization of different
types of data and so that is a recurring
topic and challenge that i think we will
see being addressed in the future and
for us what that means is that we really
need to focus on uh making that
continuous workflow from raw data to
interpretable biological insights that
can integrate effectively
across these different technologies
and so i was really happy to see
uh you know dr julia panoff and
also
elizabeth
who uh
showed advances on the t-binding for
platform that we also offer as a tool in
the training that we offer and as a
commercial solution for our research
partners but that that is really
exciting to see that you know this
solution exists and continues to evolve
and develop to address these important
needs uh in single cell
or in the future in uh multi-atomic
integration and user-friendly
monotonomics integration as well
uh just a brief reminder of what we
heard yesterday we heard about machine
learning and multi-ominous integration
in the area of single cell research from
dr nikolai oskolkov from sweden we heard
about interdisciplinary forensic
sciences integration of vitamix
technologies in forensics
and i thought that was really
interesting from dr sarah zappico we
also talked about
networks and graph theory in an
application to databases for patients in
oncology and we heard about precision
medicine in pediatric oncology and the
way bioinformatics is informing state of
the art in new emerging places like
brazil so really fascinating
set of topics that i hope we can use to
turn into another set of case studies
and and kind of leverage these
connections to offer students
opportunities to explore these topics in
much greater depth than what we heard um
there
now we also heard today
about solutions in
medical informatics
which obviously is kind of the other
side of the coin when we talk about
bioinformatics and omix technologies
it's really about how to integrate them
in many cases into that clinical
workflow so we heard about predictive
analytics clustering time steers
analysis
classification and others and i hope
that those topics are really
uh you know something that ultimately
converges because omix technologies can
inform
a lot of those questions as well another
presentation that was really
exciting for me to hear is a
presentation about the cpgr
bioinformatics
kind of network or
this effort in south africa where we see
them being able to both train support
research but also include uh services
into their uh kind of mod model uh so
that they are successful um you know at
addressing industry and academic needs
so really great presentation there
and finally you know maybe one of my
favorites
was a bioinformatics in the beauty
industry
from dr raya heinen who
talked about her company but also in
general the need and interest
in developing
new
targeted personalized solutions for
wellness and specifically for beauty and
i think that you know that's the
that's a component that aligns well with
what dr castoulis mentioned about
entrepreneurship
ultimately states can invest you know
government funding and research funding
into research projects so getting more
grants but there's also a component of
innovation and entrepreneurship that
exists and i think that's
a way to translate these ideas and
innovation and skills out of highly
specialized and qualified students into
this industry domain so and as a result
of you know partially this presentation
but also our internal planning uh we are
going to host a bioinformatics hackathon
focused on omics wellness
and
also health so we're going to make
available some uh publicly available
data sets that have been curated uh we
will make tools available for specific
types of analysis related to this domain
and we will work with our academic and
industry partners to organize this
hackathon in november so november 17 to
22
this year we will host this hackathon
and then we will present the results of
this hackathon at a later date but the
ultimate product
here will be
that each individual will be able to
join a team
build an actual application
and then publish and share that
application that we will host for one
year with our industry partners
so that anyone can try and use that and
and you see that as an mvp as a
prototype for some practical use case in
the omnics wellness and health domain
so
with that i also want to mention that
right after this symposium our team is
actually going to continue working on
expanding our code or no code
bioinformatics paths in the omixlogic
portal and we are excited uh to be able
to um you know bring this across
the network that we heard about today
the national association of idea
principal investigators and work with
those partners to make sure that it is
more accessible and effective uh
throughout the whole network and because
of these efforts and because of you know
gradual progress that we are making with
these relationships uh it is really
exciting to be uh now um you know seeing
the results of the suffer um across the
network so we recently shared this uh
update we have individuals from a
university of hawaii um university of
nebraska uh delaware and others that
have graduated from this training um so
really um i think it's over a hundred
people that have gone through this
training from across the
network and we are now
um also going to announce new uh
research fellowship opportunities for
students that have basic skills that
would like to work over the next few
months on developing independent
research projects uh leveraging
bioinformatics and leveraging their
skills uh that they will be able to use
um and finally my last slide you know
we're excited to be selected as the
finalists semi-finalists sorry for the
ed tech cup
in new york
the largest egg tech accelerator in the
us
so
we will be sharing more information
about this in the coming days and we
hope that you will support us in that uh
journey as well
so again thank you and uh with that i
will leave some time for questions
great thanks again elia uh you did
mention interest in dr cannon's work is
that due to need in the beauty area i
just thought i'd ask it never mind
so we wanted to get to some uh
questions here's one from the chat and
this is a long one so we'll go here it
seems that omixlogic is all about
medicine health etc it seems other
domains are less targeted till now
please could you lead me where to find
omics related
to the fisheries aquaculture domain
environmental dna
etc and then or
how can we use the omnilogics platform
to bring improvements to the domains
that i just mentioned
yeah excellent question so i think one
of our challenges is actually finding a
long-term relationship around those
topics and significant interest in those
topics for people to be able to kind of
you know fully develop and leverage
those
resources so we do have people that have
worked on fishery
and environmental projects we just don't
have enough volume to turn those into
actual
kind of specialization tracks so
yes you can still use bioinformatics and
omixlogic provides resources to be able
to do that
and also yes we would love to work with
others who are you know experts in those
domains to prepare those specialization
tracks and i hope to see that just over
the next few months actually because we
have worked on those uh briefly over the
summer
seems like uh omix is touching literally
everything it's it's such a great pre
post suffix as it were
so what are some of the specific
objective objectives taken for
development promotion and improvement of
data centric research experienced by
omixlogic
well one of the major objectives for us
is to allow students to go even further
so right now we're kind of at the stage
where a student can develop their
project and talk about it right share it
what we would love to do is take it
further by showing that they can
actually develop solutions with those
skills and by that i mentioned the
hackathon that would be one of the first
steps in that direction is to allow them
to build applications that other people
can use
leveraging these efforts that they have
you know analyze data created a model
maybe created a database or something
like that so really create a platform
for applications and then as we develop
that i think that will lead into
the next phase where we will offer
support to research projects or to even
you know innovative entrepreneurial
ideas
to take that further as well
okay
what are the bioinformatics skills that
the omixlogic research and training
program offered intend to enhance
well like i mentioned we want to provide
a universal education about
bioinformatics but i think there's a lot
of effort in that domain already
we want to provide specialized skills
that are data science you know coding
data management data wrangling data
visualization things like that but i
think what is important is that within
that broad umbrella of skills
is also the integration with biology or
life sciences skills
application in this domain and soft
skills right being to being able to
think critically you know come up with
innovative solutions communicate your
results things like that right so that's
really why our program i think is
different is because we we put that
emphasis on logic and developing logic
based on data and also providing
opportunities for them to interact speak
and describe their projects as well
cool i got one more for you if we can
keep it under 60 seconds i'm going to
challenge you how can the student and
research community benefit from the
training provided by the omnilogics
programs platform to gain research
experience
i think the best way is to find a mentor
we have a network of mentors and develop
an independent research project so the
research fellowship is really the best
program for that
great ely it was great to hear about all
these updates and it looks like we have
an exciting path ahead we hope that
after the event we get to further
discuss the way all of these
international efforts can be coordinated
for the benefit of all the students and
young researchers that are learning and
applying data science and biomedical
research so thank you so much
and if dr paulson can be available and
go ahead and come on screen
he is an associate professor in the
departments of computer and information
sciences plant and soil sciences and
biological sciences at the university of
delaware
his research interests lie at the
intersection of genomics and microbial
ecology examining the ways in which
microorganisms and their viruses affect
and are affected by their environments
in light of covid and other viruses this
could be a very relevant topic for our
world
dr polson you are on the stage
all right great and can everyone hear me
everything i can hear you fine and your
presentation is showing fine so it's all
excellent
all right well thank you to the
organizers for the invitation to talk
today um i put together a talk that
dives a little bit into my research and
actually
kind of looks at a bioinformatics
education thread with undergraduates
that has kind of
shaped my research program over the
years and we'll get into that in a
little more detail
but as grant mentioned i i am at the
university of delaware and i wear a few
hats there
in addition to you know my faculty role
i'm also a director of
core facility and the bioinformatics and
data science core aspect of the delaware
embry program so i work with
investigators pretty much across the
swath of
biomedical data science and
bioinformatics in trying to figure out
how to
interpret data that they have
how to actually move forward their
research using uh different tools and
and how to educate people in
bioinformatics so a lot of what
we saw in our last talk is was great uh
really
kind of hit the nail on the head with a
lot of the topics that i'm usually
talking about in my presentations
so
i i as i said i'm going to talk a little
bit about my science today but i did
want to briefly mention kind of our
bioinformatics data science
infrastructure at the university of
delaware i think the university of
delaware was really forward-looking
about 15 to 20 years ago and making a
really big investment in bringing in a
strong bioinformatics aspect to the
campus
and one of the unique aspects our
bioinformatics programs have is that our
campus you know we are not associated
with a medical school which actually
means that we have a lot of life science
uh
research that is going on that is not
only in the biomedical sphere but goes
beyond that to agriculture
biopharma
bioengineering chemical engineering so
there are just tons of related
disciplines that end up feeding into our
bioinformatics center
that i am part of so we have we have a
really vibrant kind of population of
people that are interested in omics data
science broadly
and
our center which uh you know has been
around for about 15 years now
is is both holding those core facilities
that i mentioned that i host and also a
really strong educational program
where we've developed a number of
different graduate degrees in
bioinformatics data sciences
that you know we we have
dozens hundreds at this point of
students have passed through our various
graduate certificates uh master's
programs and of course doctoral level
programs
and and we're really engaged in
education throughout that entire that
entire realm
but one thing i did want to include in
this talk is we are really excited that
you know our already what we feel like
are really good bioinformatics education
programs have just gotten a huge boost
from an nih investment
uh which i am lead pi on this new t32
graduate training grant in computational
biology bioinformatics and biomedical
data sciences that we're going to be
hosting at the university of delaware
and actually just gave the launch
orientation for that a couple of days
ago and we're really excited about the
opportunity to bring this in
it comes with a number of new uh you
know slots for students that we can
fund and bring into our program but also
is going to let us really work in those
kind of interesting experiences with
working with industry working with
government and working with people in
the medical industry
as well so
i just want to put in a plug for this we
are
you know recruiting for our next cohort
starting next year anybody's interested
in our program
please feel free to to reach out to us
at the bioinformatics udel.edu email
address
so without further ado on to the
research talk that i want to give for
today um
so
my entire career has been you know based
around looking at microbes and what they
do
um and i think you know we've seen in
the past you know decade or so that
the the the role of microbes the
microbiome associated with humans and
other organisms they really started to
take a much more central role than they
ever had in the past
so i i
if we look at this kind of extent of
genetic diversity on earth
and we look at this tree here you can
see that
this little red circle at the bottom
pretty much every organism that you can
see with your eye is within that red
circle all the rest of this diversity
it's microorganisms from bacteria to
archaea to microbial eukaryotes so this
really is a you know it's a microbial
world i don't think this is any secret
but even this tree does not capture that
full extent there's obviously one
missing piece what is it
um well it's viruses right
so viruses
obviously have been very much in our
consciousness than the last couple of
years with the covet epidemic
but i tend to to research more on a
different group of viruses
which are the microbial viruses which
would be any virus that infects one of
those microorganisms that i mentioned
uh and these are you know by far the
most diverse group of biological
entities on the planet the the
if there is a gene on this planet
probably a microbial virus is carrying
around some version of that gene
um and they are probably one of the most
poorly or least poorly understood groups
of or of you know biological entities i
always hasten to call them uh organisms
um
uh on the planet and uh that's a lot of
what my research has been based around
is how to figure out ways to understand
viruses and how they impact their
environment
so
i i have a joint research group here at
the university of delaware i've actually
teamed up with two other faculty members
eric womack and jeff furman and we've
you know developed a joint group that
looks at different aspects of these
virus microbe
environment interactions in that
environment
really it could be anything um you know
i've looked at this is just a small
selection of things i have looked at
but it could be anything from you see
sea grass here coral sea water
but also humans right humans are an
environment and a major environment for
microbes so looking at humans and
biomedical models agricultural models
you can see soybean here
these are the types of projects we do
but what unifies them is this interest
in the microorganisms how those
microorganisms interact with these
either environments or or eukaryotic
organisms
and then ultimately how the viruses that
infect those microbes uh play into that
so it's kind of a tripartite system
we're looking at
and to to study this you know obviously
dna you know those types of omics
techniques are the bread and butter of
looking at these types of systems uh so
those are really kind of the unifying
themes that go through my research
so
you know just as a basic background
viruses are really difficult to study if
you can go out and isolate a virus and
sequence this genome you know you're
you're golden you can do a lot of
research with it but it is very very
hard to do that even when we know what
the host is say human it is often very
difficult to go out and find specific
viruses that are infecting that host
much less if you're looking at
environmental samples where there could
be thousands of potential hosts and
thousands or tens of thousands of
different types of viruses and figuring
out which virus goes with which host and
what can you host can you culture the
host can you culture the virus
so there's a there's a lot of
complexity in trying to study viruses
so
dna based methods have really become
important for looking at viruses
however a lot of the tools that allow us
to use omics based techniques and other
organisms like marker genes that are
universal say the 16s rna gene that gets
used in bacteria don't exist in viruses
there is no one gene that every virus
has
so it makes it quite difficult quite
quite complex to look at
so using shotgun metagenomics which you
know would be going out into an
environment taking a sample that has a
broad mixture of organisms in it
typically what we'll do is we will
filter out the cellular organisms into a
separate fraction so that what's left is
just things of a size that should be
viruses
and then we sequence that entire sample
right so we get a huge amount of dna
sequencing data back and it's about many
many many different types of viruses
that might be living in an individual
sample
so then we use various techniques to go
through and look at that and some of
those techniques can be quite
computationally expensive
but you know as computing and other
technologies have advanced that's really
not a limiting factor in doing these
types of
uh of techniques at this point at this
point really our limiting factor is our
ability to make biological
interpretations out of those genomic
data that we get
i'd say in viruses it's really hard
because as i mentioned you can't culture
many of them so for us to actually have
phenotypes in the viruses that we could
potentially correlate with things we're
seeing genotypically in that metagenomic
data it becomes a real challenge for us
so
you know
other other issues that we run into are
things like if we look at any given
environment and we metagenomically
sequence it and then we cluster all the
putative proteins that are there
and we look at them
from the most common to the least common
among the most common proteins one study
we have here we found that 62 of the 100
most abundant putative proteins were
uncharacterized
and of the ones which is saying they
were not in a genome at that point
and of the ones that were actually in a
genome all the ones that have arrows
pointing to them here were you know they
were annotated as puted of
uncharacterized protein which might as
well be
uncharacterized uh or are unknown uh for
for all intensive purposes so this is a
major wall we also run into is that you
know there's a lot of genomic data out
there but we don't even know what gene
it corresponds to so much less what type
of activity it may have
so it's been an ongoing challenge and
probably one of the things that keeps me
interested in this work
is that it's challenging to go through
these data and figure out ways to make
meaningful biological conclusions based
on them
so i mentioned you know undergraduate
researchers have played a huge role in
shaping this research program
and this is a this is actually a slide
from about 11 years ago this is a
program that we've had going on for
quite a while
but what we started to do uh
with my collaborators was to each summer
recruit a cohort of undergraduate
researchers into the lab and we're lucky
to have excellent summer undergraduate
research programs at the university of
delaware that have helped us to do this
and to bring these students in
and we we've really put them to work on
doing metagenomic analysis on doing some
of the lab-based steps downstream of it
uh so that we can start to understand a
little bit more about this diversity
that is out there
so
one of the main approaches we've used
with them is we will you know we'll take
these protein clusters that we see in
metagenomes we'll have them explore them
we'll have them
adopt a particular cluster or a
particular type of cluster
i have ribonucleotide reductase clusters
kind of pointed out in this graph here
so
one undergraduate researcher may take
these and they will they will actually
go through the metagenomic data pull out
the sequence reads for those
those that contain those genes
do assemblies
do phylogenetic analyses ultimately
build some primers so that they could
look at this and try to actually
identify it an environmental samples and
then you know take some environmental
samples that we have in our library and
see if they can actually re-identify
these genes in those
natural samples and through doing this
it really increased our bandwidth to be
able to look at all that metagenomic
data that we're holding on to
and really start to understand some of
these genes that we see very commonly in
uh
the the various metagenome sequences and
you know i
we've definitely looked at both unknown
and known functional genes through these
types of methods and we have interesting
stories on both
today i'm going to follow through with
one story that is from a known gene
which would be dna polymerase one so if
you're not familiar it is the
proofreading polymerase and many
bacteria but in
viruses that carry out it it is the main
polymerase it is the one they use for
replicating their genome
and it is a fairly common gene for a
double-stranded dna virus to carry we
see it in about 25
of known dna viruses double-stranded dna
viruses so that's actually a pretty good
percentage for us so looking at this
gene gives us the ability to look across
a lot of different viruses
so one group that has looked at this and
there are a couple of grad students just
chopin and dan nasco
also eric sakowski who's not on here and
in particular one undergrad helen
schmidt
who really adopted this dna polymerase
gene over the course of several years
and made some really interesting
discoveries with it that i wanted to
walk you through
so
first is a little bit of background to
remind you
viruses and microbial viruses in
particular tend to come in two
lifestyles or flavors
there are the viruses that will enter a
cell and immediately they're going to go
into the replicative cycle make a lot of
copies of themselves and immediately
lyse the cell so those are the ones that
are virulent or live the light the lytic
lifestyle by default
the other group are the temperate phage
or temperate viruses those are the ones
that enter the cell incorporate
themselves into the host genome
will lie dormant for some period of time
and then eventually some trigger in the
cell or the cell's environment will
cause it to essentially activate itself
and then do a replication so
understanding which viruses are lytic
and lysogenic
is a pretty pretty important thing when
you're trying to understand viral
biology and how viruses impact their
host
so
it seems like this would be a very easy
thing to identify within a sequence but
it's not always and actually many many
many phage that are out there we have
complete genome sequences but we still
don't know for sure which one of these
lifestyles uh those phage tend to follow
so
uh helen schmidt as i mentioned she was
a undergraduate biochemistry major uh
and she came into one of our summer uh
undergraduate internship uh
opportunities and adopted this dna
polymerase one uh cluster and started
looking at it in much more detail
um and through her work and her
particular interest in biochemistry uh
she noticed something within this gene
that has led to 12 years of subsequent
research for us
and that was the fact that within this
gene
when you look at the the protein
sequence for it there is an individual
amino acid residue within it that seems
to be predictive for the phage lifestyle
if we look at this
residue at position 762 relative to the
e coli version of the gene
the the default that you tend to see in
bacteria as a phenylalanine at that
position
however if tyrosine is at that position
uh there is biochemical data out there
that indicates that that makes the
polymerase about a thousand times more
processive faster
essentially but also makes it more prone
to errors while it's replicating
um there's also a mutation that's been
biochemically characterized to leucine
at that location and when that amino
acid is in there we get about three
times more accurate but about a thousand
times slower than the phenylalanine
so it's quite a spread in the speed and
the accuracy that occurs
based on this one amino acid change in
polymerases and what helen noticed was
that this individual amino acid residue
when she overlaid its identity onto a
tree
very neatly clades with our groups with
the clades that were on the tree we can
cleanly see there are two groups here
that are leucine but there's a single
group each for phenylalanine and
tyrosine so to us that was an indication
wow there is a real
uh biological uh
phenomenon going on with this amino acid
residue
and we really saw that when she started
to look at the lifestyle of the phage
that we did know their um their
lifestyle and that was that the the
tyrosine version was always lytic we we
had no exceptions at the time of a
lysogenic uh phage that had tyrosine
phenylalanine was almost always lytic a
few exceptions there
and leucine was almost always lysogenic
so just this individual residue gave us
that information that otherwise is very
very difficult for us to identify out of
these types of sequences
so
we just do the thought of experiment of
why this might be important to viral
biology
let's think about you know lydic viruses
are the ones that come into their host
they replicate fast they produce lots of
copies of themselves and then they're
out of the cell
so for those guys if they have errors in
a few copies maybe that's okay maybe
occasionally you're going to get a
mutant and maybe that mutant is actually
a good thing right maybe that's new
diversity that's going to allow them to
succeed but if that mutant actually is
bad then you know it it's okay you've
got lots of copies that are faithful to
the original
um
you know and occasionally you're going
to get a really crazy mutation which uh
you know may may or may not be a good
thing but you have to see how that works
out with natural selection but the
really interesting thing with this trait
is you're modifying your polymerase and
your polymerase is ultimately
responsible for the mutations that could
lead to natural selection lead to
evolution so really by modifying their
polymerase in this way or you know
naturally selecting for the polymerase
in this way they're evolving to increase
the rate of of evolution which you know
that's a phenomenal thought right
they're they're they're really giving
themselves the ability to be more
diverse
if we look at the other side of the of
the coin temperate phage tend to
replicate slower they're sitting within
their cell for a long time so they
really need to be more in sync with the
cell and then when they actually do
start to replicate themselves they're
doing it at a critical time when there's
probably a stress on the cell and they
really need to get accurate copies and
get out so that they can survive and
reinfect a new cell so
in those phage you know selecting for a
more accurate mutation this leucine
mutation even though it's a bit slower
it may have significant evolutionary uh
of
potential for you know keeping it in
sync with its host
so for the rest of my talk or actually
one more slide on this so you know the
the the first students i talked about
they were doing that process that whole
process very manually we've actually
since done a lot of work on streamlining
it making it easier building
bioinformatics tools i've had a number
of grad students who have come through
and we've just made an entire suite of
bioinformatics tools that make this
process of investigating these viral
genes in this way
very straightforward
and easy to do um
so
for the rest of the talk if we go back
to this dna polymerase a you know we
we've looked at plenty of other clusters
but this one has really been one that
has really captured our
our interest
uh and i i mentioned this this thousand
times faster but not quite as accurate
or three times more accurate and a
thousand times slower
um those are really you know fairly
widespread in biochemical literature but
when we really traced it back they all
went back to single studies where they
tried some in vitro uh
mutations so really we didn't know for
sure that all polymerases followed this
rule or that it's something we would
actually see in the environment
so a current study we have ongoing now
is actually taking the bioinformatics
back into the lab
and i have a student rachel keown
who's
been working with some collaborators at
virgin biosciences and what we've done
is actually taken our metagenomic
sequences for dna polymerase a
and have picked out different variants
of them across the tree represent these
different types of amino acid residues
that come from different sources and
we've had them synthesized had the dna
synthesized and then cloned those into
expression vectors so that we can
actually produce the protein and do
biochemical characterizations of it
so
this was something a little bit out of
our wheelhouse and we were really hoping
it was going to work and fortunately you
know working with these experts at
virgin
it's working we we have actually taken
we've had about 50 of these synthesized
at this point and we've had about a 60
success rate of being able to isolate a
protein out of it and that protein
actually having functionality
so
you know it's really cool that we can
actually take a sequence from a
metagenome and make a protein out of it
but what we're ultimately interested in
is we want to find viral phenotypes and
the biochemistry of these enzymes
ultimately determine how fast that virus
can replicate how fast it can copy
itself and get out of its host cell
so understanding the different
phenotypes biochemically for this enzyme
is something really important that we
can now layer on to other data that we
have so
you know i i won't go into explaining
this figure because i'm getting a little
short on time but the bottom line is
if we look through
these different ones that we have
synthesized we have found quite a few of
them that we can show have primer
extension activity at various speeds to
various rates
we also have several of them that have a
strand displacement activity which is an
interesting activity uh on its own um
that our by our our partners in industry
are very interested in but we also are
interested in is that it's another
phenotype that that organism has or that
virus has that it's carrying around that
we can potentially look at
so rachel is moving forward with this
work
she's gone a little bit beyond only
looking at this biochemical data that
she's been producing but she's also
looked more at
what else goes with the polymerase it's
not living in a vacuum it's ultimately
working with other genes to replicate
the genome
and we really see that there are some
really constant associations between our
different tyrosine pulley phenylalanine
pulley leucine pulley with different
types of helicase genes that are
specifically tuned to work with
individual ones so this is another piece
of evidence that this processivity
accuracy
hypothesis that we've been testing may
well be true in that
gp4 helicases for instance are known to
be among the fastest helicases out there
and if you're unwinding the dna for a
very fast polymerase you would think
you're going to need a very fast
helicase
so that we're seeing these associations
is very promising and we're now starting
to move beyond the pole a and also look
at the biochemistry of these accessory
genes like helicases like ribonucleotide
reductases
that we see in association with these
and look at that broader genome net
neighborhood and figure out how that
module of genome actually impacts the
biology of the phage
so where are we going with this work
you know ultimately rachel's still
working on purifying and biochemically
characterizing those various enzymes
she's worked with another group of
undergraduates this summer in doing
optimal ph and temperature assays
which can actually tell us a little bit
about the biology of the cells that the
phage are infecting based on where their
optimal amplification or where their
optimal operational temperatures and
ph's may fall
as we're expanding this database of
biochemical information about different
phage from different phylogenetic parts
of the tree
we're correlating that data with other
information that we're we either have
based on where they were isolated or
abundance and infectivity information
that we're we're producing in other
areas of our lab
through various collaborations and our
ultimate goal here is we're going to
take this massive data both on
biochemistry observable phenotypes when
we can get them as well as the genotypic
features that seem to correlate with
these and we're going to integrate them
together
and begin to
see if we can make models that will
allow us to predict phenotype more
accurately based on the genotypic
features that we've seen within these
replication module proteins
and how well it can interpret or
predict these types of infectivity
characteristics or environmental
characteristics
that may apply and we've done this on
some fairly simple basis so far just
looking at combinations of
ribonucleotype reductases and dna
polymerases that we see occurring
together and we've actually had some
really interesting
results come out of that where we can
see correlations between
uh versions of ribonucleotide reductase
that require oxygen versus don't require
oxygen and the the available oxygen or
metal cofactors
that are available in their system
so we have some great preliminary data
here and we're really hoping to build a
more
substantial model moving forward
with our work
so i think i am wrapped up now
thanks to everyone in my lab my
collaborators and of course our funding
sources
thank you dr paulson that is again
fascinating stuff if you don't mind you
can quit sharing your screen so we can
see you um how are these in silico tools
like alpha fold for research you're
working on how useful are they
uh they're actually quite useful i
actually have a grad student zach
schreiber and a collaborator marty
belcade at the university of hawaii and
they are looking at particularly at
protein structure
that we can predict with these new and
silico alpha fold two and so forth
and how well that can be used to
classify these proteins and metagenomes
so that's that's actually a different
direction we're going but it is
something we are investigating in this
area
very fascinating how important is
mentorship and student participation in
this research you've mentioned a whole
bunch of names that aren't yours during
this
yeah absolutely so
you know student participation is you
know our research could not happen
without it both undergrads and grads and
we really try to set up a kind of a a
group support mechanism we don't just
take an individual student through we
bring through a cohort of students which
brings a support mechanism with it in
itself and then we pair those student
those undergraduates with graduate
students
and then we have mentor pi meetings with
them on a regular basis
so through that kind of multi-level
mentoring
it both teaches graduate students to be
mentors but it also sets up multiple
levels of support for those students as
they move forward um to to you know get
get at these types of
new skills that they're trying to uh to
learn and apply
thank you so much i've wrapped up our
time with you and we really appreciate
that i think we could ask questions for
another half hour if we could but we
need to move on so thank you again for
your participation here this afternoon
we really appreciate it thank you thank
you
our next featured speaker is dr april
white
and we are really happy to have her here
she's currently the assistant professor
biological science at southeastern
louise louisiana university dr wright
has several currently funded projects in
the lab on deep time evolutionary
dynamics in a variety of groups of
organisms
secondary focus in the right lab is
domain based education research in
computational biology and how biology
undergraduate students learn computation
and mathematics
dr wright i can't wait to hear what a
bayesian model is and the latest
fashions they're wearing oh that
probably isn't the right kind of model
right i'll stop guessing and let you go
on go right ahead
all right thank you um really happy to
be here today uh i'm gonna try and uh
put this into slideshow mode and see if
you can still see me advancing
all right can you guys see me advance my
slide or are you still seeing the time i
can and we can hear you just fine
everything's good perfect uh all right
well thank you so much for having me uh
it's really nice to be here today
uh so today i'm a little bit of a
different type of scientist than um your
other past couple of speakers um so i'll
be talking a little bit about uh some of
the mathematical modeling that we do in
the lab uh there actually won't be any
genomic data um in this particular talk
uh and instead we'll be focusing on
what we
do with models and and how we can do
that confidently i just realized i have
the wrong year uh in my in my slide it
is not
20 21
but it's been it feels like it's been a
lot of years lately so that's fine like
i said i'm a little bit of a different
biologist than um the other speakers in
this session i don't really do very much
in the way of genomics um
and in this lab we predominantly work on
complex and particularly hierarchical
models for estimating phylogenetic trees
particularly from
the integration of a variety of data
sources
uh and elia had asked me a little bit to
talk about how i ended up interested in
something like this
and i didn't start interested in uh
phylogenetics at all in fact um
so when i went to college i started
taking intra-bio classes
uh
and i was really bored by that um
you know you you memorize the krebs
cycle and and
you know you have to know all this stuff
and so i was i was bored by that um
and i ended up dropping the biology
major picking up a journalism major
actually um
but
being the only person on
uh staff who had any sort of
uh stem
background at the newspaper
i got handed a lot of science articles
and this was back in
2006 when a lot of the challenges to
teaching evolution
started to happen
uh so for example uh the dover v kits
miller trial and things like this uh and
so it was a really interesting time to
be
writing about and thinking about
evolutionary biology
and because of that i actually realized
that
biology wasn't just memorizing a bunch
of stuff and regurgitating it onto an
exam it was a living discipline
uh and i became interested in the uh
um
you know the role of phylogenetics as
sort of something that would allow you
to study a little bit of everything
right so you can build a phylogeny of
fish you can build a biology of mammals
we work on ants in this lab we work on
stem mammals in this lab we work on
things that have been extinct for 500
million years
we work on things that you could walk
out your front door and collect on your
doorstep
so um i got interested in phylogenetics
because it was this uh
way to get to do everything a little bit
at once as well as a way to sort of uh
engage with the deeper philosophy of
biology
um and when neily and i had a
conversation about this as well um
uh he wanted me to talk a little bit
about primarily undergraduate
institutions
um
so when i went to college i went to a
undergraduate only institutions anal
college in northfield minnesota uh and i
decided that i really liked sort of that
modality of education uh and i decided
to pursue it following uh my phd so i've
been here at southeastern louisiana
university uh this is the start of my
sixth year as awarded tenure last year
uh and so i feel like the balance of
responsibilities that i have in this
type of lab is very good i teach three
courses a semester i have a couple
masters students and typically four to
six undergrads in my lab uh and the work
that you're about to see has been sort
of touched on by all
all of those personnel at at least some
points
all right so what we have here are two
phylogenies
in panel a this is a phylogenetic tree
that is what we refer to as not scaled
to time
so in this case
typically you're going to see a tree
like this you saw some in the previous
presentation
where
the uh
the branch links are usually given in a
rate right the number of substitutions
expected per site so a measure of
you know either the genetic or the
morphological change whatever you happen
to use for your data
on the right hand side
is a phylogeny that has been scaled to
time or what we might call absolute or
geological time
these types of trees allow you to make
like i said absolute or geological
statements about when lineage is
diverged did they diverge 10 million
years ago 5 million years ago 100
million years ago these are the types of
questions that we can answer with the
time scaled tree
and over the next couple slides i'll
show you a couple of applications of
these types of um
uh phylogeny's in the literature
so for example right now
we might all be very familiar with this
this is a screen grab from the website
next strain
where
uh you know they're tracking different
variants of cobit right and you can see
there's a time axis on the x-axis of
this
they're keeping track in absolute and
real time
of
what strains are arising and how they're
diversifying you can see the different
strains are in different colors here
with some of them labeled
by sort of their common uh
name and you can see over time some of
them sort of go extinct some of them uh
continue and diversify so for example
omicron right now is sort of the
dominant strain and you can see that
dominance kind of over here on the on
the right hand side of the phylogeny so
this is an example of a time-scaled
biogenetic tree
uh and another example here this is an
example from scallops where they've
built
uh
you know phylogenetic tree of scallops
and what they're looking at is um
you're never looking looked closely to
living scallop they're bizarre um they
have a bunch of eyes on them
you can see
by the scale down at your left um the
eye abundance goes from you know black
is like 37 eyes up to 151 eyes in the
blue there and then on the uh kind of
right facing for lodging phylogeny b
we have the life habits so are they
abyssal do they sit
on on the ground do they really attach
to the ground so cementing do they
freelance do they glide do they do other
things
uh and so this is the study this is the
study of trait evolution how does
the evolution of the eye impact the
evolution of life history and these
types of studies typically also assume
a uh
branch length in sort of millions of
years so absolute or geological time
and so how do we get
a phylogeny with branch links in
millions of years of time
and that is sort of the real question uh
those family of methods that i refer or
that i work with are referred to as the
fossilized birth death model
and it has
three different phylogenetic
components for this reason it's been
sometimes referred to as the tripartite
model or the tripartite approach
so under this model we have our data
so our phylogenetic characters these
could be morphological characters these
could be dna characters and we have our
fossil ages and fossil is a little bit
of a
general term
if you're working with actual organisms
that might fossilize then yes you have
fossils if you're working with
viral data
these would just be the ages of the
thing that you isolated so if you did a
blood draw and you found that somebody
was carrying hiv and you wrote down the
date
that would be your possible age
and this model has three different
components there's
the substitution model so how your
phylogenetic characters evolve
the clock model which describes the um
distribution of evolutionary rates over
time and the tree and tree models and
this describes the process
of diversification that generates your
actual phylogeny
and what i mean by that is this
uh
this part of the model is referred to as
the fossilized bird death what we have
in the middle here is this character t
that represents the phylogeny
and you can see there are five different
parameters that are all pointing towards
the phylogeny these are the parameters
that govern the tree shape how many
branches are on the tree so how many
lineages are on the tree
the age of the tree
we're going to walk through them so
right here we have the origin time
when did the process of diversification
that leads to your observatory start in
your group
the speciation rate is what is the rate
at which new lineages are added to the
phylogeny
the extinction rate is the rate at which
they are removed
the fossilization is
rate is the rate at which we recover
lineages in the past so this could be
via you know sampling viral um
loads this could be
the rate at which fossilization occurs
in your group
and then the sampling probability of the
things that currently exist in your
group
how many of them have we sampled
right this is uh you'll notice that this
probability the sampling probability is
in a square
that refers to this parameter being
fixed we typically assume in this model
uh that you know
how many um
of your clade of interest
you've sampled so if you have
um
you're estimating phylogeny of bears
there is genetic data out there for
every bear you can include every bear in
your sample and so your sampling
probability would be one for many groups
you probably haven't sampled everything
but you might have some good idea of
what proportion of the extant diversity
you've sampled
and different tree shapes are going to
imply
or sorry different model parameters are
going to imply different tree shapes
so for example if we are
not including
you know any
um
tip sampling at all that would sort of
imply that we are going to sample
absolutely everything
as we you know increase or um
as we increase our extinction rate that
impacts the tree that we're going that
exists in reality and it impacts the
tree that we can recover from our data
continue on there
right
so i think a lot of us are fairly
familiar with bayes theorem we have that
right here we have the posterior
probability on the left-hand side of the
equation which is kind of the
probability of parameters given data and
a model
uh
on the right hand side we have the
likelihood so the probability of the
data given your parameters in a model
any priors you have right prior just
probability distributions that specify
uh you know knowledge that you have
about those parameters and that's all
divided by the marginal probability of
the data which is sort of a complicated
uh quantity to get a handle on it i'm
not going to spend too much time on it
here but if you have questions i'm happy
to answer them
so in the case of
the fossilized birth death
in a phylogenetic context that equation
looks something like this
um and there's a lot of stuff on the
screen
so this is this is a little bit tricky
uh to deal with
and so we're going to take a look at how
we can sort of break this down usefully
to do good model selection for each of
our three hierarchical sub models
and i'm actually going to present to you
um
uh some results that we have from
actually an entirely paleontological
data set called the sentence these are
an extremely temporally restricted
group of organisms
invertebrates marine invertebrates
and they're found basically from about
500
and 10 million years ago
to about 498 million years ago and
that's it
um
so these have a pretty good amount of
phylogeny characters for a small
invertebrate about 60 characters for
those 27 taxa
um and something that's interesting is
that we have some idea about how diverse
they were over time
um
so i'm going to call your attention to
panel uh
c on this one
where basically between the first two
points this one down at the origin and
then this one over here at
um
about six million years
there's a huge jump in what we call the
disparity and that's an index of how
different organisms are from one another
and so very early in this group we
accumulate a lot
of
morphological change things begin to
look very different very fast
and so that's a very common pattern in
the fossil record
sometimes referred to as the early burst
and so this might imply something about
our distribution of evolutionary rates
in fact it might imply that
they are
very quick at first and then they slow
over time
and so we decided to test four different
molecular clocks the strip clock says
the rates of evolution are the same
all across the tree all through time
probably not true in our case
the autocorrelated clock says
well the rates of an ancestor are
going to be similar to the rates of its
descendants
okay that seems plausible early bursts
like i just said it kind of looks like
our data is that and then the
uncorrelated means an ancestral
descendant can have strongly different
rates of evolution no limits sky's the
limit do whatever you want
right so again that's sort of a this is
a visual representation of that where
you can see on you know the
autocorrelated generally
uh the cooler colors are the low rates
and generally you have to kind of pass
through intermediate rates to go from
low rates to high rates
on the uncorrelated clock there you can
see when the branches are colored by uh
evolutionary rate that you can have
jumping from very low evolutionary rates
to very high ones no problem
all right so we had a look at those
um and something that's also the case
here is that we have pretty good
geological information about the time
period when these guys existed
so for example we had pretty rapid
accumulation of lineages here in
stage five
and then slower lineage accumulations in
these stages and so
um
you know while we might expect
evolutionary rates to change over time
this could potentially also be
implicating the process of
diversification
over time perhaps it's that we're
diversifying very rapidly early on and
therefore accumulating disparity so
perhaps it's not the rate of evolution
but the rate of diversification
and so we took a little bit of a look at
this and got some overall estimates from
extinction rates and origination rates
or speciation rates
and this allowed us to sort of have
some idea of ballparks for these sorts
of models so we're able to use these to
place informative prior distributions on
each of these values
and we use a set of models that are
referred to as skyline models which
allow us to have a different kind of
diversification process for each of our
time periods so we had to look at
dividing up the time period into two
chunks
uh but also three chunks so each of
these individual stages
getting its own diversification process
so we're not totally out to lunch on at
least two of our models
right but what about this part here
so most of the time we're going to be
working with the mk model of paul lewis
and that's pretty much what we did in
this paper i'm starting to run out of
time so i'm just going to keep moving
um we also looked at you know if uh
feeding and non-feeding characters
evolve differently
so
from kind of an infinite set of models
that we could have assembled from all
those parameters we were able to distill
down to about 10.
which is great we used a constant data
set of
fossil and phylogenetic characters
we did all of our estimation or model or
a software called rev phase which is
something that my lab works on for
development
and this allows us to calculate a
precise model likelihood to make
comparisons between models
and what we found is that for each
um
of the hierarchical subcomponents there
was one clear model that was best
right so for each we could fit
um
a best fit model
uh and use that to and for our phylogeny
so our um uncorrelated log normal model
was the best for the clock which i was a
little bit surprised by
and a model in which we have
diversification changing per stage was
also good
all right um
so this is computationally expensive but
we were able to get things to work a
little bit better by not evaluating
every single model and instead choosing
models that have some prior evidence for
them
right and so when you have these types
of extremely complex models that really
calls for a return to hypothesis driven
work right why do we think this is the
right model what is our intuition
telling us
all right so we were able to estimate a
phylogeny but there's some stuff about
this that's intrinsically unsatisfying
so i mentioned
earlier that we could have an early
burst model that manifests in either the
clock or the tree model
what if those interact are these subsets
independent and is it valid to do model
selection on each of them
and my answer is a little bit no
uh and so
my lab has been piloting what we call
reversible jump model selection this
allows us
to sample the number of model parameters
as part of a markov chain monte carlo
analysis and so in this case we could
have uh subsets of models um
being selected at once
so we could be doing the model fitting
for each of our sub models together
rather than separately
so we can sample models simultaneously
to determine
the correct model for all of the
sections together
and finally the other technique that my
lab has been piloting is
the posterior predictive model adequacy
testing these are a family of methods
that allow us to simulate data from our
bayesian posterior predicted or bayesian
posterior distribution and then see if
when we simulate those data they look
like
the empirical data and if they do we
have some test statistics to describe
the goodness of fit there and they're
assumed that then the model is sort of
adequate for the data i'm running out of
time so i'm just going to sum this up
really quickly
with these new hierarchical statistical
models we have non-independence and
model subsections that could be
misleading for our analyses and so we're
kind of looking at evaluating a new
generation of tools for their
effectiveness for dealing with these
sorts of problems
all right so thank you to all of these
um
write lab members and collaborators as
well as to funders and i think i'm out
of time
well not quite you actually have a few
more minutes we have about 10 minutes we
can fill up
so we're going to ask you some on the
spot questions here are you ready yeah
all right you getting good quit stop
sharing your screen there if you would
and uh that way we can uh be just there
yet go now we can see you so a question
from chat and stuff you mentioned that
you are not working with genomic data
that was at least what was understood
how do you validate that model
predictions or how important or even
possible it is to validate the models
yeah so you work with a lot of simulated
data in the lab
uh and try to simulate data that looks
uh
like you know the real data um i mean
and that's exactly the same as you would
do with genomics right um
so we work with a lot of simulated data
for model validation
and then um we do quite a bit of
sensitivity testing as well so um
you know you run the model and then
you know you take a look at how well
it's
kind of working with your data
and you run it up with maybe some
different assumptions and see how much
of a difference that makes to your
actual conclusion
uh and then the other thing that you can
do for kind of model validation would be
the posterior predictive model adequacy
testing
which is that very last thing that i i
kind of uh thought that i was out of
time to discuss but the idea with this
is that you take samples out of your
posterior distribution
simulate data with them
and then uh you use test statistics to
determine how closely the correspondence
is between
um
you know the data that you've you've
simulated under your model and your
empirical data right so they look very
similar according to your test
statistics then that's you know a good
sign that you're probably modeling the
correct things
okay well thank you
what are the limitations of using
hierarchical basin models
i mean i would say that the limitations
are mostly sort of actually we had an
annual reviews paper that came out on
this last week um but there are there
are lots of limitations and a lot of
those limitations are computational um
so when it comes to bayesian methods you
know we're really looking at
the idea of
you know having these models converge to
a stationary distribution where you can
assess that you've drawn enough samples
from the posterior to approximate it uh
that takes a long time in practice uh
for complex models so there's a time
sort of factor and then the computation
time associated with that uh it's very
hard to do this type of work for example
in the cloud
so if you don't have you know a server
or an hpc unit a lot of this is at this
point kind of out of your reach um it's
not something that can effectively be
done via aws or anything like that
uh so there's that that's a big
limitation
uh another limitation is sort of the
uh
the quality of information that you can
come up with right so let's say you have
um
you know genomic data
but there's no fossils in your group
your ability to have any sort of
resolution in the past is therefore
extremely limited and there are some
groups where that's true fish for
example are one where
because of the nature of sort of the
sedimentology and how they get deposited
it's pretty hard to tell when a fish is
from um
uh other soft bodied organisms
are also quite tricky um
but you know if you're working with
something like disease biology you often
have a lot of extremely high certainty
data because you know what day the
patient came in
and you sampled their flu strain right
uh so in the biomedical realm methods
like this are often extremely effective
um
and actually one of the founders of this
kind of series of methods uh was on
swiss national tv every week for the
coronavirus update because they were the
ones who were tracking it um
so you encounter a lot less limitations
when you're looking over those short
time scales like a couple hundred years
or a couple thousand years for a
disease-bearing organism i think the
other big limitation is
just
your ability to think about all of these
things at once um
you know it's it's complicated
uh it really is and
developing the statistical literacy the
computational literacy knowing each of
your data sources and its individual
limitations that's a lot to ask of
anyone
uh so i think
yeah just our ability with human brains
to think about these things is is
considered my greatest
been my greatest impression over the
last two days is just
how everybody's keeping all this even
remotely close to what they can think of
okay here we got one from chat can the
models be used to determine gene
evolution for potential vaccine
candidates for tick species
i mean i don't see why not um
so
for a long time phylogenetics event has
been a component of um
the flu vaccine uh selection
right and so uh
this is initially described back in the
early octs with uh
mike warby at all where they would show
that you know you would get often times
kind of a trunk lineage that would give
rise to the flu strains for that year
uh and so phylogenetics has a deep kind
of um
history with that and they typically do
that based on a couple of loci
associated with sort of the uh host
genome
evasion
um
response and so
uh
yeah definitely i think that sort of
thing is is very possible so um
you can build individual gene
phylogenies and see what they're telling
you that might be
different than the whole kind of species
tree uh so oftentimes there's conflict
between what individual genes will tell
you versus when you look at them all
together what they'll tell you
but those techniques are very well
explored and so i think that would
absolutely be possible yeah
okay thank you what are the ways you can
combine hierarchical basin trees with
other methods like your standard
neighbor joining tree etc
you can't
there we go that was a simple answer
yeah i don't really like to give answers
that simple but um
doesn't work with neighborhood okay
here's another one from chat
have they used k nearest neighbor models
against real data for synthesizing data
has this included both clinical and
omnics data omics data for example using
cynthia patient data with 1kg genome
data or using uk biobank data with
clinical phenotypes etc
i have never heard of any of that
so
you and me both so we're potentially
someone else yeah
all right very good um if it has
limitations then what is the biggest
motivation to use it
well i mean everything has limitations
right
i mean if if we didn't do things that
had limitations
you know
you wouldn't have a computer right like
um
you wouldn't be in this manner living in
stone would make this very interesting
right right so what prompted you to
focus what prompted you to focus on this
specific topic of research and did you
consider other domains also why did you
get this direction
yeah so for me um you know i think like
most kids they grew up watching you know
dinosaur tv shows and reading books
about dinosaurs and you think you might
want to be a paleontologist but um
you know that's
that's a pretty tough career path um
whereas going into the computational
side of things you know you get to do a
lot of different things um
in a day and so you know when i was
first thinking about you know
evolutionary biology seriously as a
career path um
you know i looked at lots of
different things you know functional
traits studies um
you know ecolog kind of evolutionary
ecological studies
all sorts of stuff like that um
but then as
i started to think about kind of well
how do we integrate those things
together uh you know phylogenetics kind
of kept coming up as sort of the
organizing framework in which we study
the evolution of traits and organisms
and so i got interested in biogenetics
that way and then
you know the statistical problems that
we have
in phylogenetics are extremely difficult
uh and hard problems keep us in jobs and
hard problems are interesting and so
that's how i ended up here
nice well we're within a minute of our
official closing times instead of
potentially starting another question
that we can't answer and and working
into emanuel's time i'm just going to
thank you for a fascinating interesting
uh decision-making modeling and how it
all relates thank you so much for being
here today we really appreciate your
time
thank you for having me
you're welcome bye-bye
we all know this field is in constant
change and it's defined and pulled and
twisted and redefined and our next
speaker dr emmanuel ruiz will discuss
how omiks data is changing our molecular
applications dr ruiz was awarded a phd
in molecular and cellular biology
throughout the years she was confronted
with the need for computational biology
tools in order to answer biological
questions and she had to acquire an
expertise on bioinformatics
and biostatistics
dr ruiz can't wait to hear what you got
for us you're on stage
can you turn your video on by the way
i cannot hear you or see you dr ruiz
here we are
hello sorry there you are
let me try again
all right yeah
i can hear you fine and if you want to
go to slideshow mode that would be great
there we go
thank you good luck
thank you
my name is emmanuel ruiz and i am a
senior postdoc bioinformatician in the
veterinary school of louisiana state
university it's an honor today to
present my work experience from the
bench to the computer and how
bioinformatics with omix data have
drastically changed my career path
so i was born raised and got my
education in neon friends i completed my
phd in the cancer research center of
young and the main purpose of the
research project was to decipher the
interaction and the collaboration
between the epithelial muslin cable
transition regulators with oncogenic
stresses that lead to mammary
transformation
this research project was initially a
basic project with bench or in vitro
data that will have been validated in
animals models and with luck finally in
human subject
however as you will see in the next
slide very soon the bench results
obtained could not anymore be
interpreted or analyzed further with
basic molecular
or cellular biologicals
the goal was to
understand if and how
the emt transcription factors were
collaborating with oncogenic stresses to
transform non-cancer memory cells and
compare these new oncogenic abilities or
properties between these emts the
methodologies chosen has been a
screening
where the tense construction
transcription factors will be compared
in four unquestioning stresses
condition
the deletion of p10 of p53 the
overexpression of egfr or the
mutation mutational activation of
beta-carotene
that are all
unconcerning stress found in breast
cancer
so briefly the various contained the 10
transcription factor sequences were
produced and infected in mammary cells
that were already altered by an
oncogenic stress
the origin original mammary cell line
did not possess unconscionable
properties or transformative abilities
and adding this unconcerning stress was
not enough to make them conscious
the infected mammary cells were grown in
a soft agar plate that meaning the
transformation process
and only cancer cells or transformed
cells can grow in soft tiger
after several days clones were collected
and amplified rna were extracted and pcr
were run in order to identify which emt
tfs have been overexpressed in the
clones
in parallel
functional tests as softagar preparation
and regression essay was performed to
compare their oncogenic properties
initially we anticipated to analyze
clones that have maybe one or two
transcription factors overexpressed
however because of the screening we
obtain clones that contain from one to
six at seven transcription factors per
clone and furthermore the functional
tests were showing that this clause
presented a high diversity of
transformer proliferative and migration
properties
so a bigger picture of what was
originally so was building up and all
this information have to be computed and
analyzed
but how
and here's bioinformatics and
biostatistics were the keys
and so we collaborate with a
bioinformatician and we gave her this
simple excel spice that contains the
combination of the emt ts in the column
for each clone that are in the row and
for the different condition transformers
and non-transformers and for the
specific unquestioning stresses
we ask a specific question as we all the
time have to do when we talk with
bioinformatician one question at the
time which ents combination or signature
were the most associated with a specific
on cushioning stress she thought that a
base a tree based model classification
could help to answer our question
but at this time so like ten years ago
more or less
um the trees that we obtained didn't
make sense for me and i was quite
confused on how to use them in order to
answer this biolus biological question
so i decided to go deeper in the
classification
process and understand the different
steps of how they were build and
how we had these complete
trees
at this time i only have excels to help
me but i succeeded to find a meaning and
also
i succeed to create a new visualization
that computes the member of the emtf
that we see on the circle uh the color
circles
the emtf signature
and also that predicts the importance of
the rank inside this signature
and so finally also this visualization
could predict the ability to drive
mammary transformation represented by
the width
of the cycle
the triangles show that their
abilities depending only on their wrong
if there were not other
parameters
altering these transformativities and we
could see that we can see the
visualization that the first
uh emt tfs that have the strongest um
ability to predict that to
predict the transformation uh properties
of the cells uh will be on the on the
top of the triangle with the first on
the signature and the one that has the
less abilities will be on the bottom
however when we put them together we saw
that we had a different signature
according the transformers
also according the unconscioning stress
and also
inside the ginseng this emt signature
the transcription factors have an
importance that were different and so we
could
um identify specific emt nature
according the oncogening stress
this analysis was the beginning of
understanding the bigger picture of the
interaction and collaborations between
emtts in the context of a specific
encouraging stress during mammary
transformation
in parallel to this project
the years of my phd were also associated
with the emergence of transcriptomic
and genomic data online platforms it was
a decade now that the first human genome
had been sequenced
different institutes like the national
cancer institute
nci and the national human genome
research where joining force to propose
genomic
epigenomic transcriptomic protein and
also clinical data on cancer tissue with
the tcga
the cancer genome atlas also on cell
line with the cancer cell and
encyclopedia and all that for the
international research community with a
free access
the possibilities to validate and
understand the bigger picture of what
uh we obtain from our bench results we
are now within everyone rich even the
ones that didn't have any bioinformatics
expertise
my bioinformatic curiosity
already
initiated by my own project were fit by
my
boss
that wanted to use these new tools
and i took the challenge to learn how to
use them what i didn't know at this time
is i will fall in love and be addicted
to bioinformatics the bench was has
maybe most a lot of you know where we
can spend hundreds of hours trying to
accumulate results and dispose them of a
kind of puzzled pieces were not any more
very exciting for me
and i largely prefer to spend the same
amount of time resolving bioinformatic
puzzles so
as i say previously i was using excess
in at the first
tools and excel shown very quickly its
limits and i had to learn from scratch
real bioinformatics and biostatistics
software like r so i didn't take um
university
classes but uh already at this time and
more today
there are excellent tutorials online
that are free or not much expensive
and
forums where i cool and i continue to
ask the dumbest question without any
shame and
people are
very patient to answer them and so all
this the fruit of this effort lead me to
have different collaborations during my
phd and one of them
lead to a publication in nature medicine
so i was quite
[Music]
encouraged by that
so after that i left france
and worked as a postdoc fellow um in the
university school of medicine with dr
candie has api dr candie is an endocrine
surgeon specialized in tyrant cancer
and so my research work was strongly
driven by a clinical perspective it was
actually a very good training to never
forget that my research project even is
driven by a strong
curiosity
have all the time
to have in mind and that in the end
the research project have to help
patients
and so today i would like to share with
you
two projects that show
how much bioinformatics is a tremendous
help to answer a clinical and
translational questions and problematics
so the first project is relative to
cancer and aging
so cancers are aging disease
and so more we get older and more the
cancer incidence increases however the
link between aging and aggressive cancer
is not clearly defined except in one
type of cancer
thyroid cancer
thyroid cancer is the only concern where
clinicians have established star data's
prognosis marker using age as a markup
component because older patients older
than 55
have a higher risk of cancer-specific
deaths
however it is not the case for every
older thyroid cancer patient and it is
crucial
to identify which one which all patients
will present a high risk of poor outcome
and aggressive tumors
the new identified by prognosis marker
will assist clinician to establish
personalized and more accurate
therapeutic strategies
first for the height with patients with
more aggressive therapies
and also for the low-risk patient with
less aggressive therapies or active
surveillance where no surgery is
proposed but a regular control follow-up
will check the evolution of these
low-risk tumors
the active surveillance is a future of
thyroid cancer as a majority of these
cancers are low risk but consequencing
of surgery and treatment are high
so in order to
discover this biomarker we use the tcga
thyroid cancer and the gtech staring
normal tissue
and different expression gene expression
analysis were performed with a
dac2r package so using the r software in
order to select
which genes were the most significantly
differentiate the x-rate in this support
aggressive aging cancer population
so we perform different comparison
analysis
between
aging cancer with aging normal tissue
young cancer neuron normal tissue aging
normal and young normal tissue in order
to select to select specifically the
aging cancer gene
and we find 198
from this first selection
other the asia analysis were performed
comparing the clinical
and survival parameters and we filtered
the 190 egg genes
on 72 cancer aging specific but also
aggressive genes
as we focus on an aggressive phenotype
associated with the aging process the
same analysis but adjusting the
parameters with age were next performed
and the
72 were filtered as 48 cancer agent
specific
and aging dependent aggressive chains
finally has an
internal validation the same analysis
were performed only on the aging core to
be sure that this
the genes selected continue to be
associated with an aggressive phenotype
in this aging world and we finally
define
23 genes that are cancer agent specific
and engine dependent aggressive
for computing the expression value and
the beta coefficient of regression
analysis of these 23
genes were calculated
this core validated the strong
association of events there was a 23
gene signature with aggressive phenotype
and also with the poor outcome
the score powers to predict the
aggressive
to predict aggressive phenotype of this
poor outcome were estimated with a
receiver operative curve analysis the
interpretation of the curve is a
following the area under curve a you see
the closest is this to one and the
strongest the power the predictive power
to classify
is is and so as you can see on this
curve the 23 gag panel presented a very
strong auc superior to 0.7 from what of
the clinical parameter analyzed
hence
this 23 dsg signature predict aggressive
tumor
phenotype in the all tied cancer
patients
we went further and we compared this uh
2013 panel with abilities to disk
to us identify the
high-risk patient with
already standardized clinical markers
that are used in clinic today
and so um
we observed that actually the 23 dhg
panel presented a significant and
strongly strongest prediction that the
age system the hcc system when we were
predicting the overall survival but also
against the ata risk classification
that predict for recurrence with the
disease-free survival and
progression-free interval handsome
this 23-gene signature is a potential
prognosis marker for aging thyroid
carcinoma and also can be used
complementary to the standardized
prognosis markers
finally
for a principal component analysis and
here she sql clustering two subclusters
of this aging cancer population could be
identified the less aggressive engine
cluster and the more aggressive aging
cluster
so we have discovered a 23dg aging panel
that predicts which all patients will
present a poor outcome and aggressive
phenotype
validation in other databases and also
in human subjects
will be needed of course and of course
to conclude this panel may lead to a
more accurate personalized therapy and a
better understanding of how aging
aggravate cancer progression
so the second project that i want to
share with you is related to the cancer
process the resistance process after
bureau of inhibitor treatment in
melanoma patients
for more than 60 of melanoma and also in
thyroid cancer present a mutation of the
kinase p b raf the main mutation found
is the v600e
with the volume the 600 amino acid of
bira protein is replaced by glutamine
acid
the mutation leads to a change in the
protein conformation making the kinase
pocket being over-activated
the over-activated kinase leads to an
increase of proliferation and survival
of the mutated cells
and so create and drive um uh tumeric
genesis
the overactivated kinase yeah so drugs
were designed to be competitive
substrate especially of
uh on this mutated kinase and so under
buravi android 60e inhibitor treatment
melanoma shrinks and patient will be in
remission
however or unfortunately most of the
patients will relapse in the next 18
months after the end of the treatment
because cancer cells will have induced
resistant mechanism against specific
drugs
so it is crucial to discover new
biomarkers as a gene panel in order to
identify which patients have a high risk
of recurrence the new biomarker will
have clinician to adjust the therapeutic
strategy by proposing
a combination of treatment
with the biref inhibitors and drugs
preventing the resistance process or by
choosing another frontline therapy as a
immunotherapy
so the project began at the bench where
our team was looking to understand the
resistant mechanism after a derived
inhibitor treatment
because these mechanisms are quite still
unclear so we perform an in vitro
melanoma model of resistance
we use sorry an in vitro melanoma model
of resistance and we performed a
proteomic assay among more than the
active different proteins 18
were differentially expressed in the
resistance samples compared to the
sensitive one
next we were interesting to see how
these proteins were behaving in human
melanoma resistant models
in our knowledge they were not protein
data available online to answer our
question so we decided to look for
transcriptomic data in the gsc dataset
rep repository we found five data sets
of human melanoma samples that were
treated with brave inhibitors and
present resistance
we focus on the first the gac 1988
has a discovery panel and we validate
our results in the other data set
so first we checked
the differential expression of the 18
genes according to the resistance stage
and we saw that most were deregulated
but few presented a significant
difference
however when we run a principal
component analysis in order to estimate
the importance of the contribution of
the actin gene to explain the
heterogeneity observed across the
samples we saw that the acting gil could
significantly
differentiate the samples according to
the resistance stage
with the pink samples represent the
sensitive one and are in the left of the
plot whereas the blue samples that
represent the resistance
samples are the right of the plot
furthermore
the genes
presented a variety of correlation
as we see on the right plot but also a
variety of contribution to the pcr with
the red
one
having a high contribution
whereas the blue one having a
lower contribution
and so as we observed that all the 18g
didn't have the same contribution to the
resistance discrimination we decide to
filter them and select a signature that
presents the strongest predictive power
to stratify the sample the sample sorry
according to the resistance stage
to this aim we use the supervised
machine learning linear discriminant
analysis methodology for every
combination possible between the acting
genes so
26200
153 possibilities all these combinations
were tested and the criteria of
selection used was a rock analysis with
the estimation of the area under curve
of the auc
so the combination presenting the
highest auc
have been chosen it was a combination of
18 gene
and this exchanging signature presents a
discriminator
discriminatory strength of 0.98
as auc in the discovery data set linear
regressions and other statistical tests
shown strong significant p values and
other data sets used
has validation tests presented similar
results
finally a merge of the five data set in
order to obtain a data set that have a
height number of samples were built with
the computation of the corresponding
z-score for the individual previous data
sets and this merge shown also a very
strong discriminative power
to of this search engine signature to
predict resistance in human melanoma
samples
the rockers illustrate the table
the previous table with the six analysis
the five data set and the measures of
the the data set and we observed that
all of them have auc superior to 0.7 the
8 engine score
has previously for the actins
gene were also differentially expressed
according the resistance stage in all
the data sets
and through a pca we could see that the
acting gene explains the difference
observed across the samples because of
the resistance process
so we have
discovered a certain gag
resistant panels that predict which
melanoma patient will relapse after a
breath 600 600e inhibitor treatment has
previously said validation in other
dataset and human subjects are needed
to conclude for this project this
potential therapeutic
marker might help clinicians to
accurately establish a personalized
therapy this panel analysis will improve
the understanding of drug resistance
mechanism
and so today
i work full time as a bioinformatician
finnish
bench works
and i work at the vet school of lsu at
baton rouge with dr kusulas being part
of the
i am part of the lbrn has an assistant
director of the bioinformatics
biostatistic and computational
biological
and i will it will be my pla and i will
be
the leader between the lbr and community
and the pan biotech it will be my
pleasure my pleasure to collaborate and
help and mentor you for your
bioinformatics or biostatical needs
thank you
you're you're unmuted there grant
there we go thank you emmanuel we
appreciate all of that information um
we have learned so much from everybody
today and you're working in a changing
world with changing data structures and
it must be a huge challenge thank you
for delving deeper and giving us more
understanding in what you're doing i'm
going to ask you a few questions that
we've got in
and
i'm going to get you a start here what
are the challenges in bioinformatics in
relevance to personalized medicine
um
on my experience what i observed is
there is the the wish of clinician and
researcher is to find the most optimized
um
[Music]
signature marker that can be used for
that has problematic
however
bioinformatics
have a diverse diverse methodology to
answer this question
and there is no one that is better than
the other so the challenge for me was
how to choose the best methodology
and
[Music]
how to
to justify the why i have through this
methodology and not the other one
that was fun thank you a challenge that
you haven't resolved
what prepared you for this position and
what do you think other students might
learn and master as they embark on their
own bioinformatics analysis
what was the first part of the question
sorry
what prepared you for the position
uh what prepared me um
about i during all the years every time
i have a new
question a new necessity on
bioinformatics i have to learn it so um
it's a learning process
and
what prepared me for this position is uh
during this
my postdoc particularly i had the
opportunity to collaborate with
different persons
that
present me in the end dr kusulas and
i think the fact that
i have this background in
molecular biology in science research
where i understand the bench work i
understand the
molecular process that
we are trying to understand
it's
an advantage
to help
researcher a student to um
for a project because i have this
balance between the molecular biology
and biologic context but also
know which kind of bioinformatics tools
are available to try to answer
the different questions and furthermore
also when you have this balance it's
maybe easier also to ask a science
biological question
um i think sometimes um what i heard
when biopharmaceuticals were talking is
it's
difficult for them to have a clear
question of what they need to answer
with their tools
and so having this uh two
two expertise in a way help to have a
clear question to be ensured
very good thank you
so what do you think we have a lot of
students on our calls i know what do you
think students might want to learn and
master as they embark on their
bioinformatics analysis what what kind
of advice do you have
i think this will be interesting for
them to
at least maybe beginning to master um
[Music]
some
free software as maybe r that is very
easy the ones that i i use on very basic
statistics and bioinformatic tools has a
correlation analysis
that can be used for different um
field
on research
can be master beginning to understand
also a statistic
that can
can be used in very diverse
field and
are not very much specific for molecular
biology or immunology or zit or other
thing so yeah it can be
helpful to have a kind of basic
understanding of the
bioinformatics tools that
are available
very good thank you we're down under a
minute for our con this session so we're
going to go ahead and close this but
we're going to head towards our panel
so uh just hang in there if you would
while we gather our panelists again
um for those of you that are on the
panel if you could go ahead and join
back in we would be most grateful
i thought the the audience might be
interested in our statistics from our
two days i'm going to put this in chat
just so you can all kind of absorb
what we've had here
we have had more than 1000 users
registered for the event
eight speakers from india five different
speakers from africa and 14 from the
americas so man everybody's been
mentioning diversity here and there
that's a lot of diversity so uh we
really appreciate that um also we've got
um
one more reminder about the learn.com
watch
for your free learning portal account
it's free
sets you on a path to learning so if you
haven't done yet i'm going to put the
link back in chat one more time as we
head towards our panel and you can get
that before we close
over the last two days we've had amazing
presentations and today we covered
diverse topics from cancer forensics uh
space to beauty drug discovery to basin
hierarchical phylogenic trees
and what brings us all together is our
appreciation of the increasing role that
bioinformatics is playing in biomedical
research and the need for high quality
bioinformatics education mentorship and
opportunities for students to
participate in research so thank you all
for all of this and we want to thank our
speakers once again from today
we will be sharing the recorded sessions
on our youtube channel and since i seem
to be really good at plugging in links
to youtube or in all that er there is
the link to our postings that we will
have
and let's review our steam panel we have
dr april wright dr emmanuel ruiz and
elia brodsky who's stayed on with us and
panel we want to dig in on how students
this is all about the students how
students can learn about bioinformatics
and advance biomedical research across
the nepe regions so who wants to start
with tidy data and what it means to us
all
yeah i can start um
i think uh
i think there's often a lot of hesitance
to try and get students to do
any sort of bioinformatics or
computational research
um you know people think oh it's going
to be really hard the students aren't
going to understand it um
and you know i'm not saying that it's
going to be easy but i use r in my
introductory biology class and we do
some
you know basic linear regressions to do
things like understand organismal
scaling or
think about how mutations move in a
population
and
um
you know most students are game to try
things like that's that's what they're
really good at trying stuff um and so i
think
you know if we think it's important to
get students
involved in learning these sorts of
skills and to
get them to think quantitatively
consistently
you know we're the ones at the front of
the classroom um so
you know there's no one else who's gonna
do that if we're not gonna do that
okay fascinating thank you emmanuel
yeah um
yeah i think is uh
as a
student um
the possibility to to learn uh
the basic tools of bioinformatics uh i
think is a quite crucial and
interesting in a way that first i think
it will uh
houses that
illustrate all the theory that is
learned on stats on uh mathematics
statistics courses um in university and
it gives
a wide example of how what we learned in
classes can be used
and
be useful for um being
global global topics
and
i think it can help them
practice
this theory that they learned
and and and yeah we need to try i mean
uh
we need to to students mean it is easy i
mean it doesn't need um
a big brand to begin to learn
bioinformatics it's um as i say and with
the omniclogic
tutorials that help very much um it's
quite easy to learn with internet and
how to use the basic of bioinformatics
and
um with very
simple examples of how it can be useful
um
it's uh it's quite interesting to uh to
learn
sorry it's i think it's also very much
important because
more today we know with all this media
crazy stuff um learning bioinformatics
biostatistics help to see that all the
information maybe are not very
significant but we need some
tools to select what can be significant
and can be kept after so it's a kind of
also a kind of
mindset that he's learned to be more
um
[Music]
how to say that more
i don't know how to say that but um
[Laughter]
maurice i'd like to help you but i don't
want to put words in your mouth you
can't have like that i don't see it so
yeah
yeah more um
take a step back of what we think and
before to confirm and um
give a big conclusion on anything we can
use tools that have to say oh maybe not
it was not true it may be but in the end
it's not true so we have to be careful
and bioinformatics
help to teach this kind of mindset
okay elia i'm going to let you uh kind
of close that up if you want to say
anything more about it and then talk
about how students uh and in diversity
of experiences lead that off too well i
think here we have a great diversity of
experience right april was saying how
she did you know a degree in biology and
and then went on to journalism and ended
up doing what she's doing now so it's
it's the very non-linear path from you
know where you start where you end up
and we had a lot of
speakers that illustrate that i mean
people that
you know maybe started in a completely
unrelated space end up doing
bioinformatics now what does that mean
for students i wonder i wonder if
it is easier for them to see
how bioinformatics can be a useful and
not an intimidating
skill set if they are exposed to it
early on
and not necessarily only after they said
i will you know master bioinformatics
and become proficient at it right how
can they do that how can they just try
something small you know in us in an
elective course or maybe a mandatory
course but not with a high stakes you
know not like you either succeed or fail
you know there's a lot of in between and
um maybe another thing is
uh diversity from the perspective of
this um this kind of a community right i
think when you are
just like three people that do something
it's also very difficult right you've
got to see that there is a
greater population of people in in
different regions
in different universities at different
levels
that maybe use this in a variety of ways
so i think that it's very important to
bring that community together and let
students see each other and kind of
realize that you know it's not just one
single type of people that end up doing
this
and one of the things i've i've heard
over the last two days is how diverse
and how diverse the paths have been so
yeah april i'm sorry go ahead oh yeah i
was just gonna say i think one thing
that um
uh
is worth remembering is that
you know when it comes to who can see
themselves doing computation
you know almost every high school offers
biology
right
a much smaller proportion of schools are
going to offer
advanced mathematics
computer science these sorts of things
and so
i was writing a grant last year and i
came across this stat that you know 90
something percent of students who major
in computer science had it in high
school and i was like wow that's
incredible
and then i realized well probably 100 of
students who major in biology probably
had biology in high school right and so
if we restrict this sort of information
and this sort of training to people who
have already declared an interest in it
we're basically restricting this sort of
information and this sort of training by
zip code in a lot of places
uh and so i think yeah that integration
like elia mentioned in lower divisions
that integration and
coursework might not necessarily be you
know the bioinformatics course but it's
something that everybody has to take uh
i think it's probably a good a good
thing if we believe all students should
have access to these
skills any expansion on that emanuel
yeah
no i don't know but um yeah it's true
it's true that bioinformatic is so
diverse
that it will um
even for the undergraduate students that
uh still don't know exactly how they
want to
evolve in their career and how they want
to specialize they they will have tools
that can help them
um
very easily because bioinformatics have
it's it's a very very diverse and this
tools also can be used for other
the same tools can be used for other
[Music]
fields as finance business or other
other activities so uh it can be quite
very useful and
and yeah and we are
i imagine because it's a long time i
have been a student but
we tried to be in the top of
technologies and rhino biology uh
have been so is so high that uh
in the technology are very high tech and
so it should be very interesting for the
students to
to have an access about how
how
this
new biology are
because of bioinformatics
in part so it's um
it's yeah
so one of the things i could imagine
a student having a hard time asking
questions
and going beyond the guide direction and
going self-directed and coming up with
creative thinking if you don't know how
to ask questions how do you ask
questions can can you guys talk about
that a bit
helium
well i think that's kind of what's
missing in bioinformatics right
bioinformatics is almost viewed as this
like set of skills you know you're not a
code you know how to do this you know
that so if somebody gives you a coding
problem and they explain to you you know
this is what you need to do this is kind
of the result i'm looking for you know
it should look like this i think yeah
anyone can follow that it's much more
difficult i think for students
uh to feel
like they can't be creative and and kind
of thinking beyond those kinds of
instructions
and even sometimes spot what they are
finding you know what is interesting
about their finding because ultimately
as a student you know you do a lot of
digging right and a lot of digging and
reworking your problems is because you
don't get them right
but
as sometimes you kind of stumble upon
something that is interesting right and
and then sometimes your expectation
might be well you know maybe that was
another mistake
but it's not always like that right and
so you have to almost have um that
anticipation that every once in a while
you know you're going to stumble across
something that is interesting and when
you do you need to have i think
a good um way to
explain what it is communicate it to
somebody who's more experienced than you
and have that discussion of equals
almost you know like this is what i see
in data what do you see you know how is
this like the correct way to interpret
that so i think that's a skill that
you cannot master by you know reading a
textbook you almost have to uh be
mentored be shown an example that yes we
all make mistakes we all stumble across
interesting findings and that's what
papers are is like we found an
interesting finding now let's try to
describe it and validate that it's a
real thing
that's interesting that you mentioned
the aspect of digging because
you know
one of the things i feel like we teach
kind of poorly is
how to
read scientific literature
right how to pick up the narrative and
how to understand it and
um
so i do some domain-based education
research and i have
um you know one class where we're
looking at kind of more straight lecture
versus if we incorporate more like
learning how to read a scientific paper
and then doing sort of socratic method
uh
discussions and i'm i'm really
interested to see how these data come
out um
because i feel like
you know one of the most common things
that i see in students is not that
they're they come into research and they
want to do things and it's not that
they're not bright or they're not
um
you know intelligent people it's that
they stumble with the independence
right and it's like you learn to be a
good writer by reading a lot
right but
when you learn to be a good scientist
you do that by sciencing a lot but
how do you do that in the undergraduate
curriculum in a way that um
you know we're constantly shuffling them
around right you're going to chem lab
and you're not a chemist so you have a
lot of instructions if you're not
a physicist you have a physics lab and a
lot of instructions and
uh there's not a lot of room for
independent exploration in a lot of
these and so in you know
having them read the literature and see
how other people have done independent
exploration i think i think is really
important that's a good point
so elia you kind of talked about
something about
um in the classroom and stuff like that
how much of that stuff
how much of responsibility do we put on
a mentor or a teacher to make sure a
student understands it's okay to be
wrong it's okay to walk down the wrong
path it's okay to ask questions
well i i'm just going to incorporate
this message that i just see in chat
from dr amitabh jayaswal who's saying
as a bioinformatics learner my
difficulty is that i find it hard to
understand concepts of computer science
and statistics although i understand
biology fairly well but those things
instill
loss of confidence and consequently
productivity also when i approach some
professors or practitioners of the
subject even they don't truly appreciate
the depths doing a series of clickable
of clicks or following an algorithm does
not impart real understanding hold so
this disenchant so
i i guess what you know this message
means to me is that
whether
i mean uh dr jay small here is not a
student right he's already an
established maybe a researcher and
learning bioinformatics so i think if
you go into any new domain
you're going to be following somebody
else who's saying you know this is
pretty much the formula of how you get
from a to b right and i want you to be a
b and that b something else happens
right you get a degree uh now you know
we call you a doctor or whatever it
might be right so i think this kind of a
view of uh what you know research if you
want to be in research that's kind of
like a parallel uh world that you're
living in because in research one of the
more important things is getting to a
point where you know you stop relying as
much on other people that tell you this
is how you do things because otherwise
you find it difficult to kind of get
away from established truths which is
what you know you're going to end up
challenging in in most of your research
so i think that you know
it's it's something that is much more
advanced
in the west than maybe in some other
more traditional um you know systems of
education so so that does exist on the
other hand i think that the effort to
get people faster to this higher level
where they can become more independent
could have this downside that you know
people view this as
restrictive so you know i think that's
where you have to kind of
leverage the abundance of resources that
are available to you know skill uh you
know understand ask questions about how
things work and get to that point but
you know it's not something that i think
you can get from that formal education
the goal of formal education is probably
not that
something that i realize on my own
experience is sometimes
you don't have reserves or you have
results that you
are not able to explain that can be in
biology but also in bioinformatics is
but it's not because they are wrong it
just maybe they are largely more complex
about what we saw initially and so we
need maybe more time or maybe someone
else at one point will find we
understand it and so you need to be to
lower a bit the pressure of the of the
results and say okay
maybe it's more complex than what i saw
but it's not
wrong per se
is that something that can help and not
be completely discouraged in the in the
research world
anything to add april
no i have to run and get my kids from
school though so thank you for having me
it was really nice well thank you for
being here yet again
so uh nice to meet you uh emmanuel as
well nice to meet you too
thank you emmanuel and elia what's uh
coding in r and python computational
training are those going together how
important are those things i've heard
those names throughout the last two days
i guess i want to also ask you know what
emanuel thinks about it i started
learning r first and i really thought
you know this is so great you know you
can just produce these charts
right away they look nice you know you
can just put them in publications it was
really kind of like an exciting simple
way to get quickly to meaningful results
in python i mean just using matplotlib
with all the loops and trying to get
your chart to you know display different
colors and annotations and that was such
a pain
until i realized that python maybe is
much easier in fact to use in other
domains like machine learning for
example i find it very easy and kind of
intuitive the way that those packages
have been built so i think that there
are benefits to you know either r or
python in different applications but it
is dependent on kind of where you see
yourself going like if all you need from
are
is to get that plot and everybody's
using that complex heat map to you know
produce that nice figure
maybe that's enough but if you are
trying to go much further beyond that
build your own application you know
start kind of working with other types
of um repositories here and there you
know that's i think where you have to
know enough of both to
not be afraid and to also be able to
kind of you know specialize eventually
down the road but you know i would be
interested to know what emanuel thinks
about that
but me it's simple i'm still not in
python
i am uh in r i
imagine i am familiar with r and i still
um
haven't find on my application the
limits of r where i couldn't use r
but um
yeah so for me i was a
simple
i would say that i found the tutorials
that let me uh understand are in a
simple way and going step by step
and so
it's very useful as you say for um
for plots for
simple analysis and um
like that in my head to be honest i
don't see publications that show
python but most of them
show that they have done their analysis
with r
so
i think it's very useful
but
as you say we don't have to be close on
one software but see how
others can be also helpful and with the
homicologic tutorials i'm gonna begin to
learn
python
but
new language i didn't initially i didn't
want to do both at the same time even if
a bioinformatician told me you need it
but i was a bit afraid that if i learn
both at the same time i will mix them
and i will don't succeed to to improve
my skills so i i stay on r
yeah nice nice so let's let's switch a
little bit of this over to the social
and emotional aspect of research
especially as it applies to students now
i've heard in my world here how many
people throughout the last two days have
stumbled onto something that became
important in their lives
but how much impact do students have
into research and then what happens in
our world
um you know i understand this topic to
be
extremely important from the aspect of
research being very discouraging
sometimes right so i think that research
is a very long
game it's not something that you achieve
results quickly and it's something that
you're going to fail a lot more than
maybe if your goal was you know much
less ambitious so so it's definitely for
people that have the perseverance and
the emotional
uh strength i would say our ability to
you know disconnect from their emotions
to go over uh you know overcome those
challenges so i think that's one part of
it the social part of it is that
being a scientist you you know you wish
you were the person on tedx talks you
know
discovering uh you know uh things that
change the world but most of the time
you're not right so most of the time
you're kind of behind the scenes in your
pis who's out there talking about the
discoveries made in the lab so
i think that you know uh if you um
if you choose this area of research and
i think that's where bioinformatics
actually
is going through sort of a
transformation you know i
uh my father is a bioinformatician and
has been for you know decades and so he
was always
um the one providing data to people who
went on the stage and you know talked
about the discoveries and i kind of saw
this disconnect between the hard effort
that he was putting into his analysis
work and whatever the biologist was then
presenting
i think today that is becoming much more
balanced
bioinformaticians there was an article a
few years ago
that bioinformaticians can finally be in
the driving seat you know
i think that
uh is a little bit of a change and an
encouraging change for those that have
chosen bioinformatics as their science
yeah i agree with you that the better
best quality of researchers are
perseverance
uh because that's you you will need it i
mean because
it's maybe less in bioinformatics
maybe more on bench work
but
you spend most of your time having
negative results before to have one
positive results and it's not something
that is easy to manage so you need to
have perseverance
and um
so
i
think there is one thing that a skill
that needs to be learned
and it's long process because it's more
a kind of a
routine to know how to separate uh your
professional life to your personal life
because research doesn't have end
and it's like when we do a big puzzle we
don't want to stop until it's finished
but at one point we need to have also a
healthy life and a healthy
separation between what is research our
professional life and personal and that
i think honestly is the skills that need
to be learned
because it's not easy it's not
innate and more when we are students and
we are working for pi of a
phd postdoc when we are working for
people that put us a pressure
it's
because they have their own pressure
okay it's not easy for them to uh it's
difficult to put this um separation and
then maybe uh
learning this this these two skills
perseverance and
separate uh
professional to personal life
is very helpful to have a
success in research
and
yeah i think that as you say
not every researcher will have a nobel
prize
but uh it gives us a kind of humility
and a kind of
encouragement to know that
uh for a nobel prize there were maybe
thousands of manuscripts that this
number schwab have read
try to understand a use to his own
project that have this reward so in a
way
all work participate to the world
science evolution and that is a it's a
beautiful feeling
fascinating so you guys touched on
something and i want to i want to kind
of go back to it
for students and doing all this research
is there an issue with expectation a
result and i think you kind of walked
around a bit hit it a little harder
because i'm a new student i know i'm
gonna find this and then it's not even
close
well i think actually uh one of the
speakers dr paulson mentioned that they
involve students
it's almost like as a pi you have to
have this you know maybe decades or
years long project and if you are able
to involve students at different stages
of this project
you end up sharing these exciting
milestones with them that they feel like
they've gotten to a result so it is a
lot of it is about mentorship with an
intent to offer students
not squeeze work out of them but allow
them to get into the field and feel like
they are contributing something
meaningful right so like for example in
my experience i've had a number of very
established
pis that have included me in
publications that you know i i honestly
did not contribute maybe that much but
the fact that you know my my name ended
up on that publication
you know gave you like you know ah you
know we published in nature
you know whatever my contribution was
but you know that was a very empowering
uh feeling for me
i understand i understand it's uh yeah
we have similar experience yeah where we
are
where we work hard i know my phd i mean
uh
my
principal project have not been yet
privileged so it was quite hard because
when we spent four years working on it
and by discovering new truths by
yourself i mean it was quite hard but um
but uh what what i have done even if the
it didn't get published as uh
we wanted it helped other teams to build
their own pro their project and um and
so uh
driving um
and discovering more about
their
science and
in the breast cancer at this time so
yeah it's it's um
it's frustrating i mean research is
frustrating it's not uh you you don't
have to be blind and go there saying oh
it's a happy place it's a it's a
frustrating work but um
but um
yeah
knowing that um
even and directly we participate to this
knowledge evolution help to uh
to overcome these frustrations
and um and so to put the pressure lower
because um
unfortunately the success of researchers
are very dependent of what they
privileged and so when you work years uh
or months or years on projects that uh
in the end but you didn't see any
publication is quite hard but um there
is other indirect way to uh to have
encouragement so it's uh it's nice to
remember that yeah very good well thank
you all we are wrapping our time here as
it comes to an end
thank you all uh especially uh elia and
dr emmanuel for sticking around this
afternoon and answering some questions
especially as students because i've seen
a lot of student questions in chat over
the last two days so thank you all to
those of you in the audience please
engage with us i posted our social links
a little bit ago and if you can comment
and share there that would really help
our mission and of course go sign up for
your free account
that wraps up our two days of
international worldwide learning uh i'm
just stunned by the level of
intelligence and integrity with all the
researchers and speakers
thank you all thank you again emmanuel
and elia and that wraps us up so thank
you all so very much